GOOD MORNING WE WILL- BEGAN
TODAY'S HEARING THIS MORNING-
THIS IS THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE NUMBER- TWO ON
EDUCATION FINANCE THIS IS A
SPECIAL INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
ON HIGHER EDUCATION AND STUDENT
HOUSING AN IMPORTANT TOPIC FOR
CALIFORNIA'S WE DEAL WITH OUR
HOUSING- CRISIS AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AND STUDENT- AFFORDABILITY AS
FAR AS THE COST OF COLLEGE AND
WE KNOW THAT. THE SKY HIGH
RENTS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
SQUEEZING A LOT OF PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY OUR STUDENTS- A VERY
CUTE AS ARE IN THE METROPOLITAN
AREAS. WITH WE HAVE- UC AND CSU
CAMPUSES WERE AVERAGE TWO
BEDROOM APARTMENT RENTS ARE
MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
A MONTH AND IT'S NO WONDER WHY-
WE LOOK AT THE COST OF COLLEGE
AND HIGHER EDUCATION. ABOUT
HALF OF IT IS RELATED TO
HOUSING THESE NON TUITION COSTS
ARE ARE. OUR KEY TO COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY. AND WE KNOW THIS
IS A KEY ISSUE NOT ONLY FOR ONE
FOR STUDENTS TO DO WELL WITH
THE STUDENTS WHO LIVE NEAR
CAMPUS RESEARCH SHOWS ARE MORE
LIKELY. TO DO BETTER AND
GRADUATE WITHIN FOUR YEARS- WHO
WOULD TURN OFF MY- PHONE I HEAR
MUSIC FROM THE BACKGROUND NOT
SURE WHAT'S GOING ON HERE- AND-
IN ADDITION. THAT WE KNOW THAT.
MANY OF THE CAMPUSES ARE
COVETED AT CAMPUSES THROUGHOUT
THE DAY CSU AND UC SYSTEM
ESPECIALLY THE UC SYSTEM. ARE
FACED WITH COMMUNITY SAYING HEY
IF YOU WANT TO GROW WHICH IS A
TOP PRIORITY OF US THIS YEAR WE
FUNDED A RECORD NUMBER OF SLOTS
TO EXPAND- YOU SEE. SOME THESE
CAMPUSES THAT COMMUNITIES ARE
LITERALLY SUING SAYING HEY IF
YOU WANT TO GROW NEED TO BUILD
MORE HOUSING SO THESE TWO
THINGS. ARE VERY VERY RELATED-
IS A PRIORITY OF US LAST YEAR
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION TO
CREATE A FUND A REVOLVING FUND.
WHICH YOU KNOW THE ONLY ELSE
TALKS ABOUT WE DID YEARS AGO TO
FUND HIGHER EDUCATION THAT
MORPHED INTO AN APPROPRIATION
THE BUDGET. OF ABOUT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT.
THREE YEARS- DEFINED HIGHER
EDUCATION AND HEALTH HELP
CAMPUSES EXPAND. OF HIGHER
EDUCATION HOUSING. BECAUSE
HOUSING- SO THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT BEST
PRACTICES- WHAT THE ISSUES ARE
AND WHAT WE CAN DO GOING
FORWARD TO HELP. IN THIS FRONT
SO WE'LL HAVE. A FEW MEMBERS IN
PRESENT IN REMOTELY TODAY- YOU
WANT TO SAY THANK FORMER. RACE
YOU READY TO GO. OKAY THANK YOU
MR AND CHAIR- I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR. THE SPACE HEARING- TO
US TODAY. I THINK I'M REALLY.
BY THE ILLEGALS. RESEARCHER
RECOMMENDATIONS. ON THE REPORT
THAT THEY PROVIDED ON THE
QUANTITY AND AFFORDABILITY SOON
HOUSING CALIFORNIA. I'M VERY
PROUD OF. IN SAMBAR DINO IS AS
I'VE MENTIONED TO YOU BEFORE
SUMMER MEDINA VALLEY COLLEGE.
IS LOOKING AT THE VERY SUBJECT
OF HOUSING FOR OUR- FOR OUR
STUDENTS- WE KNOW THAT THAT THE
HOMELESS THE FOSTER FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH- THE-
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS ARE THE
ONES WHO SUFFER THE MOST
THROUGH. NOT HAVING HOUSING
SECURITY SO THIS IS A VERY
TIMELY SUBJECT TONIGHT THANK
YOU AND THE PANELISTS. FOR THIS
INFORMATION. THANK YOU AMERICA
JOINED BY OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
SHARE MR MEDINA I KNOW. GOES
AROUND THE STATE VISITING
CHANCELLORS AND COLLEGE
PRESIDENTS AND- I'M SURE
THEY'RE ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT
HOUSING RIGHT MR MEDINA THEY
CERTAINLY ARE SO THANK YOU-
CHAIR MCCARTY FOR PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER THIS PANEL. HEARING
TOGETHER. AND YES EVERY TIME I
GO. WHETHER IT IS- VISITING
WITH THE. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PRESIDENT. OR EIGHT YOU SEE.
PRESS OR CSU- HOUSE ALWAYS
COMES UP- UC RIVERSIDE WHERE I
REPRESENT- ALSO FACES THE SAME
CHALLENGES. THAT I THINK- ALL
OF THEM ARE- INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER LEARNING THEIR FACES AND
THAT IS A SHORTAGE OF HOUSING
FOR STUDENTS SO IT LOOK FORWARD
TO- LEARNING MORE AND- TAKING
ON SOME OF THESE CHALLENGES IN
THE NEXT LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
YES OKAY SO WITH THAT-
DISCONTENT- HOUSEKEEPING I WE
HAVE A WITNESSES TESTIFYING
TODAY IN PERSON AND USING OUR
WEB BACKS SYSTEM WE ALSO WILL
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT AVAILABLE
AT THE END OF THE HEARING AS
WELL AS HERE IN- THROUGH FORTY
TWO A TWO- THAT THE CALL IN
NUMBERS ON THE AGENDA BUT IF
YOU DON'T HAVE IT'S.
1-877-692-8957. 1-877-692-8957
ACCESS ONE THREE ONE FIFTY FOUR
TO A TWO. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO ZERO TWO SO WE'LL
START OUT BY HEARING FROM OUR
L. A. L. WHO DID IT HAS MISSED
REYES SAID A NICE- RIGHT HALF
OF THE ISSUE AND SOME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CALIFORNIA
THEN SOME A SYSTEM WIDE
PERSPECTIVES AND LASTLY WE'LL
HEAR FROM SOME CAMPUSES WHO ARE
FOCUSING THIS ON THE GROUND AND
SEE TO SOME CAMPUSES I KNOW
THAT HIGHER EDUCATION SHERMAN
DEAN AND I HAVE TALKED TO IN
PERSON ABOUT THESE ISSUES SO I
WITH THAT WE WILL ASK OUR L. A.
L. TO COME UP IN. START STOP.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER PATEL
LET'S JUST AND ALL OFFICE. AND
SO WE WORK- OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL WEEKS. I HAD TO GATHER
INFORMATION ON THE TOPIC OF
STUDENT HOUSING WE SUBMITTED
WRITTEN INFORMATION REQUEST TO
THE THREE SYSTEM OFFICE SAYS.
MATT WITH THOSE OFFICES TO
DISCUSS THEIR PROGRAMS. THAT
WITH THREE UC CAMPUSES IRVINE
MERCED AND SANTA CRUZ. MET WITH
FOR CSU CAMPUSES- EAST BAY
HUMBOLDT LONG BEACH AND
MONTEREY BAY AND WE CONNECTED
WITH EXPERTS ON STUDENT HOUSING
PROGRAMS AND OTHER STATES. I
WANTED TO JUST THINK REALLY
QUICKLY ALL OF THOSE WHO WORKED
FOR AT WITH US THE SYSTEM
OFFICES THE CAMPUSES COMMITTEE
STAFF THE ADMINISTRATION THEY
ALL GIVE US INFORMATION IN THE
PROCESS OF COMPILING A HAND
OUT. SO THEY END UP SHARES WHAT
WE LEARNED- SIR IS THE
HIGHLIGHT SO DIVING RIGHT IN ON
THE FIRST PAGE WE FOCUS FIRST
ON THE ROLE OF THE STATE AND
HOW IT'S HANGED OVER TIME. HIS
STAR THE ROLE OF THE STATE HAS
BEEN SMALL STUDENT HOUSING
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN FUNDED WITH
STUDENT CHARGES. THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN SUBSIDIZED BY THE STATE.
THIS IS STILL THE CASE ACROSS
MOST OF THE COUNTRY. WE FOUND
FOR STATES THAT EXPLICITLY
PROHIBIT STATE FUNDING FROM
BEING USED FOR STATE FUNDING.
WE DIDN'T FIND ANOTHER STATE
THAT SUBSIDIZES STUDENT HOUSING.
IN THE LATE EIGHTIES IN
CALIFORNIA THE STATE DID
PROVIDE A SMALL AMOUNT OF ONE
TIME FUNDING TO CREATE A
REVOLVING LOAN FUNDS THAT WOULD
HELP CSU CAMPUSES. ADD HOUSING-
AT LOW BORROWING COSTS. SO THEN
JUMPING FORWARD A FEW DECADES
THE STATE ROLE VERY RECENTLY
HAS EXPANDED SO AS YOU PROBABLY
KNOW IS PART OF THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET ACT THE
STATE PROVIDED. ONGOING FUNDING
FOR RAPID RE HOUSING PROGRAMS
AND THEN AS PART OF THE MOST
RECENT BUDGET AGREEMENT THE
STATE PROVIDED TWO BILLION FOR
STUDENT HOUSING PROJECTS. AS
YOU PROBABLY KNOW THAT MONEY IS
SPREAD ACROSS THREE YEARS FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND THEN SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION THE NEXT
TWO YEARS. OF THE TOTAL
ALLOTMENT THE FUNDS ARE SPREAD
ACROSS THE THREE SEGMENTS WITH
50% ALLOTTED TO THE COLLEGES
30% TO CSU AND 20% TO UC. AND
THEN OF THE COLLEGE ALLOTMENT
SPECIFICALLY TWENTY FIVE
MILLION AS RESERVE FOR PLANNING
GRANTS. COLLEGES TO- GET THESE
GRANTS CAN USE IT EITHER TO
BUILD NEW HOUSING OR TO CONVERT
COMMERCIAL SPACE AND TO HOUSING.
THE NEW PROGRAM HAS TWO MAIN
GOALS- THE CHAIR ALREADY
REFERENCED THIS IN HIS OPENING
REMARKS ONE GOAL IS CAPACITY
JUST INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
BEDS WITH THE PRIMARY GOAL OF
HELPING TO ACCOMMODATE FUTURE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH. AND THEN THE
OTHER GOAL IS TO MAKE THAT
HOUSING AFFORDABLE PARTICULARLY
FOR LOWER INCOME STUDENTS.
ALTHOUGH THE STATE CREATED THIS
NEW PROGRAM THERE ARE NO
SPECIFIC CAPACITY GOALS THAT
THE STATE WANTS TO FUND AN EX
NUMBER OF BEDS OR ACTS- SHARE
OF THE UNDERGRADUATE POPULATION.
STATE LAW DOES HAVE A FEW
PROVISIONS RELATING TO HOUSING
SO IT ALLOWS CAMPUSES TO OFFER
HOUSING IT ALLOWS CAMPUSES TO
REQUIRE STUDENTS TO LIVE IN
THAT HOUSING. AND OF CAMPUSES
DON'T HAVE HOUSING THEN THERE
TO GIVE HIGHEST PRIORITY FOR
BEDS TO HOMELESS YOUTH AND
FOSTER YOUTH. NONE OF THE
SEGMENTS THE GOVERNING BOARDS
OR THE SYSTEM OFFICES HAVE
UNIFORM CAPACITY GOALS THAT
APPLY TO ALL CAMPUSES THE
CAMPUS IS THAT THEIR OWN
CAPACITY GOALS. MANY CAMPUSES
ONE HOUSE ALL INTERESTED FIRST
YEAR STUDENTS SOME ALSO TRIED
TO HOUSE INTERESTED SECOND YEAR
STUDENTS. IN ADDITION TO GOALS
AROUND UNDERGRADUATE CAPACITY
CAMPUSES OFTEN HAVE GOALS TO
HOUSE THAT SPECIFIC SHARE OF
GRADUATE STUDENTS AND STUDENTS
WITH FAMILIES. UNSURPRISINGLY A
CAMPUS'S STUDENT BODY HAS A BIG
IMPACT ON THE SIZE OF ITS
HOUSING PROGRAM SO CAMPUS IS
THAT HAVE A HIGH SHARE OF
STUDENTS COMMUTING AND LIVING
LOCALLY THEY TEND TO HAVE
EITHER NO HOUSING PROGRAM OR A
SMALL PROGRAM. THOSE CAMPUSES
WITH A HIGH SHARE OF NON LOCAL
STUDENTS THOSE AT CAMPUSES THAT
ARE DRAWING STUDENTS FROM ALL
OVER THE STATE WHERE STUDENTS
ARE MOVING INTO THE AREA TO
ATTEND COLLEGE THEY HAVE MUCH
LARGER PROGRAMS. PAGE THREE OF
THE HANDOUT SHOWS THE AMOUNT OF
CAPACITY ADDED SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN. BOTH SEGMENTS UC AND
CSU HAVE ADDED SUBSTANTIAL
HOUSING CENTS TWENTY FIFTEEN
CSU REPORTS ADDING A MORE THAN
FOURTEEN THOUSAND BEDS THROUGH
TWENTY EIGHT PROJECTS YOU SEE-
HAS REPORTED ADDING ALMOST
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND BEDS AT
TWENTY THREE CAMPUS PROJECTS.
AND SO IN ADDITION TO THOSE BUT
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
CONSTRUCTED OR LAST FIVE SIX
YEARS THEY'RE ALSO BOTH
SEGMENTS IN THE PROCESS OF
CONSTRUCTING MORE SEE ISSUES IN
THE PROCESS OF CONSTRUCTING
TWENTY THREE HUNDRED MORE THREE
SIX PROJECTS AND YOU SEE IS IN
THE PROCESS OF CONSTRUCTING.
ABOUT NINETEEN THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL BEDS THREE TWENTY
ONE PROJECTS. FOR PROVIDE SOME
MORE DATA ON THIS SO YOU CAN
SEE THAT YOU SEE EVERY CAMPUS
HAS ADDED SOME BAD SINCE TWENTY
FIFTEEN. SANTA CRUZ HAS ADDED
THE FEW ESTIMATE NUMBER OF BEDS
BUT I WOULD NOT THERE IN THE
MIDST OF A PROJECT THAT PROJECT
IS ADDRESSING SOME
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES AT THE
MOMENT I THINK YOU MIGHT HEAR
MORE ABOUT THAT PROJECT LATER
TODAY. AT CSU ABOUT HALF THE
CAMPUSES HAVE ADDED BEDS ARE
LAST FIVE SIX YEARS SAN DIEGO
SAN LUIS OBISPO SAN FRANCISCO
HAVE ADDED THE HIGHEST NUMBER
OF NEW BALANCE. PAGE FIVE THE
FIGURE AT THE TOP SHOWS HOW
BEDS HAVE INCREASED IN TANDEM
WITH ENROLLMENT GROW SO IT
TRIES TO COMPARE WHETHER THE
INCREASE AND BEDS HAS KEPT PACE
WITH AN ROAMING GROWTH. AND
HOUSING CAPACITY HAS SLIGHTLY
OUTPACED AT AT EACH SEGMENT.
I'M SO WHAT YOU SEE IT'S GONE
UP LESS THAN ONE PERCENTAGE
POINT- THE BUT IT HAS GONE UP
SO THE NUMBER OF BEDS HAVE HAS
INCREASED ABOUT 15% OVER THIS
PERIOD WHILE ENROLLMENT GROWTH
INCREASED FOURTEEN PERCENT.
THAT'S THE ISSUE THE- INCREASES
A BIT MORE NOTABLE ITS NUMBER
THE IT SHARE OF BAD HAVE
INCREASED EIGHTEEN PERCENT.
WELL IT SAN ROMAN INCREASED TWO
POINT 3% SO THAT PROBABLY
SOUNDS LOW TO YOU BECAUSE CSU'S
UNDERGRADUATE RESIDENT
ENROLLMENT HAS GONE UP MUCH
MORE THAN TWO POINT 3% BUT IT'S
BEEN OFFSET BY REDUCTIONS IN
GRADUATE ENROLLMENT AND
NONRESIDENT ENROLLMENT. TURNING
TO THE COLLEGES FOR A MOMENT
PRIOR TO TWENTY NINETEEN THERE
WERE ELEVEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THAT HAD HOUSING PROGRAMS
ALMOST ALL OF THESE WERE IN
RURAL AREAS. AND ALMOST ALL OF
THEM ARE LONG STANDING. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
ORANGE COAST COLLEGE OPENED A
STUDENT HOUSING FACILITY AND
IT'S THE LARGEST FACILITY
AMONGST THE COLLEGES RIGHT NOW
EIGHT HUNDRED BAGS THAT'S FOUR
TIMES LARGER THAN ANY OTHER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE HOUSING
PROGRAM- AS ITS ACCOUNTING FOR
ABOUT ONE THIRD OF ALL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BEDS RIGHT
NOW. SO I'M. WE ALSO LOOKED AT
HOW DOES THE CAMPUS FIGURE OUT
WHETHER THERE IS A ON DEMAND
STUDENT DEMAND. AND WE FOUND
THAT CAMPUS IS THEY USE A
SIMILAR PRODUCT PROCESS SO
EVERY YEAR THEY'RE LOOKING AT
THEIR ON CAMPUS OCCUPANCY
RATES. AT WAIT LISTS FOR THEIR
ON CAMPUS HOUSING AND NOT
VACANCY RATES WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY. AND IF THEIR WEIGHT
UNSURPRISINGLY IF THEIR WAIT
LISTS ARE LONG THERE VACANCY
RATES IN THE AREA ARE VERY LOW
AND THEIR HEART CAMPUS HOUSING
GOALS AREN'T BEING MET. THEN
THEY INITIATE A MORE INTENSIVE
STUDENT HOUSING STUDY TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE IS THE UNMET
DEMANDS HOW DO THEY BUILD
ACCORDINGLY. SO THE SURVEY
STUDENTS TYPICALLY AND
UNDERTAKE A MUCH FULLER
ANALYSIS OF THE LOCAL HOUSING
MARKET. I KNOW THAT THERE ARE A
FEW UC CAMPUSES THAT HAVE AMMO
USE WITH THEIR COMMUNITIES SUCH
THAT IF THEY INCREASE
ENROLLMENT GROWTH THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO INCREASE THEIR
BADS. UC DAVIS AND UC SANTA
CRUZ FALL IN THIS CATEGORY YOU
MIGHT ALSO HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT
LATER TODAY. WE LOOK WAIT LESS-
BUT THE FALL TWENTY TWENTY AND
FALL TWENTY TWENTY ONE BECAUSE
OF CODE MIGHT NOT BE THE BEST
DATA FOR YOU IT MIGHT BE
SLIGHTLY ANOMALOUS. BUT NONE
THE LESS THAT DATE AS REPORTED
HERE FOR TALK FALL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. CSU HAD WAIT LISTS
AT THIRTEEN CAMPUS AS TOTALING
ABOUT EIGHTY SEVEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS. AND THAT YOU SEE
EIGHT CAMPUSES HAD WAIT LISTS
TOTALING SLIGHTLY MORE THAN
SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS.
THE TO UC CAMPUSES THAT DIDN'T
HAVE WAIT LISTS FOR UC SAN
FRANCISCO IT ACTUALLY REPORTED
A 20% VACANCY RATE RIGHT BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC IT BROUGHT A
HOUSING STRUCTURE ONLINE. AND
IN SAN FRANCISCO STILL DEALING
WITH SOME LINGERING EFFECTS OF
THE DESTRUCTION OF COALBED. I'M
AND THEN SANTA CRUZ REPORTED
THAT ALTHOUGH IT MAINTAINS
WEIGHTLESS TYPICALLY BY THE
TIME THING SHUFFLE OUT IT ENDS
UP WITH A SMALL NUMBER OF
VACANCIES AND AT ON CAMPUS
HOUSING PROGRAM. SO IN ADDITION
TO THE BEDS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN BILL AND THAT ARE IN THE
MIDST OF CONSTRUCTION AS WE
SPEAK BOTH SEGMENTS HAVE PLANS
TO BUILD MORE. CSU WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THEIR OUT YOUR PLANS
THEY HAVE SEVENTEEN HOUSING
PROJECTS NOW UNDER DEVELOPMENT
AT ELEVEN CAMPUSES WHAT AT
ABOUT ELEVEN THOUSAND ADDS. AND
THEN YOU SEE HAS ELEVEN.
HOUSING PROJECTS UNDER
DEVELOPMENT SIX CAMPUSES ADDING
MORE THAN SIXTEEN THOUSAND BEDS.
SO SHIFTING FOR JUST A MOMENT
FROM CAPACITY TO AFFORDABILITY.
CAMPUS IS AS YOU KNOW THEY
SACKED THEIR STUDENT HOUSING
CHARGES EVERY YEAR AND THEY
HAVE TWO MAIN GOALS OF TRYING
TO COVER THAT PROGRAMS
OPERATING COSTS AND ANNUAL DEBT
SERVICE COSTS WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME HAVING A CHARGE THAT
STUDENTS CAN AFFORD- IDEALLY
THAT'S BELOW WHAT THE MARKET IS
CHARGING IN THEIR AREA. LIVING
ARRANGEMENTS WILL AFFECT THAT
CHARGE SO CAMPUS IS TYPICALLY
HAVE A RIGHTY OF TYPES OF
HOUSING OPTIONS FROM SINGLE TO
DOUBLE TO TRIPLE ROOMS TO THAT
SHARE A COMMUNAL BATHROOM ON
ONE FLOOR. TWO APARTMENTS AND
QUADS INN SUITES WHERE THEY
MIGHT SHARE A KITCHEN AND A
BATHROOM WITH JUST A FEW ROOMS
AND THE PRICES FOR ALL OF THOSE
TWO VERY. AT CSU THE ON CAMPUS
HOUSING CHARGE WE JUST LOOK FOR
A DOUBLE ROOM JUST TO GIVE YOU
SOME SENSE OF THE VARIATION
AMONGST CAMPUSES. AND THE
CHARGE RANGES FROM MORE THAN
ELEVEN THOUSAND AT FULLER TEN
AND CHANNEL ISLANDS TO LESS
THAN SIX THOUSAND PER ACADEMIC
YEAR AT CSU MONTEREY I'M SORRY
MARITIME AND FRESNO. THAT DATA
IS ALSO PROVIDED IN MORE DETAIL
ON THE NEXT PAGE. YOU SEE SENSE
THAT IT DOESN'T SYSTEMATICALLY
COLLECT DATA ON ITS ON CAMPUS
CHARGES AT ALL CAMPUSES
RELATIVE TO THE LOCAL MARKETS
BUT THAT- IT DOES IT INTENDS TO
HAVE ITS ON CAMPUS CHARGES
BELOW MARKET RATE. SO AS I
MENTIONED ON PAGE EIGHT YOU CAN
SEE THE DATA FOR CSU FOR THE
SAKE OF TIME I'M JUST GONNA
LEAVE THAT FOR YOUR REFERENCE.
PAGE NINE FOCUSES ON A KEY-
ASPECT WE WERE ASKED TO- AT
INVESTING- LEARN MORE ABOUT
WHICH IS HOW CAMPUSES FINANCE
THEIR FACILITY PROJECTS. FOR
SOME PROJECTS UNIVERSITY SELL
BONDS AND THEY REPAY THE DEBT
ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE BONDS
FROM THE ANNUAL STUDENT HOUSING
CHARGES TYPICALLY REPAYMENT
OCCURS OVER ROUGHLY THIRTY
YEARS. CAMPUSES LIKE LIKE MANY
OF YOU WITH MAYBE A HOME
MORTGAGE THEY DO PUT A LITTLE
BIT DOWN TYPICALLY SOMETHING
LIKE FIVE OR 20% THEY PAYING
CASH UP FRONT THIS TENDS TO
HELP THEM GET MORE FAVORABLE
BARLEY IN TERMS. SOME PROJECTS
USE UP PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP WHICH ARE THESE
LOCALLY NEGOTIATED AGREEMENTS
BETWEEN A PRIVATE PARTNER TO
AND A DEVELOPER AND THEN THE
CAMPUS. IN THE SAME WAY THAT A
REVENUE BOND IS RETIRED THOUGH
A P. THREE THAT WILL ALSO BE
RETIRED USING ANNUAL STUDENT
HOUSING CHARGES TO COVER THE
DEBT SERVICE PAYMENT OVER THE
AMORTIZATION PERIOD. IN MANY
CASES WITH THE P. THREE THE P.
THREE ISN'T THE PARTNER IS NOT
ONLY HELPING WITH CONSTRUCTION
BUT THEY'RE ALSO MAINTAINING
AND OPERATING THE FACILITY FOR
A SET PERIOD OF TIME AND THEN
AFTER THAT TIME LAPSES SAY
THIRTY YEARS FULL CONTROL OF
THE FACILITY- GOES TO THE
CAMPUS. AND THE THIRD MAIN WAY
THAT- SOME PROJECTS AND AS A
MUCH LESS COMMON WAY IS THROUGH
DONOR SUPPORT. SO WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE COLLEGES TWO THIRDS OF
THEIR PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
FINANCED WITH LOCAL BONDS AND
THEN ROUGHLY A THIRD THROUGH A
P. THREE ARRANGEMENT. WHEN YOU
LOOK AT CSU CAMPUSES MOST OF
THEIR PROJECTS ARE DONE WITH
REVENUE BONDS. AND THEN YOU SEE
HAS USED A MIX OF BONDS P.
THREE IS AND ON OUR SUPPORT-
OVER OVER THE COURSE OF TIME P.
THREES HAVE BEEN MORE PREVALENT
THAT YOU SEE THAT OTHERS. SO
THERE ARE MANY FACTORS THAT
WILL AFFECT WHAT KIND OF
FINANCING APPROACH A PROJECT
TAKES. SO THOSE CAMPUSES THAT
HAVE LARGE AND OR LONG STANDING
HOUSING PROGRAMS RELATIVELY LOW
LEVELS OF THAT EXISTING HOUSING
FACILITIES THAT ARE IN GOOD
CONDITION. UNSURPRISINGLY THESE
OTHER ONES THAT HAVE MORE
BUDGET CAPACITY THEY CAN STILL
CHARGE ANNUAL HOUSING CHARGES
AND THEN THEY CAN BUILD UP
THEIR RESERVES AND WHEN THEY GO
TO THE MARKET THEY'LL HAVE MORE
TO MAKE IS THE DOWN PAYMENT
BILL TYPICALLY GET BETTER
BORROWING TERMS. NEWER CAMPUSES
CAMPUSES WITH SMALLER HOUSING
PROGRAMS WITH HIGH LEVELS OF
ASSOCIATED THAT WITH AN OLDER
HOUSING STOCK THAT NEEDS
SUBSTANTIAL RENOVATION. THEY'RE
NOT GONNA HAVE THE SAME LEVEL
OF RESERVES TYPICALLY SO WHEN
THEY GO OUT TO THE MARKET THEIR
BAR IN TERMS WILL TYPICALLY BE
SOMEWHAT LESS ADVANTAGEOUS. SO
AGAIN BOTH SETS OF GROUPS ARE
ABLE TO ACCESS THE MARKET JUST
TENDS TO BE NOT AS FAVORABLE
FOR SOME CAMPUSES RELATIVE TO
OTHERS. SO THEN ON PAGE ELEVEN
ANOTHER TOPIC WE WERE ASKED TO
LOOK INTO IS WHAT ARE THE
CONSTRAINTS WHY IS IT THAT SOME
CAMPUSES- ARE HAVING DIFFICULTY
ADDING CAPACITY AT AN
AFFORDABLE RATE. AND ONE THAT
OBVIOUSLY CAME UP AGAIN AND
AGAIN WAS FINANCING. BUT IT
WASN'T FINANCING IN THE SENSE
OF HITTING A DEBT LIMIT OR DEBT
CAPACITY BOTH OF THE SYSTEMS
REPORTED THAT THEY HAVE
BILLIONS OF ROOM LEFT UNDER
WHAT MIGHT BE A LIKE A
THEORETICAL OR EVEN PRACTICAL
THAT STEALING LIKE THEY CAN'T
GO TO THE MARKET AND ACCESS
ADDITIONAL BORROWING. AND THEY
REPORTED THAT DEBT LIMITS
WEREN'T THE THING THAT WAS
PREVENTING ANY PARTICULAR
CAMPUS FROM PURSUING A PROJECT.
BUT WHAT ALMOST EVERY PROJECT
VOICE TO US IS THAT IT'S JUST
HARD TO MAKE PROJECTS VIABLE SO
WHAT THEY HAVE TO DO IS MAKE
SURE THAT THEY BUILD THE
FACILITY AT SUCH A WAY THAT
THEY CAN COVER THE ANNUAL
OPERATING COSTS THE ANNUAL DEBT
SERVICE COSTS AND STILL HAVE A
RATE CHARGING STUDENTS THAT
THEY THINK IS AFFORDABLE THAT
STUDENTS WOULD STILL BE WILLING
TO PAY. SO THAT'S A CHALLENGE
FOR ALL PROJECT ALMOST ALL
PROJECTS. WHAT SOME CAMPUS ARE
ABLE TO DO PARTICULARLY THOSE
THAT HAVE LOTS OF HOUSING
FACILITIES IS THEY CAN TAKE THE
OLDER FACILITIES THAT MIGHT
HAVE RETIRED THEIR DEBT SERVICE
BUT THEY'RE STILL HAVING
REVENUE FROM STUDENT CHARGES SO
THEY HAVE RESERVES. THEY CAN
USE THAT TO CROSS SUBSIDIZE THE
NEWER HOUSING FACILITIES FOR
THE FIRST FEW YEARS TO MAKE
THOSE RATS MORE MANAGEABLE FOR
STUDENTS. ANOTHER MAJOR
CONSTRAINT THAT WE HEARD FROM
ALMOST EVERY CAMPUS. DEALT WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES SO CAMPUS
SAYS FOR ANY LARGE PROJECT HAVE
TO FOLLOW THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT SO
THE SEQUEL REVIEW PROCESS SEES.
AND CAMPUS IS COMMONLY REPORT
THAT THOSE PROCESS FEES AND
POTENTIAL LITIGATION ASSOCIATED
WITH THEM CAN INCREASE THEIR
COST AND LENGTH AND THEIR
PROJECT TIME. NOW HAVING SAID
THAT AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW
CONCERNS MISTY QUAD TRACED BACK
DECADES AND THE STATE
PERIODICALLY HAS DONE THESE
INTENSIVE REFUSE TO TRY TO
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS AND TRY
TO BALANCE ALL OF THE ISSUES AT
STAKE. SO FOR THE SAKE OF THIS-
HERE IN THIS PARTICULAR TIME
FRAME WE DIDN'T DO A DEEP DIVE
ON THE NEW OPPORTUNITIES THE
STATE MIGHT HAVE TO DO FURTHER
STREAMLINING IT COULD BE AN
AVENUE YOU WANT TO INVESTIGATE
MOVING FORWARD BUT AGAIN THAT
HAS BEEN DONE PERIODICALLY BY
THE STATE TO TRY TO IMPROVE AND
STREAMLINE THAT PROCESS. WHERE
WE HEARD FINANCING AN
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS FROM
ALMOST EVERY PROJECT IN CAMPUS
WE TALKED TO A FEW OF THEM SAID
THEY HAD THE ADDED CHALLENGE OF
LAND ACQUISITION. SO WE TENDED
TO HEAR THAT'S UNSURPRISINGLY
FROM CAMPUSES THAT ARE FEEL
FULLY BUILT OUT AND OR THEY
FACE GEOGRAPHIC CONSTRAINTS
FROM BUILDING OUT THEY THEY-
BUMP UP AGAINST AN OCEAN OR A
FOREST OR MOUNTAIN OR CITY
DEVELOPMENT THAT WOULD
OBVIOUSLY MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO BUILD.
THIS CAMPUS IS STILL PURSUE
HOUSING PROJECTS BUT THEY TEND
TO HAVE TO DEMOLISH AND BUILD
UP OR RENOVATE AND BUILD UP SO
THAT THEY CAN NOT THE CAPACITY.
SO BECAUSE WE THOUGHT THERE
WOULD BE INTEREST IN THIS NEW
PROGRAM THAT THE STATE RECENTLY
CREATED ON PAGE TWELVE WE DO
PROVIDE SOME VERY PRELIMINARY
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT PROGRAM.
SO APPLICATIONS WERE DUE UNDER
STATE LAW THEY WERE DUE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OCTOBER
THIRTY FIRST SO JUST ABOUT A
WEEK AGO. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION- VERY JUST ARE
GENEROUSLY IN QUICKLY SHARED
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION WITH
US. FINANCED RECEIVED A HUNDRED
AND THIRTEEN APPLICATIONS
TOTALING THREE POINT THREE
BILLION. SO AS YOU CAN SEE FROM
THE CHART EACH STATEMENT
REQUESTED MORE THAN THEIR TOTAL
PROGRAM ALLOTMENTS NOT JUST
THEIR ALLOTMENT FOR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUT ACTUALLY THEIR
TOTAL ALLOTMENT ACROSS THE
THREE YEARS. SO THERE WAS LOTS
OF INTEREST IN THIS PROGRAM
LOTS OF APPLICATIONS SUBMITTED.
FOR THE LAST TWO PAGES OF- I'M
SORRY- WHAT WE ALSO TRIED TO DO
JUST A FEW WOULD FIND IT
INTERESTING US TO TAKE SOME OF
THAT PRELIMINARY INFORMATION
AND GET A BETTER SENSE OF HOW
FAR THE STATE DOLLARS WOULD
STRETCH. SO BASED UPON JUST A
SAMPLE OF THOSE APPLICATIONS
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO PEEK AT-
THE COST PER BED COULD RANGE
FROM ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND TO MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND. SO WITHIN
THAT RANGE- THIS THE PROGRAM
THIS NEW CASH PROGRAM THE STATE
CREATED COULD FIND BETWEEN
SEVEN THOUSAND AND TWELVE
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL PADS. SO
THAT WOULD INCREASE TOTAL
HOUSING CAPACITY ACROSS THE
THREE SEGMENTS BY 427%
DEPENDING ON WHERE THE EXACT
COST PER BAD LANDED. HAVING
SAID THAT YOU'RE GONNA SEE VERY
DIFFERENT EFFECTS ACROSS THE
THREE SEGMENTS BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THE PROGRAM ALLOTMENTS WORK
WITH 50% RESERVE FOR THE
COLLEGES TWENTY FOR IT THE
UNIVERSITIES. SO YOU MIGHT SEE
HOUSING CAPACITY DOUBLE AT THE
COLLEGES. MAYBE INCREASE
SOMEWHERE LIKE 325% AT CSU AND
THEN ONE OR 2% THAT YOU SEE.
THOSE APPLICATIONS AGAIN WILL
COME YOUR WAY AND MARCH THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL GO THROUGH
THOSE APPLICATIONS AND THEN
GIVE YOU A FIRST STEP TO REVEAL
COME MARCH. THE LAST TWO PAGES
NOW THEY HAVE NOT JUST FOCUSED
ON THE TAKE AWAY SO WE DID THIS
ENDEAVOR AND TALKING WITH THESE
VARIOUS GROUPS ON WHAT WE
WALKED AWAY- WITH IS THAT.
THERE IS A SENSE THAT CAMPUSES
HAVE BEEN AND ARE ADDING
CAPACITY SO EVEN WITHOUT STATE
FUNDS THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
NAVIGATE THESE CHALLENGES-
THEY'VE THEY'VE ADDED BEDS
THERE NOW IN THE MIDST OF
CONSTRUCT IN THEM AND THEY HAVE
PLANS FOR MORE. CAMPUSES ARE
ALSO SOMEWHAT UNIQUE AS THE
LANDLORD BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
REQUIRE STUDENTS TO LIVE ON
CAMPUS AND AS A RESULT OF THAT
THEIR PROJECT RISK IS SOMEWHAT
LOWER BECAUSE THEY HAVE
SOMEWHAT GREATER
PREDICTABILITY. AND WHAT THEIR
FUTURE REVENUE STREAMS WILL BE
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT THEY CAN
REQUIRE AGAIN STUDENTS TO SHOW
UP AND PAY. I WE KNOW THAT AT
LEAST AT THIS TIME OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST FEW YEARS
INTEREST RATES HAVE BEEN AT
HISTORICAL LOWS. INTEREST RATES
ARE A BIG FACTOR IN WHETHER A
CAMPUS WANTS TO PURSUE A
HOUSING PROJECT SO IT'S BEEN
VIEWED AS A PARTICULARLY
ATTRACTIVE TIME TO BUILD. NO
INTEREST RATES MIGHT START
GOING UP OVER THE NEXT COMING
QUARTERS AND YEARS- IF THEY GO
UP A LITTLE BIT I THINK
CAMPUSES MIGHT STILL VIEW IT AS
FAVORABLE IF THEY GO UP STEEPLY
OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T STAND DYNAMICS
ARE GOING TO CHANGE. OUT WHAT
IT TAKES TO MAKE A PROJECT
FISCALLY VIABLE IS GOING TO BE
MUCH MORE SIGNIFICANTLY
AFFECTED. WE ALSO WALKED AWAY
RECOGNIZING THAT CAMPUS
CHALLENGES TEND TO BE A
LOCALIZED. SO ALL OF THESE
FACTORS I MENTIONED THIS
MORNING I CAMPUSES FISCAL
CONDITION IT'S EXISTING HOUSING
STOCK THE STATE OF THAT STOCK.
THE CURRENT LOCAL HOUSING
MARKET CONSTRUCTION COSTS IN
THAT AREA THE SPECIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES THAT A
CAMPUS IS DEALING WITH. THE
COMMUNITY CONCERNS THIS DIFFER
ACROSS ACROSS CAMPUS AS- SUCH
THAT IF THE ANY STATE POLICY
RESPONSE LIKELY WOULD WANT TO
TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT AND
OFFER SOME FLEXIBILITY FOR
CAMPUSES TO DEAL WITH THOSE
PARTICULAR CHALLENGES THEY'RE
FACING. WE ALSO RECORD A WALKED
AWAY- WITH THIS RECOGNITION
THAT THERE ARE MULTIPLE WAYS
THE STATE HAS FOR ADDRESSING
AFFORDABILITY AND HOMELESSNESS.
ONE MAJOR WAY THE STATE HAS
TRIED TO DO THIS IS STARKLY IS
AND IN TERMS OF HELPING
STUDENTS WITH THEIR LIVING
COSTS IS THROUGH FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS. AND OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED THE
AMOUNT OF FINANCIAL AID FOR
LIVING COSTS AS PROVIDED MORE
AID FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WHO ARE GOING FULL
TIME FOR STUDENTS WITH
DEPENDENT CHILDREN FOR FOSTER
YOUTH. AS PART OF THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP TWO POINT OH
IT SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED
LIVING AID FOR UC AND CSU
STUDENTS. AND THEN IN ADDITION
TO THESE TRADITIONAL FINANCIAL
AID PROGRAMS THE STATE HAS
CREATED THESE RAPID RE HOUSING
PROGRAMS. AND WHAT MIGHT BE
GOOD NEWS FOR YOU IS CAMPUSES
REPORT THAT THOSE RAPID RE
HOUSING PROGRAMS ARE WORKING SO
THEY'RE SETTING ASIDE SLOTS
WHEN A STUDENT INDICATES THAT
THEIR HOUSING SITUATION IS
VULNERABLE WHERE THEY CAN PUT
THEM IN A RESIDENTIAL HALL AND
GIVE THEM STABLE HOUSING. FOR
SOME COURSE OF TIME BEFORE THEY
CAN MOVE THEM AND EITHER TO
ANOTHER HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
THAT'S STABLE ARE JUST STAYING
RIGHT THERE IN. A RESIDENTIAL.
SO WE WALKED AWAY NOT REALLY
HAVING A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF
HOW THE NEW HOUSING GRANTS
WOULD INTERACT WITH THESE
TRADITIONAL FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS THE RAPID
RE HOUSING PROGRAMS. AND I
THINK IT'S STILL OPEN ISSUE
WHETHER THOSE HOUSING GRANTS
WILL BE MORE OR LESS EFFECTIVE-
AT HELPING STUDENTS THAN THESE
OTHER PROGRAMS NOW A BIG CAVIAR
IS THOSE OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE
YOUR FINANCIAL AID IN RAPID
REHOUSING PROGRAMS. THEIR
ONGOING AND THIS IS A ONE TIME
THEN THE HOUSING PROGRAM AS ONE
TIME SO THAT'S A BIG
CONSIDERATION FOR YOU. THE
FOURTH AND FINAL TAKE AWAY IS
THAT THE STATE IS FACING
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL TRADE OFFS
SO IF THE STATE WANTS YOU SEE
AND SEE IF YOU FOR EXAMPLE TO
ADD STUDENTS. FOR SOME CAMPUSES
THAT WILL MEAN NOT ONLY KNEW
HOUSING SPACE BUT NEW ACADEMIC
SPACE. AND CAMPUSES RELY VERY
HEAVILY ON THE STATE FOR THEIR
ACADEMIC SPACE. THE STATE
OBVIOUSLY STILL WANTS CAMPUSES
TO SERVE OTHER EXISTING
STUDENTS AND SAFE- WELL
MAINTAINED FACILITIES AND ALL
THE SEGMENTS ARE REPORTING
BACKLOG OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. SO BIG FISCAL
TRADE OFFS FOR YOU BETWEEN
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE. NEW
ACADEMIC SPACE AND NO HOUSING
SPACE. BY CONCLUDES THE
OVERVIEW I'M HAPPY TO AND TRY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE. OKAY QUESTIONS FOR
THE L. A. L. MISTER O'DONNELL
AND BY THE WAY WELCOME MR
DONALD AND MR LEE THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU. I
THANK YOU CHAIR I JUST A QUICK
QUESTION WITH REGARD TO YOU ARE
YOU TALK ABOUT OTHER BRANDS YOU
KNOW WHEN EVERYONE PART OF THE
COST OF THE TO LIVE THERE. ARE
THE NUMBER OF UNITS AT A
CONSTRUCTION BUT THERE WASN'T
TOO MUCH THERE WAS TOO MUCH IN
DEPTH ON HOW MUCH IT COST TO
CONSTRUCT EACH UNITS. OF NEW
HOUSING LEAVE TALK I THINK YOU
SAID BETWEEN. ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND TO THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. IS IT IS IT. IS THAT
THAT THAT'S QUITE A RANGE.
RIGHT IS ARE THERE ANY FACTORS
BUILT INTO THAT RANGE THAT
YOU'RE AWARE OF AS FAR AS JUST
JUST. JUST JUST TO SEE CSU OR
UC DO A BETTER JOB. AT
CONSTRUCTING HOUSING IN A MORE
EFFICIENT MANNER COST. COST
FRIENDLY MANNER ACCEPT OR DO
YOU HAVE ANY. CAN YOU ADD
ANYTHING TO THAT CONVERSATION.
YEAH IF IT'S HELPFUL WE LOOKED
AT THE CSU IN THE- FIRST ROUND
OF APPLICATIONS SUBMITTED EIGHT
APPLICATIONS. AND THEIR COST
PER PROJECT PER BAD. RANGE FROM
TWO HUNDRED AND TWO THOUSAND
TWO I THINK THREE HUNDRED AND
FOUR THOUSAND SO IF A NOTABLE
RANGE THEIR AVERAGE WAS TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND.
WHEN WE LOOK OVER PROJECTS WE
HAVE LIMITED DATA ON THE OTHER
SIX MONTHS AND SOME OTHER
HOUSING PROJECTS OVER TIME-
AND- IT IS ALSO HOUSING CUT
CONSTRUCTION COSTS ARE GOING UP
SO EVEN WHEN WE LOOK AT IT YOU
SEE HOUSING PROJECT FROM FOUR
YEARS AGO WE KNOW IT'S NOT A
GREAT. INDICATOR WHAT THEY PAY
IF THEY WANT TO THE MARKET
TODAY. BUT THOSE TEND TO BE IN
THE HIGH ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED THOUSANDS. SO THIS
IS A BIT OF GAS WORK WE REALLY
WERE JUST TRYING TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF ROUGHLY HOW MUCH YOUR
CAPACITY WOULD ADD. I THINK I
APPRECIATE THE SPIRIT OF THE
QUESTION AT THE FISCAL ANALYSTS
ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. HOW
MUCH SHOULD A BAD COST AND WHAT
FACTORS SHOULD YOU BE
CONSIDERING AND TRYING TO
CONTROL THE COST. AND AS YOU
WORK WITH FINANCE OVER THE NEXT
FEW MONTHS ARE THESE
APPLICATIONS YOU'VE GOT TOO
HIGH OF A COST COULD MAYBE RE
ENGINEERING THE BUILDING TO
GIVE YOU MORE BEDS BUT STILL. A
GOOD FACILITY WHERE STUDENTS
ARE STATE FAN THEY HAVE GOOD
COMMUNAL. SPACE- BUT WE HAVEN'T
I. DON'T REALLY. INTO HOW TO
FIGURE. WHETHER THE RATE ARE
ARE BALLPARK REASONABLE WHEN
YOU LOOK AT HISTORY THERE
BALLPARK REASONABLE. OKAY IT
WOULD JUST ONE MORE QUESTION SO
AND SO I THAT AND ALSO WE DON'T
HAVE ANY DATA RELATIVE TO.
WHETHER OR NOT- HOW MANY
BENEFACTORS ARE GIVING. TO
BUILD. TO AYE ANYONE OF THE
SYSTEMS TO BUILD STUDENT
HOUSING AND I YOU KNOW THERE'S
A CIRCUS AND IN SANTA BARBARA
RIGHT NOW RIGHT. SO I MEAN IS
THAT HAPPENING ALL OVER THE UC
SYSTEM CSU SYSTEM AS A ONE
SEGMENT GETS MORE MONEY. FROM
BENEFACTOR ENSURE THAT PLAN HOW
MUCH WE SUPPORT EACH SYSTEM AS
WELL ANY OPINIONS YEAH- AS WE
LOOKED AT HOW THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND CSU PROJECTS WERE
FUNDED SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN. I
DON'T THINK WE CAME ACROSS A
SINGLE PROJECT A STUDENT
HOUSING PROJECT THAT WAS
FINANCED IN ANY NOTABLE WAY
FROM PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORT I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY GOT MUCH IN
THE PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORT. YOU
HEAR ABOUT IT AT UC CAMPUSES
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S BEEN A BIG
ONE ON THE NEWS OF LATE
REGARDING THE UC SANTA BARBARA
PROJECT BUT EVEN NOT YOU SEE
IT'S NOT HOW- IN. ANY NOTABLE
SHARE OF THEIR FACILITIES ARE
FINANCE P. THREES- FOR EXAMPLE
OVER THE LAST FIVE SIX YEARS
WERE ACCOUNTING FOR ABOUT 40%
ANOTHER HUGE CHUNK OR ACCOUNTED
THROUGH REVENUE BONDS. SO YOU
CAN ASK OUR OBVIOUSLY YOUR
SEATS TO GIVE YOU MORE ACCURATE
INFORMATION THIS AFTERNOON BUT
I HAVE A SENSE IT'S- LIKE LESS
THAN 10% OF THEIR HOUSING
FACILITIES ARE FUNDED THROUGH
PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORT THAT
MIGHT EVEN BE. TOO HIGH BUT BUT
I APPRECIATE THAT THE GAS AND.
YOU SEE IS IN THE ROOM SO THEY
CAN CLARIFY. OKAY THANK YOU.
THE ONLY REASON I IS THAT
COULD. IF THE BENEFACTORS
DESIGNING THE BUILDING. THAT
COULD IMPACT THE ULTIMATE COST
OF THE BUILDING. AND THEN YOU
HAVE TO QUESTION WHETHER IT'S
WORTH HAVING THAT BENEFACTOR
EVEN IN THE END MAYBE YEAH ONE
OF THE MORE STRAIGHTFORWARD
WAYS IN THIS I THINK IS A
FUNDAMENTAL TENSION BEFORE YOU
IS YOU CAN START GETTING
GREATER ASSUREDLY ON THE COST
PER BED BY PRESCRIBING SOME OF
THE ARCHITECTURAL DETAILS OF
THE BUILDING HOW MANY STUDENTS
YOU WANT IN A ROOM. HOW MANY
BATHROOMS YOU WANT PER STUDENT
ACCESS TO KITCHENS EXIDE ROCK
THAT WILL ALL AFFECT HOW MANY
WINDOWS YOU WANT PER PROBE AS
ROOM ARE COMMON STUDY SPACE
AREAS HOW MUCH YOU WANT FOR IN
ROOM SOURCES COMMON STUDY SPACE
BUT THESE ARE THINGS THE STATE
TRADITIONALLY HAS NOT WEIGHED
IN ON- AND SO THE BIG TENSION
IS DO YOU WANT TO BE
PRESCRIPTIVE SO YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU'RE GETTING SPECIFICALLY
WITH THE DOLLARS. OR DO YOU
WANT TO JUST GIVE THE CAMPUSES
MONEY MAYBE HAVE A REPORT ON
THE BACKEND IN TERMS OF HOW
MANY BEDS WERE ADDED THE PRICE
PER BED WHAT THE RESULTING
MONTHLY RENTS WILL BE AND GET
US FUNDS ON THAT WHOLE HOLD
THEM ACCOUNTABLE ON THAT BACK
AND IT IS THAT. IT'S A
DIFFICULT CHOICE FOR YOU TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO HOW TO.
ADMINISTER THIS PROGRAM MOVING
FORWARD. GREAT THANK AYE
MINISTER PROBABLY LONGER DESIGN
AT DESIGN. I AM NOT INTERESTED
IN DESIGNING COLLEGE DORMS
MYSELF SO. I CAN SPEAK FOR MY
FELLOW LEGISLATORS THANK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU WELL IF YOU HAVE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
APPARENTLY YOU CAN DESIGN YOUR
OWN DORM RIGHT MR DONE. AND YOU
KNOW I WAS GONNA ASK THAT WE'RE
NOT THERE YET BUT MR POSTER
MIGHT I DID HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT AND I
DON'T WANNA GET INTO HEARING
ABOUT SANTA BARBARA BUT JUST.
GUESTS GET READY FOR THAT BUT I
GUESS THE BIG PICTURE THERE IS
IT'S A ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR PROJECT. AND THIS.
BENEFACTOR IS GONNA DONATE
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED MILLION PUTS
A LOT OF MONEY. THAT'S ALL OF
HIS BILL THE WHOLE THING IT'S
LIKE 1015% OF ITSELF. IS I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS IF IT
DOES. YOU KNOW DOES THAT MAKE
IT A MAKE OR BREAK I DON'T KNOW
I'M I'M NOT THINK THAT'S QUITE
ACCURATE SO BUT WE CAN GET.
INTO THAT BUT THE DUTY TO KIND
OF OVERARCHING QUESTIONS FOR.
THE L. A. L. IS WHAT TO DO
WITH- THE MONEY. WE HAVE. SET
ASIDE. IN THE BUDGET. AND MONEY
RECOUP THE MONEY WE'RE GONNA
GET NEXT YEAR WOULD HAVE MORE
ONE TIME MONEY THIS IS A TOP
PRIORITY IN. COLLEGE HOUSING
SO- THE WILL COME OF THAT BACK
THAT THE SECOND BUT- THE FIRST
PICTURE THE FIRST THING IS. AS
YOU KNOW IT IT IT'S VERY
DIVERSE YOU KNOW SOME SEE
ISSUES AND FRESNO AND
BAKERSFIELD AND CSU SAMBAR TO
DINO AND- MAYBE THEY DON'T HAVE
THE- HUGE NEED. FOR STUDENT
HOUSING IT'S A COMMUTER CAMPUS
OR THERE IS. A LOT OF HOUSING
NEXT TO THE CAMPUS AS WELL. AND
THEN IT YOU THAT YOU SEE IS.
THAT IT'S MORE NEED FOR STUDENT
HOUSING- BUT SOME IT SOUNDS
VERY DIFFERENT WHERE AS YOU
KNOW THAT UC. BERKELEY AND
SANTA BARBARA AND SANTA CRZ LA
DOES NOT LAND BUT IT DAVIS AND-
RIVERSIDE MERCED. THERE'S A LOT
OF LAND SO IT'S NOT ALWAYS.
APPLES AND ORANGES. BUT I'M
KIND OF. PERPLEXED BECAUSE-
WHEN I'VE GONE TO TALK TO.
CHANCELLORS AND PRESIDENTS AS
HAS. CHAIR MEDINA A LOT OF THEM
HAVE SAID- THE SAME THING WHICH
IS THEY WANT TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING. AND IT'S KIND OF A LOW
RISK PROPOSITION BECAUSE YOU
HAVE STUDENTS. THERE'S MORE
COMING THEIR HOUSING AND SECURE
IN THE FIRST PLACE YOU CAN
FORCE THEM OR COERCE THEM TO
COME ON CAMPUS FOR THE FIRST
COUPLE YEARS WHICH IS A GOOD
THING THEY DO BETTER IF THEY'RE
ON CAMPUS. YOU KNOW THAT
THEY'RE GONNA COME YEAR AFTER
YEAR FOR. UNLESS YOU HAVE A
GLOBAL PANDEMIC WITH I WAS A
LITTLE BLIP SO IT'S PRETTY
SOLID BUSINESS PROPOSITION YOU
KNOW THEY'RE GONNA BE THERE
EVERY YEAR YEAH YOU ARE GROWING
EVERY YEAR. AND SO YOU GET INTO
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE WHY. YOU
WOULDN'T IF YOU HAD A POT OF
MONEY TO BUILD THE HOUSING IF
YOU BUILD IT THEY WILL THEY
LITERALLY WILL CON BECAUSE
THEY'RE THERE ANYWAY. SO A LOT
OF THESE CAMPUSES HAVE SAID
THAT THEY'RE RUNNING THEY RUN
INTO COMPETING- FINANCIAL
CONSTRAINTS WITH THEIR DEBT
CAPACITY AND SO I HEARD THAT
OVER AND OVER UC'S NC ISSUES
THE LAST TWO YEARS. AND THEN
YOUR RESEARCH WHAT I 100%
BELIEVE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING WHEN
YOU TALK TO THE SYSTEM AND
WE'LL GET TO THIS WILL BE
PASSED UC AND CSU TO COME OUT.
THERE SAYING DIFFERENTLY AND
THEN WE HAD SOME CHANCES AT THE
END WHO ARE SPEAKING SO. CAN
YOU HELP US ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
FIRST. EIGHT I YEAH I APOLOGIZE
IN ADVANCE IF IT'S NOT A
PARTICULARLY SATISFYING ANSWER
BUT I THINK WHAT WE HEARD IS
THAT. CAMPUS IS FEES FISCAL
CHALLENGES AND THEY SEEM LIKE
REALLY SERIOUS CHALLENGES AND
THIS IS THE PERENNIAL WE TALK
TO ANY LOCAL OR STATE AGENCY
THEY ARE ALWAYS FACING A
SERIOUS FINANCIAL CHALLENGE.
AND I AND YOU CAN UNDERSTAND
OUR REASONS WHY THEY ARE TO
MAKE A HOUSING PROJECT PENCIL
OUT. THEY HAVE TO BE SKILLED AT
WHAT THEY'RE DOING TO GET ALL
THE PIECES TO WORK JUST RIGHT
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO DESIGN
A FACILITY. TO BE ABLE TO GO
OUT THE MARKET AT THAT TIME
DELIVER IT ON SCHEDULE ON PRICE
AND THEY NEED TO HAVE THE DEBT
SERVICE AND THE OPERATING COSTS
THAT WILL GO INTO PERPETUITY
THERE AFTER. AND PENCIL IT ALL
OUT AND THAT IS DIFFICULT. I'M
NOT SURPRISED THAT WHETHER IT'S
YOU OR ME GOING OUT TO TALKING
TO PEOPLE WE ARE HEARING THAT
FINANCING AS A CHALLENGE. I
THINK THE KEY. CHALLENGE THE
KEY FOR POLICY ISSUE IS IT'S A
CHALLENGE. ARE YOU PREVENTED
FROM DOING WHAT YOU WANT OR IS
IT A CHALLENGE THAT YOU FACE
AND I THINK WHAT WE HEARD IS
THESE ARE SERIOUS CHALLENGES
BUT THEY DON'T PREVENT US FROM
BUILDING. THEY DON'T PREVENT US
FROM BEING ABLE TO. FIGURE OUT
THE DESIGN OF THE BUILDING AND
BE ABLE TO COVER THE DEBT
SERVICE AND THE OPERATING COSTS
AND STILL HAVE A MONTHLY CHARGE
THAT IS WITHIN THE- REALM OF
REASON FOR MOST STUDENTS. SO
THEN IT BECOMES LAW HOW CAN THE
STATE- HAVE A- IMPORTANT ROLE
HERE- AND IT IT IS A LITTLE BIT
TRICKIER BECAUSE YOUR- AGAIN
WE'RE TRYING TO SIGN IN THE
ABSENCE OF STATE MONEY WHAT
WOULD OTHERWISE HAPPEN AND
CAMPUSES ARE SHOWING YOU THAT
THEY'VE BUILT OUR BUILDING HAVE
PLANS TO BUILD THE MARKET IS
SAYING IT'S A GOOD ENVIRONMENT
TO BUILD- BUT THIS ISN'T SAYING
YOU WILL NOT YOU WILL HEAR FROM
DISTRICTS. I PROBABLY FOR YEARS
TO COME THAT VACANCY RATES ARE
LOW WAIT LISTS ARE LONG.
HOUSING IS HARD ESPECIALLY FOR
A LONG FROM FOLKS TO COVER- AND
I'M SORRY TO HAVE SUCH A
DISSATISFIED ANSWER AT THE
MOMENT BECAUSE I'M NOT QUITE.
UNFORTUNATELY I NORMALLY YOU
AND THE RESURGENT GOVERNOR LIKE
ALL THE STATE POLICY SOLUTION
IS OBVIOUS THAN HERE AS YOU
PROBABLY HEARD WITH ALL YOUR
HOUSING CONVERSATIONS THERE'S
NOT LIKE A SIMPLE OBVIOUS
SOLUTION. MAYBE YOU CAN FIGURE
OUT SOME PRIORITY RULES THAT
REALLY GIVE THE GRANTS TO THOSE
VERY ISOLATED AREAS THAT ARE
NOT ABLE THEY THEY THEY PROVE
TO YOU THAT THEY CAN'T OVERCOME
IS MORE THAN JUST A CHALLENGE
IT'S AN INSURMOUNTABLE
OBSTACLE. AND YOU SOMEHOW
FIGURE OUT WHERE ARE THOSE
PLACES AND HOW CAN WE GIVE THEM
JUST ENOUGH SO THAT THEY CAN
MAYBE GO TO THE MARKET AND
ACCESS THAT MAYBE THEY JUST
DON'T HAVE THE RESERVE LEVELS
BECAUSE THEIR DEBT LOAD RIGHT
NOW IS HIGH. AND CREDIT RATING
RAIDERS ARE LOOKING NOT THOUGHT
SO MAYBE THAT'S THE AREA AND
MAYBE YOU CAN STILL DO THAT IN
THE MIDST OF THE NEW PROGRAM
YOU JUST LOOK AT THE
APPLICATIONS VERY CAREFULLY TO
TRY TO MAKE THIS JUDGMENT CALL
AS TO WHETHER IT'S JUST A
CHALLENGE OR AN INSURMOUNTABLE
BARRIER. YEAH I THINK THAT'S
THE ISSUES THAT LOCAL FIRST. WE
HAVE TIME TO FIGURE IT OUT
BECAUSE WE JUST. WE HAVE THAT-
DURING OVER THREE YEARS IF YOU
WANT TO COME BACK FOR MORE. SO
I GUESS THE ISSUE IS. YOU KNOW
LIKE HERE IN SACRAMENTO. I USED
TO BE ON THE CITY COUNCIL FOR
TEN YEARS- AS YOUR COUNCIL
MEMBER OF COURSE. AND THAT. WE
A- WEEK SOMETIMES YOU DO LIKE
TE KIND GAP FINANCING YOU LOOK
FOR PROJECTS. FOR DOUBLE
HOUSING PROJECTS THAT ARE. IN
NEED GIVE ME A LITTLE BIT TO
PUT HIM OVER THE TOP. SO THAT
WE WANT TO DO TO JUST PUT LIKE
A LITTLE BIT OF CASH TO PUT
THEM OVER THE TOP THE DOWN
PAYMENT ASSISTANCE. TO HELP
THEM. TO LOWER THEIR
AFFORDABILITY ABOUT WHICH WE
HEAR FROM YOU SEE SAN DIEGO.
WHICH IS WHICH IS CASH. BUT
SOME OTHERS ARE SAYING WOULD
EVEN NEED THAT WE JUST NEED US
TO HAVE THIS POT OF MONEY OVER
THERE TO ALLOW US TO DRAW DOWN.
KIND OF LIKE COSIGN. AND SO
WE'RE KIND OF AT A LOSS. WHICH
ONE TO DO SO DO WE DO THEM BOTH
DO WE DO THAT AS IS IT EITHER
OR- BASED UPON WHAT WE HEARD
THE FIRST OPTION SEEMS LIKE IT
WOULD BE MORE PROMISING. AND
THAT LIKE WITH A REVOLVING LOAN
FUND ONE OF THE MAJOR
ADVANTAGES AS LOW COST
BORROWING AND THE FIELD IS
TELLING U RIGHT NOW LOW COST
BORROWING IS NOT AN ISSUE.
INTEREST RATES ARE LOW WE CAN
GO TO MARKET AND ACCESS CASH-
BUT- BEING ABLE TO GO IN ACCESS
CASH YOU STILL ON AGAIN FOUGHT
TO HAVE THIS PROJECT. RESULT IN
MONTHLY CHARGES THAT STUDENTS
CAN AFFORD. SO IT MIGHT BE
SOMETHING LIKE THE GAP
FINANCING WHERE IF WE JUST GAVE
THEM A LITTLE BIT MORE THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO PENCIL OUT.
THE PROJECT- AT THAT WOULD
OBVIOUSLY WE'D HAVE TO AS AN
OFFICE THINK MORE ABOUT HOW TO
HELP YOU DESIGN SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTIONS REALLY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RACE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AT AGE TWELVE YOUR REPORT
I I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU THAT I'M
REALLY ENCOURAGED. TO SEE OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS NEW HOUSING
GRANT PROGRAM. BUT WE KNOW THAT
MOST OF THE COMMITTEE COLLEGES-
COMPRISE OF PEOPLE OF COLOR
MAJORITY ARE- OUR OUR- AT 60%
TYPE THINK OF ART LATINO
STUDENTS AND ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS ONE OF
THOSE IMPORTANT ISSUES-
ESPECIALLY FOR NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS TRYING TO JUGGLE
BETWEEN WORKING IN SCHOOL AND
WHAT HAVE YOU. ARE THERE ANY
IDEAS OR PROPOSALS FOR MULTI
CAMPUS STUDENT HOUSING GOOD
COMMUTER COLLEGE PARTNER WITH
OUR NEW- NEARBY UC OR CSU- TO
BUILD AND SUPPORT HOUSING FOR
STUDENTS FROM MULTIPLE CAMPUSES.
AND SO THE NEW CASH PROGRAM
DOES ALLOW FOR THIS YOU MIGHT
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN THOSE
EARLY CONVERSATIONS THAT DO
MAKE THIS AN ALLOWABLE PRACTICE
WHERE COLLEGES PROBABLY WORST
YES YOU WOULD GET TOGETHER TO
FIGURE OUT IF THERE COULD BE
SOME- HOW HOUSING NOT PROVIDED
MUTUAL BENEFITS TO THE TWO
SEGMENTS. YOU CAN SEE ON PAGE
TWELVE THAT OF FINANCE GOT FOR
INTER SEGMENTAL APPLICATIONS-
AND I I'M I'M NOT PRIVY TO
EXACTLY WHICH CAMPUSES THOSE
ARE I'M HOPING AGAIN. OVER THE
COMING MONTHS WE'LL GET MORE
INFORMATION ON THE SPECIFIC
NATURE OF ALL OF THOSE
APPLICATIONS. WHEN WE WERE
TALKING TO CSU M. AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE THEY BOTH WERE
EXPRESSING INTEREST IN THE IDEA
I THINK WE WERE STILL AT TWO
PRELIMINARY OF A STAGE FOR THEM
TO HAVE. SPECIFICITY AND HOW IT
WOULD WORK WHO IS WHICH
STUDENTS WOULD BENEFIT WHERE
THE CAMPUS- FACILITY WOULD BE
LOCATED BUT I IMAGINE IN THESE
FOUR APPLICATIONS THERE IS THAT
LEVEL OF DETAIL PROVIDED- SO
THIS IS ALL TO SAY WILL LEARN
MORE IN THE FUTURE IT SOUNDS
LIKE THE STATEMENTS ARE
AMENABLE TO THE IDEA AND
THEY'RE TRYING TO WORK IT OUT I
THINK THERE'S STILL THIS
PRACTICAL ISSUE OF WILL THEY BE
ABLE TO WORK OUT ALL THOSE
REALLY CRUCIAL DETAILS. WILL
THEY END UP BEING ONE OF THE
SELECT APPLICATIONS THAT YOU
ACTUALLY SEE IN MARCH DO THEY
PASSED FINANCES. REVIEW PROCESS.
OKAY THE THIS VIDEO YEAH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- IN CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS ARE NOT CONSIDERED A
SPECIAL NEEDS POPULATION- FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR FOR
REGIONAL NEEDS HOUSING
ALLOCATION UNLIKE OTHER GROUPS
LIKE AGRICULTURAL WORKERS OR
SENIORS CAN CAN YOU TELL ME WHY
WHY THIS IS THE CASE. I THINK
TRADITIONALLY AND THIS CAN BE
FOUND ON REMANENCE OF I THINK
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW. STUDENTS
HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN VIEWED- MORE
AS LIKE AN ADVANTAGE GROUP
BECAUSE THESE ARE STUDENTS WHO
HAVE GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL
JUMP THROUGH THE HOOPS OF
ENDING UP ON A POST SECONDARY
INSTITUTION AND IF THEY'RE ABLE
TO COMPLETE THEIR POST
SECONDARY EXPERIENCE. ARE MORE
LIKELY BASED UPON DATA THAT
SUITS YOU ON AVERAGE GET A JOB
HAVE A LIVING WAGE BE RESILIENT
AND THE TYPES OF JOBS THEY HAVE
AND THEIR ABILITY TO STAY
EMPLOYED- SO IF YOU COMPARE A
TWENTY YEAR OLD WHETHER THEY'RE
AT THE CSU OR THE UC CAMPUS
WITH A TWENTY YEAR OLDS WHO.
NEVER GOT ON THAT CAMPUS AND IS
WORKING ON TRYING TO MAKE ENDS
MEET I THINK IT'S STILL AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION FOR YOU
LIKE WHICH IS MORE OR LESS
ADVANTAGED BUT I THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY WHY THEY HAVEN'T BEEN.
CALLED OUT AS A SPECIAL A
DISADVANTAGED GROUP IN THEIR
ENTIRETY. THANK YOU. OKAY NOT
VERY HARD FOR. YEAH WE HAVE ONE
PERSON. YEAH. YEAH. OF
DIFFERENT VALUES- YEAH DR ED
OKAY GO AHEAD ALL RIGHT. AND WE
HAVE- PREFECT MAKES THE SEGMENT
WILL HAVE. FIVE YOU PROBABLY
TIME. RIGHT THERE UNTIL MID NOW
WASN'T ON HE SEGMENT HAVE.
WE'LL HAVE. FIVE MINUTES AND
SELL IT YOU'LL HAVE ENTIRE FIVE
MINUTES IN THE CSU AND UC WE'RE
GONNA SPLIT UP YOUR TIME-
ACCORDINGLY FOR FIVE MINUTES A
THREE SEGMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU TO MCCARTY GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
NATHAN BROSTROM ON THE CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER FOR THE UC
SYSTEM- THIS MORNING HOWEVER I
SPEAK KIND OF PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE I SERVED AS THE
INTERIM CHANCELLOR AT UC
MERCED- NINETEEN TWENTY AND
DURING THAT TIME ACTUALLY LIVED
IN AN APARTMENT ONE OF THE
DORMS SO I CAN TELL YOU
FIRSTHAND THE- JOYS AND
CHALLENGES OF STUDENT HOUSING.
AS CHAIR MENTIONED AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOUSING IS A KEY
COMPONENT OF AN AFFORDABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE EDUCATION MANY OF
OUR CAMPUSES ARE LOCATED IN
SOME OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE
RENTAL MARKETS IN THE COUNTRY
SO WHY WE'VE LAUNCHED. THE
STUDENT HOUSING INITIATIVE WE
ACTUALLY LAUNCHED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN TO EXPAND ON CAMPUS
HOUSING CAPACITY AT THAT TIME
WE HAD OVER EIGHTY SEVEN
THOUSAND YOU SEE STUDENTS WHO
LIVED IN UNIVERSITY PROVIDED
HOUSING. AND THE INITIATIVE
SOUGHT TO PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL.
FOURTEEN THOUSAND NEW- CAMPUS
HOUSING BEDS. I GIVEN THE CAN.
OF STUDENT HOUSING PROJECTS AS
THE ELLIE- MENTIONED THERE IS
NO ONE SIZE FITS ALL
DEVELOPMENT MODEL. OUR STRATEGY
HAS BEEN TO USE A MULTI FACETED
APPROACH TO LEVERAGE THE
BENEFITS OF VARIOUS DELIVERY
AND FINANCING MODELS. ACROSS
THE SYSTEM. THE CHALLENGE AS A
BUILDING AFFORDABLE STUDENT
HOUSING AND HIGH COST MARKETS.
WITH LIMITED UNDEVELOPED CAMPUS
LAND LET US TO PURSUE SEVERAL
STRATEGIES ALL OF WHICH HAVE
PROVED EFFECTIVE. FOR EXAMPLE
WE RECENTLY UPDATED OUR GET
POLICY. TO RECOGNIZE THE
REALITIES OF STUDENT HOUSING
PROJECTS. WHICH OFTEN THE
SUPPORT OF THE AUXILIARY SYSTEM
FOR THE FIRST FEW YEARS. WE
STRATEGICALLY USED A VARIETY OF
THE VEHICLES TO FINANCING
HOUSING SYSTEM WIDE TO SECURE
LOW COST FINANCING WHICH IS AS
THE ELLIE- SAID ON V. KEY
DRIVER NOT BEEN GREATER
AFFORDABILITY. WITH ACCELERATED
PLAN HOUSING PROJECTS AND
EVALUATED OPPORTUNITIES TO BOTH
PURCHASE AND LEASE HOUSING.
INCLUDING USING UP PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS. AND
ENSURE THAT THESE PROJECTS
SERVE ALL OUR STUDENTS WE
CONTINUALLY EVALUATE. ALL
FUNDING DELIVERY MODELS TO
MAINTAIN THE AFFORDABILITY. IN
THE PAST YEAR WE FINANCED EIGHT
STUDENT HOUSING PROJECTS WITH
FIVE CAMPUSES USING BOTH OUR
OWN LIMITED PROJECT REVENUE
BOND CREDIT. AT A COST OF LESS
THAN THREE PERCENT. FOR TERMS
OF THIRTY YEARS AND GREATER.
ARE SIMILARLY WE ALSO FINANCE
TO PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS
ADDING OVER TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
BEDS TO THE DAVIS AND IRVINE
CAMPUSES- AGAIN BOTH ACOSTA
CAPITAL LESS THAN THAN 3% THESE
EFFORTS HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
AND WE HAVE ADDED OVER TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND BED SINCE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT OF A STUDENT
HOUSING INITIATIVES. AND WE
PLAN TO AT LEAST MATCH THAT
AMOUNT IN THE COMING SIX YEARS.
STILL CAMPUSES STRUGGLE PROVIDE
ENOUGH CAMPUS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO MEET THE STUDENT
DEMAND DUE TO ENROLLMENT
GROWTH. AS WELL AS THE
INCREASINGLY UNAFFORDABLE
HOUSING COSTS IN THE
SURROUNDING MARKETS. MANY OF
OUR CAMPUSES ARE LARGELY BUILT
OUT. WITH AVAILABLE SITES ONLY
ON THE CAMPUS PERIMETER OR IN
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY. ARE
THE REDEVELOPMENT PEOPLE'S PARK
IN BERKELEY PROVIDES A GOOD
EXAMPLE BOTH THE CHALLENGES
WITH USING CAMPUS SOME LAND IN
A NEW WAY BUT ALSO OUR
COMMITMENT TO THE PROCESS OF
UTILIZING THIS LAND. AS THE L.
L. MENTIONED SEQUEL EDUCATION
IS ANOTHER CHALLENGES THAT MANY
CAMPUSES HAVE FACED. AND A
SLOWED ARE ABILITY TO DELIVER
HOUSING PROJECTS IN THESE
DELAYS HAVE RESULTED IN
INCREASING COSTS. FOR THE OTHER
PROJECTS. SEQUEL INDICATIONS
EASILY PURSUED BY ANYONE
OPPOSED TO NEW DEVELOPMENT OR
ENROLLMENT GROWTH OR WHO WANT
TO USE IT AS A NEGOTIATION
TACTIC. IF NOT SETTLED THIS
TYPE OF LITIGATION CAN TAKE
YEARS TO RESOLVE THROUGH THE
COURT SYSTEM AN APPEAL PROCESS.
AND DELAYS IN THE PROJECT
INCREASE CONSTRUCTION COSTS AND
SLOW THE AVAILABILITY OF BEDS
TO OUR STUDENTS. WITHOUT REFORM
A SEQUEL WILL CONTINUE TO SLOW
DOWN OR PREVENT THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THOUSANDS OF URGENTLY
NEEDED. A STUDENT AT. UNDER
CURRENT CONDITIONS WITHOUT THE
STATE PROGRAM BECAUSE YOU SEE
ON AVERAGE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED TO
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER BED TO COMPLETE A
NEW HOUSING PROJECT. THAT
EQUATES TO ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EVERY FOUR
HUNDRED NEW CAMPUS BEDS. THAT
WE ADD TO THE SYSTEM. OUR
DURING THE LAST BUDGET CYCLE-
THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
CREATED THE HIGHER EDUCATION
STUDENT HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM.
WHICH PROVIDES STATE FUNDING
FOR AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING-
CONSTRUCTION. WE HAVE APPLIED
FOR THESE FUNDS IN ANY FUNDS WE
WOULD USE WOULD WREAK READ-
WOULD RESULT IN KEEPING PROJECT
DEBT TO A MINIMUM AND OFFERING
MORE LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AFFORDABLE- CAMPUS OPTIONS AND
WE ARE EXCITED ABOUT THE
PROGRAM. AND GRATEFUL TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
FOR THAT THE FOR CITING
CREATING IT- GERMAN PARTY MIGHT
SAY IN ADDITION TO THIS GRANT
PROGRAM- WE WOULD ALSO BE
INTERESTED IN IF THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE. A YOU
SEE WITH LONG TERM SUSTAINED
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE- ARE
THROUGH WITH NO INTEREST
REVOLVING LOAN FUND. FOR
EXAMPLE OVER THIRTY YEAR PERIOD
A TWO BILLION DOLLAR STATE-
ZERO INTEREST REVOLVING LOAN
FUND WOULD SAVE OUR CAMPUSES.
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY WHEN COMPARED TO OUR
CURRENT- BARRING RATE. AND SUCH
A FUND WOULD ALLOW US TO BOTH-
REDEPLOY THE PRINCIPAL PAYMENTS
ON NEW PROJECTS. AND THE CAMPUS
IS WITH SAVE ON THE INTEREST
EXPENSE. AND THEN THE SAVINGS
WOULD THEN BE PASSED ON TO THE
STUDENTS IN LOWER HOUSING
COSTS. WHICH ARE NOW THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF. OUR
STUDENTS TOTAL COSTS OF
EDUCATION. SO LOOK FOR TO
PARTNER WITH YOU I FINDING.
WAYS FOR YOU SEE TO CONTINUE TO
ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS. TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION THIS MORNING.
OKAY THANK YOU. SO CAN YOU CAN
YOU ADDRESS THAT THAT THIS
QUESTION THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR LATER FROM YOUR CHANCELLOR
IS THAT- SANTA CRUZ AND SAN
DIEGO AND YOU- NATHAN MISTER
ROACH I'M- GONNA HAVE A UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE BEING AT THE OFFICE
THE PRESIDENT GOING TO A CAMPUS
FOR A COUPLE YEARS TO FOCUS ON.
IS THIS NOTION THAT- THAT THIS
DEBT CAPACITY THING IMPAX
CAMPUSES TO PULL THE TRIGGER
AND MAKE THESE PROJECTS A
REALITY. SO YEAH DALY L.
CERTIFIED ISSUE AND SOME YOUR
CAMPUS SAY IT IS AN ISSUE BOB
WHAT DO YOU SAY IT IS NOT IT IS
NOT AN ISSUE WE HAVE WE ARE
CURRENTLY IN OUR OUR LIMITED
PROJECT REVENUE BONDS WERE
RATED DOUBLE A THREE WHICH IS A
VERY STRONG RATING HAS BECAUSE
WE DO IT ON A PORTFOLIO BASIS
SO ALL OF THE HOUSING IN THE
WHOLE SYSTEM. COVERS THE DAT-
ACROSS THE SYSTEM THAT ENABLES
US TO BRING PROJECTS AND KEEP
THEM AFFORDABLE FROM A VERY
EARLY EARLY STAGE ON IT'S ONE
OF THE PROBLEMS WE'RE SEEING IN
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE ONE THEY HAVE
TO BE DONE ON A PROJECT
SPECIFIC FINANCING AND SO THEY
DON'T GETTHE CROSS
SUBSIDIZATION OF OTHER CAMPUSES
AND OTHER- PORTFOLIOS- AND ALSO
WE CANNOT THEN OUR ISSUE BONDS
THROUGH OUR SEQUEL EDUCATION.
WHEREAS WE HAVE BEEN ABLE ISSUE
BONDS AND SOME OF OUR CAMPUSES
EVEN WHEN THEY ARE UNDER A
COURT ORDER THROUGH THE-
THROUGH A PORTFOLIO FINANCING-
I AS I MENTIONED OUR R. COSTA
FINANCING IS REALLY REALLY LOW
AND A TRACTOR RIGHT NOW AND IT
IS PROBABLY THE BIGGEST FACTOR
IN OUR ABILITY TO KEEP THE-
HOUSING AFFORDABLE OKAY SIX SO
YOU WOULD SAY THAT. THAT THEIR
REQUEST ARE HARD TO. DID REVOL
FOR. WHICH WE THINK GREAT IDEA.
WE INTRODUCED. LAST YEAR ON
THIS IT WAS MORE OFTEN TO THE-
BUDGET PROPOSAL BUT WE CAN
REVISIT THAT. AND THEN TO SOME
OF YOUR CAMPUSES ARE SAYING IN
ADDITION TO THAT. IT WAS THE
ONLY A TALKED ABOUT TWO IS FIND
OUT. CASH STATE APPROPRIATION
TO HELP. OTHER BY DOWN THE
AFFORDABILITY LIKE SAN DIEGO'S
GONNA MENTION A LITTLE BIT. OR
JUST. DO YOUR- UP FRONT COSTS
IN YOUR- TOWN HE ENDURED SUCH
FOR YOUR DOWN PAYMENT WOULD
HAVE COVERED CHICHI KIND OF
CATEGORIZE THAT IS THAT
ACCURATE. THAT'S ALRIGHT I
THINK THAT THE REVOLVING LOAN
FUND HAS ADVANTAGE THAT WE CAN
BECAUSE WE CAN NOW LEVERAGE IT
AND REDEPLOY IT. IT'LL IT'LL
HELP US FINANCE MANY MORE
THOUSAND BEDS. I MEAN I DO
THINK THERE IS GAP FINANCING
THAT'S IMPORTANT IN THE
UNCERTAIN SAID SITUATIONS BUT-
THE REVOLVING LOAN FUND ENABLE
US TO BRING DOWN THE COST OF
THAT AND THEN ALSO- REDEPLOYED
AS A PRINCIPAL IS PAID BACK-
SO. THEY HAVE THE ADVANTAGE
THAT WOULD STRETCH OUT OVER
DECADES- IN RUNNING OUR
PROGRAMS YEAH. AND THEN YOU
KNOW WE WE'VE SEEN SOME CITIES.
YOU HAVE ALL THE- THE HIGHER
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA'S
MAINLY THE UC. WE HAVE. HUGE
ENROLLMENT- DEMAND AND JUST
LIMITED SUPPLY AND IN SOME OF
THE UC CAMPUSES. LIKE BERKELEY
AND- AND LA- SANTA CRUZ AND
SANTA BARBARA YEAH WE'RE JUST.
NOT IT'S NOT A PLAN TO GO
AROUND SO SOME CITIES HAVE SUED
AND GROUPS HAVE SUED AND- TWO
TWO QUESTIONS ONE THERE IS
APPARENTLY AT A LOWER COURT.
DECISION IN BERKELEY. WHAT
WHICH THAT- THIS WHAT IMPACT
ALL. GROWTH IT FOR IN YOU SEE
AND CAN CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES
THAT YOU MUST HAVE ONE FOR ONE-
NEW NEW BAD WHEN YOU BRING ON
THE STUDENTS RELATED TO YOUR
LONG RANGE PLAN CAN YOU GIVE US
AN UPDATE ON THAT. YEAH THE
LOWER COURT ACTUALLY RULED THAT
ENROLLMENT WAS A VIABLE- A
FACTOR IN IN SECRET
DETERMINATIONS WHICH THE NEVER
BAN- A PREVIOUSLY AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE WILL BE
CHALLENGING BUT MOST OF OUR
SETTLEMENTS- AS YOU KNOW CHAIR
MCCARTY DO INVOLVE FOR EXAMPLE
YOU KNOW SANTA CRUZ IN THEIR
LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT PLAN
SAID THAT THEY WOULD BUILD A
NEW BAD FOR EVERY SINGLE
STUDENT. THAT WAS BROUGHT ON UC
SANTA BARBARA- HAD SAID THE-
THE- THE SAME THING YOU KNOW
THEY'RE UNDER POTENTIAL THREAT
FROM THE CITY BELIEVED ON- ON
ON THEIR ENROLLMENT I THINK
YOU'LL FIND GOING FORWARD
ESPECIALLY IN THESE VERY- THE
LAND CONSTRAINED CAMPUSES AT
THAT WILL BE A FACTOR OF MANY.
OF OUR A LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT
PLANS. OKAY AND THEN DID YOU
WANT TO POTENTIALLY ADDRESS
THIS. THIS UC SANTA BARBARA.
ISSUE AND WHAT SOME OF THE NEXT
STEPS ARE THERE RELATED TO THE-
THE DESIGN AND I'LL SAY THAT I
WENT DOWN AND TOWARD THIS
FACILITY OVER THE SUMMER THE
HOUSE CANCER YANG I THOUGHT IT
WAS AN AMAZING IDEA. THAT YOU
SEE HAS. UC SANTA BARBARA HAS A
HUGE HOUSING CRISIS THERE AND I
LIVE ESTAS OVERPOPULATED AND
KIDS LIVING IN SQUALOR THERE.
HE SENT TO HAITI IN ISLA VISTA.
AND SO THEY HAVE THIS. THIS
PAST WHERE THEY HAVE SOME YEAH.
ESSENTIALLY THEIR COURTYARD AND
SOME OTHER LOWER INTENSE USES
AND SO SANTA BARBARA'S GONNA
MOVE THOSE A MILE AWAY IT IS A
PROPERTY THEY BOUGHT LIKE AN
ABANDONED BAG. WAREHOUSE WHICH
I THINK IS A GREAT IDEA AND
THEN USE THAT AREA ON CAMPUS.
TO DO A DANCE HOUSING PROJECT
WHICH IS. GREAT YOU KNOW.
INFILL ANYA SMART GROWTH.
OPPORTUNITY THERE- AND WHEN I
TOWARD I DIDN'T I DIDN'T EVEN
RECOGNIZE TOWARD THE MOCK UP
AND I DIDN'T EVEN RECOGNIZE THE
FACT THAT BECAUSE IT WAS A MOCK
UP WE DON'T HAVE ACTUAL WINDOWS
THAT THERE WEREN'T. THE WINDOWS
AND SO THAT'S BECOME THE ISSUE
AND SO FORTH SO. I THINK THE
ISSUE IS WE WANT MORE STUDENT
HOUSING THERE WE LIKE THIS
FORTY FIVE. HUNDRED INTERNET
THING THAT ALLOWS US TO. MEET
THE NEEDS OF SANTA BARBARA
WHICH- YOU KNOW HAS A HUGE
HOUSING CRISIS IN THAT CITY.
THANK OF MISTER BENNETT WERE
HERE SO EARLY MONDAY WOULD
ATTEST TO THAT. BUT ALSO WE
WOULD ENROLL MORE CALIFORNIANS
THAT TOP AS YOU KNOW WE'RE BEEN
HAMMERING ON YOU FOR YEARS
ABOUT THIS AND SO. WE CAN'T DO
THAT WITHOUT HAVING. TO YOU
KNOW IN HUGE INFUSION OF
HOUSING THERE ON CAMPUS SO-
WHAT WHAT ARE WE DOING GOING
FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THIS IS
THAT THIS WORKS YEAH WELL BOB
FIRST OF ALL TO ADDRESS- MISTER
DONALD EARLIER QUESTION WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL WHEN WE DO GET
PHILANTHROPY FOR. HOUSING IT'S
QUITE RARE- ALL RIGHT IN THIS
CASE YOU KNOW- MR MUNGER'S
PLEDGED OVER TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS TOWARDS IS
CONSTRUCTION. WE DO HAVE SOME
CASES OF A BREAK THESE GETTING
A- DORM THT'S BUILT. ENTIRELY
BY AYE DONOR- AND THAT'S VERY
APPRECIATED BECAUSE IT HELPS
BRING DOWN THE OVERALL COST
ACROSS THE SYSTEM. AND YOU SEE
SAN FRANCISCO AS MR TANG- MAY
KNOW- HAS RECEIVED SEVERAL
GIFTS- TOWARDS HOUSING WHICH IS
VERY. VERY NECESSARY THEY- ARE
ON THE ISSUE OF THIS- HOW PA.
IT'S VERY EARLY IN THE PROCESS
REVIEW AND APPROVAL THE CAMPUS
HAS NOT YET- EVEN COMPLETED
THEIR- THEIR ER THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT-
THAT WILL NEED TO GO NOT ONLY
TO THE REGIONS BUT ALSO TO THE
COASTAL COMMISSION FOR REVIEW
AND APPROVAL. AND ALSO BECAUSE
OF ITS PROXIMITY TO THE SANTA
BARBARA AIRPORT TODAY ACTUALLY
HAS TO BE REVIEWED- AS YOU BUT
I DO KNOW CHAIRMAN PARTY BY THE
HEIGHT- IF THEY HAD. THAT ALL
THOSE- IT HAPPENS AND IT WOULD
COME TO THE REGION'S FOR
APPROVAL BOTH FOR SEQUEL- FOR
BUDGET FOR DESIGN AND AN
EXTERNAL FINANCING THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT
VERY CLOSELY BECAUSE- AS AS YOU
MENTIONED EVEN WITH THE GIFT
WOULD STILL BE OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS IN FINANCING AND THAT
WOULD BE A BIG PART OF OUR- OUR
OVERALL LOVE. A PORTFOLIO WE
WANT TO LOOK AT IT IN TERMS OF
THE IMPACT ON ON CREDIT- YOU
KNOW IT IS UNPRECEDENTED IN
SIZE AND SCOPE IN DESIGN AND-
I'M SURE THERE WILL BE A LOT OF
SCRUTINY TO- TO THE PROJECT-
BUT THAT BEING SAID AS YOU. AS
YOU NOTED- UC SANTA BARBARA
REALLY REALLY NEEDS HOUSING
THEY'RE SEEING IT MORETHAN
EVER THIS FALL. THEY HAVE THEIR
A 118% OF THE HOUSING CAPACITY
BECAUSE- I LOVE THIS THAT WE'RE
YOU KNOW KIDS USED TO JUST CRAM
AND THEY'VE THEY'VE- HAD MUCH.
LESS DENSITY THERE BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC AND SO KIDS HAVE
BEEN LEFT WITHOUT HOUSING. THE
UC SANTA BARBARA'S BEEN DOING A
LOT OF TROUBLES FOR DOUBLES AND
QUADS OR TRIPLES AND THINGS
LIKE THAT- AND THEY HAVE NOT
ADDED ANY HOUSING SINCE THE
FALL OF TWENTY- TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SO. WE'RE GOING TO
WORK FOR THE CAMPUS AND SUPPORT
THEM ANYWAY WE CAN TO TRY TO
GET MORE HOUSING IS. AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE- I ALSO THINK THAT
THERE'S A POSSIBILITY OF DOING
THINGS IN COMBINATION WITH SOME
OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES LIKE.
SANTA BARBARA CITY COLLEGE TO
BUY YOU KNOW TO LOOK AT JOINT
HOUSING PROGRAMS. THAT WOULD
HOUSE BOTH UCSB AND SANTA
BARBARA CITY COLLEGE- STUDENTS.
AND QUESTIONS MISTER DON. IT'S
JUST A BACK AN EARLIER COME YOU
MAY WITH REGARD TO I BELIEVE
UC'S CRUZ UC SAY BARBARA AGREED
TO CAP THEIR ENROLLMENT- AND
LESS THEY BUILT A UNIT OF
HOUSING FOR EVERY NEW STUDENT
DID YOU STATE THAT YEAH WHAT
ARE YOU SEE SANTA CRUZ JUST
PASS OUR LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT
PLAN WHERE THEY PLAN TO ADD
ABOUT NINE THOUSAND STUDENTS
OVER THE NEXT DECADE. BUT WHAT
THEY'VE COMMITTED TO DO FOR
THE- YOU FOR THE CITY AND THE
COUNTY IS THAT THEY WOULD ADD A
NEW BD FOR ALL NEW ENROLLMENT
SO WOULD IT WOULD LET IT WOULD
MITIGATE SOME OF THE IMPACT ON
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY AND
THEIR RENTAL MARKET. SO IT'S
BEEN OF THE OF THE OBJECTIVE.
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN FACT JUST.
PRETTY MUCH A COUPLE
LEGISLATORS ARE HERE IN THE
ROOM TODAY TO INCREASE
ENROLLMENT. SO IS THIS SOME.
SOME ROUND ABOUT WAY TO
ACTUALLY. ENSURE THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO INCREASE
ENROLLMENT- NO I THINK WE WANT
TO INCREASE ENROLLMENT WE ALSO
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
BEING- YOU KNOW SENSITIVE TO
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY AND-
SANTA CRUZ IN PARTICULAR THE
CHANCE WILL BE- TESTIFYING BUT-
YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S ONE. OUR
COMMUNITY WHERE THEY THE- CITY
REALLY FEELS THAT THE STRAIN OF
THE GROWTH HAS BEEN- IMPACT ON
THEIR HOUSING MARKET. WELL I
LIVE RIGHT BY LONG BEACH STATE.
AND IT'S A BIG CAMPUS AND I
KNOW IT WAS THERE WHEN I MOVED
IN. RIGHT SO I HAD TO PUT UP
WITH THE IMPACTS AND I SEE A
GREATER BENEFIT. TO THAT THAN
JUST MY OWN HOME SO I THAT
CONCERNS ME THAT INDIVIDUAL
UNIVERSITIES WOULD BE ALLOWED
TO. TO IN EFFECT LIMIT THEIR
GROWTH. IS THAT WELL AND I
DON'T SENATE REASONABLE CONCERN
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE NOT
LIMITING THE GROWTH OF JUST
SAYING THAT THEY WILL IT WILL
ADD A BAD WHICH WE CAN DO. YOU
KNOW WHY AND HOW THEY CAN'T DO
THAT WHEN. THEY DON'T HAVE ONE
OF THE DON'T HAVE THAT.
RESOURCES TO A BEDS ONE HALF.
WHAT WE DO ASSIST WE DO HAVE.
AS A SYSTEM HOW THE ABILITY TO
ADD MORE BEDS TO- YOU KNOW TO
MEET THE GROWING DEMANDS. OKAY
I'LL TAKE YOUR WORD FOR THAT
BUT- I JUST GOTTA GET IN. MY
CONCERN. WILL BE THIS BE SOME
ATTEMPT BY INDIVIDUAL
UNIVERSITIES. TO LIMIT THEIR
GROWTH YEAH I KNOW IT WASN'T I
MEAN THIS WAS DRIVEN MOSTLY BY
THEIR- YOU KNOW NEGOTIATIONS
AND RELATIONSHIPS WITH THAT.
pCOMMUNITIES. NOT BY ANY DESIRE
TO- I MEAN THEY WANTED TO GROW
I MEAN BASICALLY GROW BY FIFTY
PERCENT. BY PROVIDE HOUSING TO
DO THAT. THANK YOU THINK AND I
JUST ANOTHER QUESTION WITH
REGARD TO THE UCSB PROJECT- SO
I MEAN IT IS IT. IS YOU. THE IT
INDIVIDUALS OFFER THEM TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. RIGHT
NOW THERE'S ALSO OTHER. MONEY
FROM THE UNIVERSITY COMING AND
I DO BELIEVE THE PROJECTS LIKE
ONE. ONE BILLION DOLLARS PLUS.
I SAW HOW MUCH SWAYED AS AN
INDIVIDUAL DONOR HAVE. OVER THE
ULTIMATE DESIGN OF A FACILITY
WHICH FOR WHICH THEY WANT TO.
GET MONEY FOR THE- THE DONOR-
I. TEND TO NOT HAVE MUCH SWAY
THAT YOU KNOW THE DESIGN IS ALL
DONE BY APPROVED BY THE REGENTS
AND IS THE PROPERTY OF THE
REGION'S- YOU KNOW IN THIS CASE
THAT THE DONOR HAD SOME VERY.
SPECIFIC IDEAS ABOUT- ABOUT
HOUSING AND HE'S PUT THEM INTO
EFFECT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
MICHIGAN SO- YOU KNOW HE HE HAS
WEIGHED IN WITH THE CAMPUS
ARCHITECTS ON THAT. KNOW
WHETHER THAT IS THE ULTIMATE
DESIGN YOU KNOW WE'LL HAVE IT
WILL HAVE TO SEE THERE ARE.
SOME ADVANTAGES OF IT IN TERMS
OF AMASSING BUT THEY'RE ALSO
SOME. SOME CONCERNS ABOUT IT.
YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY IN A- A
POSTCODE WORLD. OKAY AND ABSENT
THE FINANCING. I MEAN. IT WILL
LOOK BACK TO THE FOR. OTHER
OTHER EXAMPLES ACROSS THE UC
SYSTEM WHERE. A DONOR HAS
GIVEN. A GOOD SUM OF MONEY AND
THEY GET TO. HAVE A ROLE IN
THAT IS THE DESIGN. IS
INDIVIDUAL TO NOT HAVE A ROLE
IN THE DESIGN THERE ARE.
PROJECTS THAT ARE CALLED DONOR
DEVELOPED PROJECTS WHERE THE
DONOR WILL ACTUALLY- BUT- IT
ALL HAS TO GO THROUGH THE BOTH
THE CAMPUS DESIGN PROCESS AND
THE REGION'S BUT THEN THE DONOR
WILL ACTUALLY. THESE ARE MOSTLY
FOR ACADEMIC BUILDINGS THE
DON'T THEIR DONOR WILL
ACTUALLY- CONSTRUCT THE
BUILDING AND THEN GIFTED TO
THE- TO THE UNIVERSITY SO
SEVERAL OF OUR CAMPUSES HAVE
EXAMPLES OF I DON'T TO DEVELOP
PROJECTS. YOU GOT IT THANK YOU.
I GUESS MY CONCERN IS THAT
SOMEONE'S GIVING MONEY FOR A
BUILDING AND I GET TO PARTAKE
IN THE OUTSIDE OF THE BUILDING
ARE THEY DRIVING THE COST UP SO
MUCH. THAT IT MIGHT NOT EVEN BE
WORTH HAVING THAT DONOR
INVOLVED IN THE- OF THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THAT FACILITY
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S ONE OF
THINGS THAT WILL BE LOOKING AT
CLOSELY YEAH THANK I THINK THE
AND THERE AGAIN THAT'S FOR. THE
RESIDENTIAL HOUSING SITE AS
WELL AS THE OTHER FACILITIES I
JUST LAST ONE HAS TO DO WITH
THE DESIGNED THIS BUILDING AND
UCSB APPARENTLY HAD NO WINDOWS.
AND I BELIEVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND PROBABLY.
PROBABLY NONE OF THE LOCAL
LEVEL THROUGH BUILDING. CODES I
DON'T BELIEVE WE CAN BUILD A
BUILDING. A RESIDENTIAL
FACILITY WITHOUT WHEN. YEAH
ONCE- VETERANS AN EXIT- I HOME
CAN'T DO THE- MIKE. RIGHT YOU
KNOW HOME WINDOWS HAVE TO BE SO
EITHER HAVE TO BE SO MANY. PER
SQUARE FOOTAGE OF A BEDROOM.
HOW WOULD IT BE THAT. A
RESIDENTIAL COMPLEX TO BE
DESIGNED WITHOUT ANY WINDOWS.
WELL THAT'S ONE OF THINGS THAT
WILL BE COMING THROUGH IN THE
IN THE DESIGN PROCESS AND ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT HAS BEEN-
ALREADY. YOU KNOW CRITICIZED IN
IN SOME OF THE PRESS. IT
DOESN'T- YOU KNOW I TOWARD THE
MOCK UP AS AS- J. MCCARTY I
DID. ITS THE- THE- THE BEDROOMS
HAVE NO WINDOWS IN THESE
VIRTUAL WINDOWS ARE. YOU KNOW
95% OF THEM HAVE VIRTUAL
WINDOWS. THE COMMON AREAS HAVE.
HUGE WINDOWS SO IT'S- THE
NOTION OF THE DESIGN IS THAT
THE COMMON AREAS WHERE STUDENTS
WOULD SPEND. MOST OF THEIR TIME
IN THOSE ARE ARE YOU KNOW HAVE-
AMPLE- LIGHT AND LOTS OF LOTS
OF WINDOWS. BUT BECAUSE OF THE
MASSING OF THE BUILDINGS A LOT
OF THE- BEDROOMS THEMSELVES ARE
INTERIOR. AND I GUESS IS THE UC
COULD DO THAT BECAUSE- THEIR
STATE AGENCY THEY WOULD HAVE TO
FOLLOW- LOCAL BUILDING. ARE WE
THOUGHT THE FOLLOWED. CODES IN.
TITLE TWENTY FOUR AND ALL THOSE
THINGS SO. BUT WE KNOW WE
THAT'S ONE OF THINGS THAT WILL
BE LOOKED AT- DURING THIS
PROCESS SO AS SOON I'M ASSUMING.
THE CITY OF SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY SARAH BARNHAM WHATEVER
MAYBE. DOESN'T HAVE AND I'M NOT
ASKING YOU TO ANSWER THIS
QUESTION DOESN'T HAVE A
REQUIREMENT THAT YOU HAVE A
WINDOW IN THE BEDROOM NO I
DON'T KNOW THAT THAT WOULD BE A
VERY UNIQUE YEAH MY EXPERIENCE
WITH CONSTRUCTION THAT WOULD BE
VERY UNIQUE- WITH THAT AGAIN I
GUESS MY OVERALL CONCERN IS
THAT. WE NOT GET HELD HOSTAGE
BY DONORS WHO WANT TO A GOOD
THING BUT THAT WE NOT GET HELD
HOSTAGE BY THEM FOR ALL THE OF
THE FINAL PRODUCT AND THAT WE
NOT BE SO DESPERATE FOR MONEY
THAT IT JUST DRIVES UP THE
COST- OF THE END PRODUCT. YEAH
I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA.
JUST TO FOLLOW UP. MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LONG BEACH. THE
CONTRIBUTION- IN THE UC SANTA
BARBARA A PROJECT HIS HIS
CONTRIBUTION IS- MR MUNGER'S
PHILANTHROPIC CONTRIBUTION. IT
HOW MUCH OF THAT- USER-
REQUIREMENT THAT YOU SEE DO IT
THE WAY THAT THAT- THAT HE'S
ASKING FOR HIS CONTRIBUTION-
THIS RE I DO NOT KNOW THE GIFT
AGREEMENT WHETHER THEY'RE AT
THAT IS THEY A REQUIREMENT I DO
KNOW IT HAS TO GO THROUGH THE
REGIONS IN THE REGIONS. YOU
KNOW ARE THE ALTERNATE- DID
WILL BE ULTIMATELY DECIDING ON
BUDGET AND DESIGNED AND
FINANCING SO THEY ARE NOT AT
ALL SUBJECT TO DO THE GIFT
AGREEMENT THAT THE CAMPUS MAY
HAVE. GOOD WEATHER I HIS GIFT
IS DEPENDENT ON HIS DESIGN
YOU'RE NOT SURE THAT I'M NOT
I'M NOT SURE. THANK THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MEMBER TANGER
BUDGET SHARE WELCOME YOU HAVE
SOME COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR JUST
QUICK QUESTION MR PRESIDENT- DO
ALL THE TEN CAMPUSES HAVE BEEN
LAID OUT. SOME SORT OF LONGER
TERM HOUSING PLANS I THINK YOU
MENTIONED THAT SOME OF THE
CAMPUS IS AN HONOR FOR ALL OF
THEM HAVE. CAN JUST TRY TO GET
A SENSE OF CALM I KNOW THAT
JUST ACCORDING TO THE RIGHT UP
THERE ARE STILL THOUSANDS OF
UNITS UNDER CONSTRUCTION. JUST
TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF YOU
KNOW OVER THE NEXT FIVE FIVE OR
TEN YEARS HOW MANY UNITS ARE
BEING PLANNED- FROM THE VARIOUS
CAMPUSES YEAH ARE ARE MY OFFICE
THAT COORDINATES THAT- MISTER
KING AND OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS. WE HAVE PLANNED- NEARLY
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND-
ADDITIONAL BEDS- NOW A LOT OF
THAT IS SUBJECT TO GETTING THE-
THE PROJECTS APPROVED IN
GETTING THEM FINANCED BUT- YOU
KNOW AND MANY CAMPUSES HAVE
ADOPTED PRETTY AGGRESSIVE GOALS
ARE GUARANTEEING HOUSING FOR
TWO YEARS OR THREE YEARS- AND
THAT THAT IS YOU KNOW IT'S SAM
UCSF WANTS TO DO IT JUST TO.
ATTRACT AND KEEP. YOU KNOW
STUDENTS AND RESIDENTS. GREAT
THANK YOU. MISTER CHANGES ON
THAT WE DID HAVE A BILL YEAR
THAT WAS OUR BILL THAT WE DID
TOGETHER THE REVOLVING FUND
THAT WHEN THE BUDGET SO WE
AMENDED AT THE END TO THE COULD
BILL THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
REQUIRING THE UC AND CSU TO
GIVE US THESE FIVE TEN YEAR.
HOUSING PLANTS SO YEAH. DO YOU
HAVE A BALLOT QUESTION TO. OKAY-NOT MR LEE. THANK YOU JUST
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP ON MY
CALLER FROM LONG BEACH IS
COMMENTS AS WELL SO WHILE
STRUCTURES REGISTERS
RESIDENTIAL STRUCTURES OF THE
UC DON'T HAVE TO FOLLOW
BUILDING CODE OF THEIR OF THEIR
OWN RIGHT BUT NOT THE- COUNTY
OR THE CITY'S BUILDING CODES
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT YEAH. SO
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTIES OR
PROPERTIES. OF THESE THE
ISLANDS- HOW DO YOU COME TO A
CONCLUSION OF HOW DANCER HOW
TALL HOW BUILDINGS HOW BIG THE
STRUCTURES ARBY'S OBVIOUSLY
THEY NEED IS VAST AND ACUTE.
AND WE DO HAVE OPENING IS JUST
LIKE IN SANTA CRUZ THAT. ARE
SENSITIVE TO THESE THINGS BUT
HOW DO YOU GO ABOUT
PRIORITIZING THE NEED OF THE
CALIFORNIA OF OUR SKILL FOR
STUDENTS AND FACULTY WITH THAT
A LOCAL JURISDICTION LIKE THAT.
YEAH AND THAT'S THAT IS A- IT'S
A GOOD QUESTION THAT IT'S A
TRADE OFF THAT WE FACE IN EVERY
PROJECT ABOUT TRYING TO.
MAXIMIZE THE DENSITY IN THE
AMOUNT OF HOUSING WE CAN
PROVIDE BUT DO IT IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE- OF THE LOCAL- A
COMMUNITY AND OFTENTIMES WHEN
YOU'LL HEAR. THE CRITICISM OF
THE PROJECT IT'S NOT ABOUT THE
PROJECT BUT IT'S ABOUT THIS
THIS IS YOUR OR SCALE UP- AND-
SO IT IS A YOU KNOW WE- WE GO
BACK AND FORTH IN THAT IT NOT
ONLY HAS TO. DO WITH STUDENT
HOUSING THAT ALSO HAS TO A
FACULTY AND STAFF HOUSING YOU
KNOW IRVINE IS VERY EXTENSIVE-
A PROGRAM FOR- FACTOR THE
HOUSING WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE PROVIDING FOR AS MANY-
FACULTY AND STAFF AS AS AS
POSSIBLE SO. THAT ALL COMES UP
IN THE- IN THE- IN THE DESIGN
REVIEW IT ALSO DOES- CONTRIBUTE
TO THE FINANCING- OF IT BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THAT. WITH THE
DENTURE THE PROJECT YOU KNOW
THE MORE REVENUE THAT CAN- GET
THAT CAN SUPPORT THE- THE COSTS
ABSOLUTELY AND THEN WITH THE
EXEMPTION TO LOCAL. STATE
BUILDING CODES ORDINANCES IS
THAT ALSO TRUE IF SAY A UC
CAMPUS OR THE SYSTEM ACQUIRES
NEW. PROPERTY OUTSIDE ITS
ORIGINAL FOOTPRINT- IT AND WE
ARE- OWN. ENTIRE AGENTS SO WE
HAVE TO FOLLOW US LAW WE ARE.
FOR LOW ENTITLEMENTS YES WELL
AS- I MEAN I JUST KNOW FROM MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE OFF OF
SERVING THE ASSEMBLY AND ALSO
WHEN I WAS A DAVIS THERE'S
ALWAYS A LOT OF- CONTROVERSY
ALLOWED CONTENTION BETWEEN THE
DENSITY OF. OF HOUSING AND WILL
COMMUNITY BUT I DEFINITELY
STRESS FOR THE UC AND ALL.
PUBLIC ALL THE SYSTEMS
DEFINITELY HAVE THAT. A FRIEND
OF MINE TO SERVER CALIFORNIA
FACULTY AND STUDENTS OF IS THAT
IS THE GREATEST NEED AND I HOPE
TO SHARE THE SAME SENTIMENT AS
ARE. CALLED ONE BEACH BUT YOU
KNOW FOLKS MOVED IN. WITH A
GREAT DRAW OF UNIVERSITY BE
NEAR THEM I HOPE THAT THEY'LL
BE ACCEPTING OF MORE PEOPLE
GOING INTO THE DOOR THOSE
BENEFITS. TO REALLY HOPE BILL
PRIOR TO PRIORITIZE THAT.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE LAN BEING
SO SCARED SO MANY OF YOU SEE
THAT WOULD BE A WASTE OF REAL
ESTATE NOT TO GO DANCE OR NOT
TO GO TALLER IF. IF ABLE. TO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU YEAH.
THANK YOU AT. SEVEN THIRTY HERE
TO FOLLOW QUESTIONS. YES. JUST
A MORMON FIVE QUICKS SO I THINK
COMMON. YOUR ONE THE REASONS WE
PRAY. HOUSING IN THE BUDGET WAS
ONE THE OPINION THAT YOUR
SEGMENT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CSU TICKET FRANKLY BUILT MANY
HOUSING UNITS FRANKLY CHEAPER
FASTER. BECAUSE OF THE STATE
AUTHORITY AS WELL AS STATE
CONTROLLED LAND IN THEIR
ABILITY TO MOVE THESE PROJECTS
THROUGH OBVIOUSLY THE FASTER
THESE PROJECTS TO BUILD THE
CHEAPER THEY WOULD BE. AND SO I
THINK. GIVEN THAT SO MANY OF
THE CAMPUSES ARE IN VERY
IMPACTED AREAS SO YOU MAY JUST
HAVE A CISCO BUT- BERKELEY
SANTA CRUZ DAVIS LOS ANGELES
I'M IN THE LIST GOES ON AND ON
HOW MANY OF THESE ARE. IMPACTED
AREAS WERE- HOMELESSNESS IS ON
THE RISE AND WE'RE SEEING
UNFORTUNATELY A RISE IN
HOMELESSNESS NOT JUST OF OUR
STUDENTS BUT ALSO OUR FACULTY
AND OUR STAFF. WERE WE HEAR TOO
MANY STORIES WERE YOU HAVE YOU
KNOW LECTURER SLEEPING IN THEIR
CARS BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD
TO LIVE ANYWHERE. CLOSE TO
CAMPUS SO THEY'RE LIVING IN A
COUPLE HOURS AWAY AND THEN-
THEY ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
JUST- SLEEPING IN THE CARS. SO
I THINK I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE MY SUPPORT. FOR ALL
THE SEGMENTS TO REALLY. AS
AGGRESSIVELY AS POSSIBLE BUILD.
AS MUCH HOUSING IF THEY COULD
DO I APPRECIATE THAT. THE
DIALOGUE OF ALL THE LOCAL
PLANNING CODES I THINK THAT IS
VERY MUCH UP TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WE HOPE THAT THE
PLANNING DOT. LOOK CAMPUSES CAN
WORK WITH PLANNING DEPARTMENT
PLANNING DEPARTMENTS IN CITIES
I KNOW THAT THAT BERKELEY WERE
WHERE YOU WERE AT THE SCENE A
LOT OF CONTENTION WITH CITY
FUND THAT'S BEEN ONGOING EVER
SINCE I WAS A STUDENT THERE. SO
I THINK IT IS IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO CAMPUSES HAVE A
GOOD RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES BUT- HAVING
SAID THAT THIS IS DEFINITELY A
PRIORITY FOR US. WELL WE KNOW
THAT. WE CAN'T HAVE A- ROLE
LOOKED WITHOUT A HOUSING- WE
KNOW THOSE HAND IN WITH THE
HEARD. WHAT HAPPENED SENATE TO
USE AGO WHEN I IN. HE SAW. THE
CHANCELLOR DOUBLE SEND OUT THE-
ASK PEOPLE TO YOU KNOW CAN THE
PEOPLE PUT UP STUDENT AND
PEOPLE TO PEOPLE PUT. UP RIGHT.
AND SO- THIS IS WHAT PRIORITY
IT'S THE THIS IS A LIFE THINK
IT'S NOW JUST MONEY THAT WE YOU
AN OF DISCUSS. SOMETHING THAT
IS COMPLETELY SEPARATE FOR THE
SADNESS TO BUILD. HOUSING AND I
APPRECIATE THE TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND UNITS THAT IS BEING
BUILT OR BEING PLANNED OF THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS. I WOULD HOPE.
THAT THERE IS SOME LEVEL OF
DISTRIBUTION BETWEEN THE
DIFFERENT- CAMPUSES- PARTLY
BECAUSE- YOU'RE SOME CAMPUSES
SAN DIEGO'S GET UCLA IRVINE-
DAVIS HAVE BEEN A LITTLE BIT
MORE AGGRESSIVE OTHERS ARE-
YOU'RE STILL KIND OF LAGGING IN
TERMS OF SANTA CRUZ OR SANTA
BARBARA BERKELEY- OBVIOUSLY
MERCED THE BRAND NEW CAMPUS
IT'S A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
BUT I WOULD HOPE THAT THERE
WOULD BE. EQUAL NUMBER OF
DIPLOMATIC DISTRIBUTION BUT
ALSO THAT SOME OF THESE
CAMPUSES. REALLY- CATCH UP
BECAUSE WHERE THERE'S LESS
HOUSING ARE SOME OF THE MOST
IMPACTED AREAS WHICH IS SANTA
CRUZ SANTA BARBARA IN BERKELEY-
PROBABLY THE- MOST DIFFICULT
PLACES FOR STUDENTS TO FIND OFF
CAMPUS HOUSING SO. I THINK IT
IS. YOU KNOW VERY IMPORTANT
THING WITH WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE. A SUPPORT THE CAMPUS IS
WHY WE THE SIX AND- THE
DIFFERENT CHEN COMPLY TO US.
BECAUSE IF WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT
OF SUPPORT YOU ALL NEED TO GET
THIS. HOUSING BUILT BECAUSE WE
THINK IT'S PART OF THE OVERALL
HOUSING- HOUSING EQUATION IN
THIS ENTIRE STATE. THANK YOU
AND I'LL I ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR
MENTIONING- TACKLING STAFF
HOUSING BECAUSE IT'S BECOME A
HUGE ISSUE IN TERMS OF
RECRUITING AND RETAINING AND
RETAINING. WE'VE GOT A GREAT
MORTGAGE I PROGRAM BUT-
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO CAN.
BUILD OUR OWN CONTROL COSTS IS
REALLY GOING TO HELP US BUILD
OUT THE UNIVERSITY. WE WERE ON
WHEN I WAS WORKING AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE WE'RE VERY
LUCKY. WE HAD A VICE CHANCELLOR
WHO BECAME A CHANCE FOR ANOTHER
CAMPUS. HAD THE FORESIGHT TO
BARI A NUMBER OF APARTMENT
UNITS ON A PRIVATE PER MINUTES
AND THAT GOT THEM INTO CAMPUS
CONTROL WHICH WAS A- HUGE WIN
FOR THAT. FOR THAT PARTICULAR
CAMPUS- THANKS FOR GRADUATE
STUDENT AS WELL AS FOR FACULTY
OFFICE. OKAY THANK YOU I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE ONE ONE COMMENT
TO I THINK MISTER O'DONNELL
ASKED THIS QUESTION ABOUT. THIS
IS THAT THE DAYS AGREEMENTS FOR
ONE FOR ONE HOUSING. AND THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT WE SUPPORT
ITS RIGHT TO. TO PUSH DOWNTURN
AS YOU SAID PASTOR WE TRYING TO
PUSH OUT IN ROMAN. MY
UNDERSTANDING TALKING TO DAVIS
AND OTHERS IS. THEY'RE GETTING
SUED BY THE CITY COUNCIL AND BY
NAME BE GROUPS. AND THESE ARE
PART OF THE SUPPLEMENTS BUT IT
AND ALL THESE- IN ALL THESE
EXAMPLES THAT I SAW FIRST HAND
I'D I DECIDED THIS SUMMER THREE
OF THEM. AND FALL CAMPUSES THAT
TAB DISAGREEMENT REMAINS. AT
SANTA CRUZ SANTA BARBARA DAVIS.
THEY THEY WERE ALL IN THE WORKS
TO BUILD. HOUSING WHICH WOULD.
BASICALLY GO IN TANDEM WITH OUR
EFFORTS TO EXPAND ENROLLMENT
SO. YEAH WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE
THESE THINGS STOP OUR EFFORTS
BECAUSE AS AS YOU SAID. WE'RE
TRYING TO ENROLL TWENTY
THOUSAND. I'M NOT SURE IF YOU
SAID THIS BUT IT DID YOU SEE A
SAID THIS FOR TRYING ON ROLL
TWENTY THOUSAND MORE.
CALIFORNIANS BY TWENTY THIRTY
AND THAT'S THROUGH FUNDING THEM
THROUGH US WHICH THIS YEAR WE
GREEN LET SIXTY EIGHT HUNDRED.
AND WE'RE REDUCING NON RESIDENT
STUDENTS AS WELL. AND YOU'LL
SEE MONEY IN THE BUDGET A FEW
WEEKS I KNOW SOME PEOPLE HAVE
COMPLAINED WORK WE DID FIND
THESE NEW STUDENTS BUT AS YOU
KNOW ALL THE STUDENTS DON'T
COME UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THERE'S NO REASON TO PUT MONEY
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET FOR
STUDENTS ACTUALLY DON'T SELL
OUT. THERE YOURSELF. WE
AUTHORIZE THOSE STUDENTS IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET AND THE
MONEY WILL BE THERE IN A FEW
WEEKS. IN THE GENERAL BUDGET
WILL WILL WILL WILL- RATIFIED
THAT WILL BE THERE. AT THE END
OF JUNE TO FUND IS TO IS WHEN
THEY COME INTO FALL TWENTY
TWENTY BUT WE WITH MY NOSE
MISTER. AND I WERE COULD MISTER
DRAKE TO COME TALK ABOUT THAT.
DEFINED AT LEAST. TWENTY
THOUSAND BY TWENTY THIRTY
BECAUSE WE ALREADY FUNDED SIX.
SIX THOUSAND YEAH PLUS THIS
YEAR SO THAT'S WHAT. YOU KNOW
FOURTEEN THOUSAND MORE TO GO.
FOR THE NEXT NINE YEARS AND I
THOUGHT IN BUSINESS OR NOT YOU
KNOW WE WANT TO FIND AT LEAST
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED. PER YEAR
SO I THINK THAT NUMBER SHOULD
BE BETWEEN TWENTY AND THIRTY
THOUSAND. NEW SLOTS FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND SO THIS. GOES
HAND IN HAND TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR WORKING HOURS FOR THE
HOUSING SO THAT HOUSING YES SO
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE WE ARE TOTAL
SUPPORT TO MAKE SURE WE DO THEM
BOTH. IT'S TO EXPAND ACCESS
YEAH YOU JUST REPORT REAL QUICK
KANA WHERE THISGOES IS. TODAY
LOOKS LIKE IT'S TO UC'S THAT
HAVE AGREEMENTS WHY SHOULD NEXT
YEAR ALL OF THEM WHY SHOULDN'T
CSU IS WHY SHOULDN'T COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND THAT'S WHERE THIS
THIS THAT THIS COULD GO. SO I
THINK GIVING INDIVIDUAL
UNIVERSITIES THE AUTHORITY. TO
SAY HEY ARMAMENTS CAT UNLESS WE
BUILD NEW HOUSING UNITS- CAN
HAVE SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. AND I GET THAT.
PLACES LIKE YOU SEE GRANTED
SANTA CRUZ ACCEPT OR THEY MIGHT
NOT GROW LIKE GROWTH. BUT THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS
COMMUNITIES CALIFORNIA HAVE TO
GROW THEY HAVE TO GET THEIR
RAIN AND NUMBER SIX ADDRESS.
AND YOU SAY WELL WE'RE OUT
UNLESS YOU GIVE US MORE MONEY
FOR HOUSING IS AN ACCEPTABLE TO
ME. BUT AGAIN A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN THIS ROOM I WORKED HARD ON
INCREASING OUR OWN BUT ALSO
INCREASING THE DOLLARS THAT WE
ALLOCATED YEAH BIG. BIG MONEY
FOR- FOR HOUSING SO I
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OKAY- MISSED. I COULD
JUST COME YESTERDAY HAS COME
YEAH I WOULD JUST SAY I THINK
IT'S A IT'S AN EXCELLENT POINT
AND I THINK- I THINK I WOULD
JUST SPEAK FOR- OUR OUR HOUSE I
DON'T THINK. THAT THIS IS THE
ASSEMBLY WE'VE REALLY BEEN
LEADING ON THIS ISSUE AND ROMAN
SILVA I DON'T THINK WE CAN
ACCEPT THAT AS AN EXCUSE. TO
NOT DO THE ENROLLMENT THAT WE
THINK THE SYSTEM SHOULD BE ABLE
TO DO- AND WE'RE GONNA WORK
WITH THEM TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DO THE HOUSING TO CLICK I THINK
I THINK THOSE TWO THINGS DO
NEED TO GO HAND IN HAND. BUT I
THINK YOUR POINTS. VERY WELL
TAKEN BUT I WOULD AGREE WITH
YOU THAT THAT'S NOT AN
ACCEPTABLE. ANSWER IN TERMS OF
A REASON TO CAP. TO CAP FOR.
CAN I JUST MISSED CHAIR YET. A
AND I DON'T KNOW WE WANT DON'T
THE LABOR THE POINT. HOW DO WE
THAT. YOU KNOW. THERE ISN'T A
UNIT. HAVE ASSED THERE IS A
CHANCELLOR. SOMEWHERE ACROSS
THE STATE. IS HEY THAT'S A
IDEAS NOW THEY'RE GONNA. CUT
DEAL. I MEAN SO. I MEAN DO YOU
HAVE DOES. THE BOARD HAVE
APOLLO. ON THE REGION'S YEAH
THE REGION'S HAVE TO PROVE
EVERY- LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT
PLAN IT COMES TWO TO THE
REGION'S AND YOU KNOW SO FAR.
ALL OF THEM THAT HAVE COME
RECENTLY HAVE. ENDORSED MORE
GROWTH. IT REALLY IS SPECIFIC
YOU KNOW SO FOR EXAMPLE- THE
MEETING NEXT WEEK WE'RE GOING
TO- APPROVE THE LONG RANGE OF
GOVERNMENT PLAN FOR UC
RIVERSIDE. AND THERE'S NO
RESTRICTION THERE I MEAN THE
COMMUNITY SUPPORTS THE GROWTH
THERE. YOU KNOW I'D SAY THE
SAME AT SEVERAL OTHER CAMPUSES
IT'S REALLY THAT THE ONES WHERE
IT'S- A REALLY HOUSING- IMPACT
LIKE UC SANTA CRUZ AND UC SANTA
BARBARA WHERE. THEY COME BACK
AND SAY- WE WANT. TO PROVIDE
HOUSING IF YOU'RE GONNA TAKE
MORE STUDENTS. I CANNOT. I
AGREE WITH IN. UNIVERSITY SIGN
OFF ON THAT POLICY BILLION I
THINK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
SENATE MAJORITY LEADER RATES
THANK YOU I WANT TO JUST GO
BACK FOR A MOMENT ON THE SANTA
BARBARA ISSUE I THINK IT'S
CLEAR THAT WE'RE LOOKING UP
THIS WE'RE LOOKING TO SEE HOW
THE UC'S RESPOND TO THIS. AND I
THINK THERE WILL BE LESSONS
LEARNED FROM THE FIRST FROM THE
FROM THE DONOR BECAUSE THAT'S
JUST ONE DONOR WILL HAVE MANY
OTHERS IN THE FUTURE AND GOING
BACK TO MR MEDINA SO TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE- HIS
QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER THE-
CONTRIBUTION- WAS CONDITIONAL-
ON ON MAKING SURE THAT THEIR
PLANS ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
IMPLEMENTED. AT IT I HEAR YOU
SAYING THAT THAT WASN'T A
CONDITION AND IF IT WAS
CERTAINLY THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT IN THE
FUTURE BECAUSE BY THE TIME YOU
FIGURE OUT. WHETHER OR NOT
YOU'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
COMPLY WITH THAT CONDITION THE
UC'S ALREADY SPENT ENORMOUS
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY TRYING
TO PUT TOGETHER PLANS. TO
FIGURE OUT IF THEY MEET THAT
CONDITION BUT I THINK. KNOWING
THAT WE ARE SETTING A PRECEDENT
IN WHATEVER IT IS THAT HAPPENS
ON THIS UC CAMPUS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. FOR THE FUTURE- SO
JUST WANTED TO. TO MAKE THAT
COMMENT THE OTHER IS REGARDING-
EACH OF THE CAMPUSES MAKING
SURE THAT ALL THE CAMPUSES HAVE
THE SAME AMOUNT OF HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES. I THINK THAT MAY
NOT WORK ON EVERY CAMPUS
BECAUSE THE NEEDS ARE NOT THE
SAME. ARE THERE SOME CAMPUSES
THAT DO REQUIRE MORE- STUDENT
HOUSING. UP CLOSE TO CAMPUS
OTHERS THE AVAILABILITY IS-
THERE'S GREATER AVAILABILITY
AVAILABILITY YEAH. I WOULD ALSO
KNOW JUST WHAT THAT YOU'RE
MCCARTY WAS SAYING EARLIER IS
THAT THERE ARE TREMENDOUS NON
FINANCIAL BENEFITS FROM OUR
STUDENTS ON CAMPUS- YOU KNOW WE
HAD A STUDY DONE IT. UC MERCED
IF A STUDENT WAS THERE LIVING
ON CAMPUS FRESHMAN YEAR THEIR
GRADUATION RATE WENT UP ABOUT
TWENTY PERCENT. AND THEY DO YOU
KNOW IT REALLY IS HI YOU YOU
CLOSE THE CAMPUS SO WE'RE
TRYING TO ALL WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT. STUDENTS NOT ONLY
COME TO THE CAMPUSES BUT ALSO
CONTINUE- AND PERSIST AND ON
CAMPUS HOUSING IS ONE OF THE
BEST. PREDICTORS OF THAT SO
IT'S ANOTHER REASON THAT WE
SUPPORT MORE HOUSING ON CAMPUS.
THAT'S WHY I LIKE THE IDEA OF
MORE COMMUNITY COLLEGES ALSO
AND I THINK HAVING THESE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OUR UC'S RCS
USE. THAT ALLOWS FOR THE FOR
THE TRANSFER EXACT COMMUTE CALL
OPTIONS TO THOSE CAMPUSES.
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU. WE
WILL NOW PROCEED WITH OUR
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE CSU
SYSTEM. WE HAVE THEM REMOTELY.
CHECK FOR STATE CHAIR MCCARTY.
YEAH I SEE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OKAY THERE YOU ARE OKAY
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
TO THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
COMMENT. MY NAME IS A VIRUS AND
ONE AND I'M ASSISTANT VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR CAPITAL PLANNING
DESIGN CONSTRUCTION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY. WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURES AND
ADMINISTRATIONS SUPPORT TO
REDUCE THE COST OF STUDENT
HOUSING BY DEVELOPING THE MULTI
YEAR GRANT PROGRAM. THE CSU
SUBMITTED NINE PROJECTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON
OCTOBER THIRTY FIRST IN
RESPONSE TO THE GRANT CRITERIA
AND GUIDELINES TO CONSTRUCT
OVER THIRTY THREE HUNDRED BEDS
AT A GRANT PROGRAM COST OF.
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX
MILLION. MOST OF THESE PROJECTS
ARE PLANNED TO START
CONSTRUCTION BY THE PREFERRED
START DATE OF DECEMBER TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO WHICH WAS
ONE OF THE KEY CRITERIA FOR CSU
PROJECT PRIORITIZATION. THE ONE
EXCEPTION IS A PROPOSED PROJECT
TO SERVE SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY'S OFF CAMPUS CENTRE
CALEXICO IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE IMPERIAL VALLEY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. ADDITIONAL PROJECTS
TOTALING OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION WERE SUBMITTED BY CSU
CAMPUSES TO THE OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR FOR THE GRANT
PROGRAM FUNDING HOWEVER THESE
WERE NOT SUBMITTED TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS THEY
WERE NOT PLANNED TO MEET. THE
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO
PREFERRED START DATE OR DID NOT
MEET THE CURRENT GRANT PROGRAM
CRITERIA. THE UNMET TO BASED ON
WEIGHT LISTEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN PRIEST PANDEMIC WAS
THIS FOR OVER EIGHT SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND BEDS FOR CSU. THE
PROJECTS SUBMITTED FOR FUNDING.
WILL BE PRESENTED TO OUR BOARD
OF TRUSTEES TOMORROW AS PART OF
OUR UPDATE ON THE CAPITAL
PROGRAM WE'VE INCLUDING
ATTACHMENT TO THEIR AGENDA ITEM
THAT INCLUDES THE LIST OF
PROJECTS SUBMITTED ALONG WITH
OTHER ELIGIBLE AND INELIGIBLE
PROJECTS WE INCLUDED THE
CRITERIA CONSIDERED
PRIORITIZATION SUCH AS THE
PERCENTAGE OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS SERVED BY THE CAMPUS.
THE CURRENT AMOUNT OF STUDENT
HOUSING CAPACITY THE ABILITY TO
ACHIEVE THE REDUCE RENTAL RATES
AND THE START DATE OF
CONSTRUCTION MOST OF THE PARTY
PROJECTS ARE ON THE CAMPUS
MASTER PLAN SO DO NOT
ANTICIPATE SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL OR COMMUNITY
CONCERNS AND ONLY ONE CAMPUS
IDENTIFIED CONCERNS WITH PEOPLE
REGULATORY ISSUES MAINLY
RELATED TO THE TIME NEEDED TO
ADDRESS DEMOLITION OF BOTH YOUR
PLUS BUILDING. AND TRIBAL
CONSULTATION. CSU CAMPUSES WERE
ALSO ABLE TO MEET THE LOW
INCOME DEFINITION AS MANY ARE
ALREADY BELOW MARKET AND STILL
HAVE THAT REVENUES FOR RESERVES
IN A NUMBER OF CAMPUSES.
PROPOSED ADDITIONAL
REINVESTMENT IN REDUCE RENTAL
RATES USING NET REVENUES BEYOND
THE BED CARE PROPOSED IN THE
PROJECT. THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
FOR THE PROGRAM IS THE
AGGRESSIVE TIMELINE. IT ASSUMES
CAMPUSES START SPENDING NOW OR
DESIGN NOT KNOWING IF THEY'LL
RECEIVE FUNDS. AND WE'VE BEEN
FORTUNATELY RECENTLY BEEN
WORKING WITH THE STATE FARM
MARSHALL TO SECURE DELEGATED
AUTHORITY TO REDUCE THE TIME
NEEDED FOR PLAN REVIEW. IF YOU
CAMPUSES ARE ALSO PROPOSING TO
RE USE DRAWINGS FROM A PRIOR
STUDENT HOUSING PROJECT IS
ANOTHER MEANS TO REDUCE TIME
DELIVER AND PROJECT COST. TO
MEMBER O'DONNELL'S QUESTIONS
FAR AS THE COST PER BED. IT
REALLY WE'RE WE'RE STILL
LOOKING AT THE DATA FROM THE
CAMPUS COST ESTIMATE FOR THE
POST. CONFIGURATION OF THE UNIT
THIS IS ONE OF THE FACTORS AS
SALIENT PENSION TO IS THAT A
CONFIGURATION OF A DORM OR IS
THAT ITS CONFIGURATION SUITES
APARTMENT LIKE WHERE THERE'S
KITCHENS OF THE UNITS. THE
NUMBER OF UNITS IS ALSO A
FACTOR WITH THE- PROPOSALS WITH
THE LOW NUMBER ARE DRIVING A
HIGHER COST PER BED STAND-
THAT- BUT STILL THIS GOT FOUR
HUNDRED. ARE SO- THE OTHER AT
ITEMS HIGH. BECAUSE SO BUT A
CERTAIN THE COST PER SQUARE
FOOT GOES UP. WHETHER INCLUDES
DINING. IN THE COST OF THE
PROJECT HEALTH CENTER FOR SAN
FRANCISCO AND PROGRAMMATIC
ELEMENTS THAT THE CAMPUS MAY
DESIRE TO INCLUDE TO SUPPORT
STUDENT MENTAL HEALTH
RESIDENTIAL LIFE THE MEDIC
PROGRAMS. A FOR EXAMPLE SAID
THE- OTHER ITEMS THAT ARE
DRIVING COST OUR SITE SO SIDE
ISSUES DOES THE CAMPUS HAVE
ENOUGH CENTRAL PLANT AND
UTILITY CAPACITY OR DO THEY
HAVE TO BUILD SOME CAPACITY IN.
AND DONALD CUT COMING CODE
CHANGES TO TRY TO DRIVE OUR
REDUCE OUR CARBON FOOTPRINT AND
INCREASED SOLAR PANELS FOR THE
PROJECTS TO GET TO NET ZERO. WE
HOPE THAT THE LEGISLATURE WILL
CONSIDER CHANGES TO THE STATUTE
TO PROVIDE THE SEGMENTS GREATER
FLEXIBILITY IN THE USE OF THE
GRANT FUNDS TO REDUCE THE
HOUSING COSTS. THIS FLEXIBILITY
WOULD INCLUDE ALLOWING
RENOVATION PROJECTS THESE
PROJECTS TEND TO BE CLOSER TO A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND PER
BED VERSUS THE TWO TO THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND THAT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER. IN THE
BENEFIT OF THE RENOVATION
PROJECTS IS THAT THE AVERAGE
COST PER BED. RIGHT THAT
INCLUDES. AS DIGIT REFERRED TO
DIFFERENT ADDRESSING RENEWABLE
DATES SO AND UPGRADING THE
FACILITY FOR ENERGY CODE FIRE
SAFETY AND ACCESSIBILITY. SO
THE CSU HAS SUCCESSFULLY
RENOVATED FACILITIES TO
INCREASE STUDENT HOUSING
CAPACITY BY INCREASING DENSITY
TO THE EXISTING UNITS SO FOR
EXAMPLE ADDING A THIRD BAD. TO
ACHIEVE THAT UNIT INCREASES THE
DENSITY SAID THE STATUTE WAS
REVISED WOULD LIKELY PRIORITIZE
SUCH RENOVATIONS TO FURTHER THE
STRATEGY AND REDUCE THE
CONSTRUCTION COSTS PER BED.
OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF YEARS
YOU HAVE HEARD THAT THE CSU HAS
ADDED ABOUT FOURTEEN THOUSAND
BEDS THROUGH A COMBINATION OF
NEW CONSTRUCTION RENOVATION AND
ACQUISITIONS TO SERVE THE
STUDENTS. BEFORE I TURN TO MY
COLLEAGUE MISTREATMENT TO TOUCH
ON HOW TO STRETCH THE STATE ONE
TIME FUNDING I DO WANT TO NOTE
THAT ARE JULY TWENTY TWENTY
REPORT TO THE BOARD ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. NOTED AN
ESTIMATED DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BACKLOG FOR STUDENT HOUSING OF
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION.
THIS EQUATES TO AN AVERAGE OF
OVER THIRTEEN THOUSAND PER BED
OF BACKLOG AND THIS AMOUNT IS
IN ADDITION TO THE BACKLOG OF
OVER FOUR BILLION FOR CSU
ACADEMIC FACILITIES. THE
CAMPUSES ARE ASKED TO BUILD
MAINTENANCE RESERVES FOR BOTH
STUDENT HOUSING AND ECONOMIC
FACILITIES AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU GRANT PROGRAMS
THAT PROVIDE SEGMENTS
FLEXIBILITY TO DO STUDENT
HOUSING COSTS AND ADDRESS
STUDENT HOUSING FACILITIES
NEEDS MORE HOLISTICALLY. IT'S
ALL HEARD IT IT'S NOT ONE SIZE
FITS ALL TO BENEFIT MORE THAN
JUST A FEW CAMPUSES GIVING THE
LIMITED FUNDING AND THE INTENT
OF THE PROGRAM. AND ALL I'M IF
YOU DON'T MIND I'LL TURN THE
PRESENTATION OVER TO ROBERT SO
HE CAN FINISH CSU PRESENTATION.
BEFORE WE GO ON IF THAT'S OKAY.
THANK YOU DEAR MCCARTY AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY I'M ROBERT EATON I'M THE
ASSISTANT VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
FINANCE AND TREASURY AND RISK
MANAGEMENT. CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT
THE HIGHER EDUCATION STUDENT
HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES IT WILL PROVIDE
FOR OUR STUDENTS. WITHIN MY
AREAS OF RESPONSIBILITY. AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY. I
HAVE OVERSIGHT OF OUR CAPITAL
FINANCING PROGRAMS INCLUDING
THE ISSUANCE OF BOND AT. YOU
FINANCED THE CONSTRUCTION OF
STUDENT HOUSING. THE CSU HAS
BEEN SUCCESSFULLY FINANCING
CONSTRUCTING STUDENT HOUSING
FOR DECADES. AND THE PRIMARY
FINANCING PROGRAM THROUGH WHICH
WE CURRENTLY ISSUE DEBT IS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITIES
SYSTEM WIDE REVENUE BOND
PROGRAM. THIS IS MY REVENUE
BOND PROGRAM HAS BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL PROVIDING RELIABLE
LOW INTEREST COSTS CAPITAL
FINANCING FOR THE CONSTRUCTION
OF CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
PROJECTS INCLUDING STUDENT
HOUSING. IN FACT OUT OF THE
APPROXIMATELY EIGHT POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS OF CURRENLY
OUTSTANDING SINCE MY REVIEW
BONTA ABOUT A THIRD TWO POINT
EIGHT BILLION. HAS BEEN
DEDICATED TO FINANCING HOUSING
FOR CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
STUDENTS. THE SIZE AND STRENGTH
OF THE SYSTEM I REVENUE BOND
PROGRAM MEANS THAT WE DO NOT
LACK AN ABILITY TO ISSUE DEBT.
OR TO PUT IN OTHER TERMS WE DO
NOT LACK DEBT CAPACITY ISSUED
THAT INSTRUCTS STUDENT HOUSING.
TO BE SURE WE HAVE UNDERWRITING
STANDARDS WHEN IT COMES TO
FINANCING CAMPUS HOUSING
PROJECTS BUT THE SIZE AND
STRENGTH THIS IS MY REVENUE
BOND PROGRAM IS WE HAVE A LOT
OF FLEXIBILITY IN WORKING WITH
CAMPUSES TO MEET THEIR
FINANCIAL. NEEDS FOR HOUSING
PROJECTS. FOR EXAMPLE IF A
PARTICULAR PROJECT WILL NOT
MEET OUR DEBT SERVICE COVERAGE
TESTS IN THE FIRST COUPLE OF
YEARS OPERATIONS. BUT WILL DO
SO THEREAFTER. WE WILL STILL
RECOMMEND THE PROJECT OR BOARD
OF TRUSTEES FOR FINANCING
APPROVAL BECAUSE OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE PROJECT FOR
THE CAMPUS. AND BECAUSE OF THE
FINANCIAL BY. OF THE PROJECT IN
THE LONG RUN. WORKING WITH
CAMPUSES OVER THE YEARS TO
STRUCTURE THE FINANCING OF
STUDENT HOUSING ROJECTS. ONE
OF THE KEY AREAS WE ALWAYS LOOK
AT CLOSELY. AND THINK THROUGH
THOROUGHLY IS BALANCING THE
FINANCIAL VIABILITY OF A
HOUSING PROJECT. THE
SUPPORTABILITY FOR STUDENTS.
WELL AS GSU HAS BEEN
INTENTIONAL ABOUT COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY FOR OUR STUDENTS.
THERE'S STILL OPPORTUNITY TO
FURTHER ADDRESS THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING NEEDS OF STUDENTS WHICH
MAKES THE HIGHER EDUCATION
STUDENT HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM.
SUCH AN EXCITING OPPORTUNITY.
AND YOU CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR
WAYS TO POTENTIALLY ENHANCE THE
GRANT PROGRAM. I WANT TO TAKE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO OFFER ONE
IDEA FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
ENSURE MCCARTY I THINK THIS
GUEST YOUR EARLIER QUESTION OF
THE ALEJO. GAP FINANCING. S.
PRESENTLY ENVISIONED THE HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM SEEKS TO PROVIDE 1100%
OF THE FUNDING FOR A HOUSING
PROJECT. AND CERTAINLY THIS
APPROACH WILL PROVIDE
CONSIDERABLE AFFORDABILITY FOR
MANY STUDENTS. HOWEVER IF THERE
IS AN ABILITY TO STRUCTURE THE
GRANT PROGRAM TO WORK IN
COMBINATION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITIES RECESSED MY
REVENUE BOND PROGRAM. WE THINK
THE POTENTIAL EXISTS TO A
GREATER IMPACT BY COMBINING THE
MERITS OF THE GRANT PROGRAM
WITH THE STRENGTHS OF OUR
SYSTEM MY REVENUE BND PROGRAM.
THE IDEA WOULD BE TO UTILIZE
CRAP DOLLARS AS A DOWN PAYMENT
FOR A PROJECT AND THEN FINANCE
THE BALANCE THE PROJECT WHICH
SYSTEM I REVENUE BOND DEBT. BY
LOWERING THE LEVEL OF THE
PROJECT DEBT SERVICE WHICH IS A
FIXED EXPENDITURE A
CORRESPONDING REDUCTION IN
RENTS CAN BE ACHIEVED. THUS
PROVIDING AFFORDABILITY FOR
STUDENTS. THE AMOUNT OF THE
DOWN PAYMENT WOULD BE BURIED
DEPENDING UPON THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE INDIVIDUAL
PROJECT. BUT THE CONCEPT WOULD
SPREAD THE GRANT DOLLARS OVER A
LARGER NUMBER OF PROJECTS.
THEREBY POTENTIALLY PROVIDING
AFFORDABILITY BENEFITS TO AN
EVEN GREATER NUMBER OF
STUDENTS. AGAINI THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE CREATED
AND I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT. OKAY THANK
YOU- MY FORK FIRST QUESTION
FOR- FORCE FOR CSU IS- IF YOU
LOOK AT THE TABLE HERE WHERE'S
THE TABLE MAYBE BELIAU WORK.
SMARR'S NEWS DOING HOUSING SO
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU HAD MADE
JUSTIN HOUSING INC INC- BEDS.
SAN DIEGO- SAN DIEGO SAN
FRANCISCO AND SAN LUIS OBISPO-
NOT SO MUCH FOR- THE OTHER
CAMPUSES LIKE WE THOUGHT THAT
THAT YOU SEE IT ARE THESE
IMPACTED CAMPUSES WHERE YOU
HAVE YOU YOU HAVE BASICALLY
THAT THAT THAT NEEDS FOR TO
SUPPLY DEMAND AND PUSHES FROM
YOUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO BUILD
MORE STERN HOUSING. I WOULD SAY
THEY STUDENT THE DEMAND IS THE
DRIVER FOR THE STUDENT HOUSING
SO IN IN ADDITION TO THE
CAMPUSES YOU'VE MENTIONED SHARE
WE HAVE RECENTLY COMPLETED A
SIGNIFICANT PROJECT AT CAL
STATE LA. FULLER TEN IS UNDER
WAY. AND SECOND ALSO COMPLETED
A PROJECT RECENTLY. OKAY YEAH I
SAW THAT. AND THEN MY QUESTION
IS SIMILAR TO WHAT WE HEARD
FROM. THE L. A. L. O. AND MR
BRO STROM AS FAR AS YOUR OVER
ARCHING NEEDS- AND WE'RE GONNA
HEAR THIS FROM FROM THERE YOUR
FULLER TEN CHANCELLOR IN A BIT.
THE FAULTS AND PRESIDENT IS IT-
RESOURCES TO HELP- MEKTIC MAKE
THESE PROJECTS PENCIL OUT OR
THIS KIND OF NOTION OF A OF A
REVOLVING FUND. OR BOTH IT WAS
WHO WHICH SHOULD BE. WHAT ARE
THE TOP THINGS THAT WE COULD DO
FROM THE STATE PERSPECTIVES.
THE FOCUS ON AND YOUR STUDENT
HOUSING PRIORITIES AT THE CSU
SYSTEM. WELL I WOULD SAY AS I
MENTIONED WE DON'T LACK FOR
COUNTY DO. ISSUE DEBT TO
FINANCE. OUR STUDENT HOUSING
PROJECTS- THE BALANCING ACT IF
YOU WILL IS THE FINANCIAL
VIABILITY OF A PROJECT BASED ON
THE REVENUES YOU CAN OCCUR IN
THE EXPENSE DOESN'T DEBT
SERVICE AND AFFORDABILITY SO I
THINK THE VALUE OF THESE
PROGRAMS THE GRANT PROGRAM AS
WELL AS A RESULT IN. STUDENTS
FUND A PROGRAM. IS THAT IT
COULD IMPACT THE AFFORDABILITY.
IT COULD PROVIDE IF YOU WILL
EIGHT A SUBSIDY OR A DOWN
PAYMENT OF SOME SORTS THAT CAN
LOWER KIND OF FIXED COSTS THE
CASE NUMBER OF ALL THE FUN- YOU
KNOW THIS- THE UC'S MISTER
BREWSTER NOTED YOU KNOW
SOMETHING THAT 0% OBVIOUSLY
WOULD BE WELCOME WE ARE A BET
AND THAT FROM LOW COST CAPITAL.
SO THE INTEREST RATE I WOULD
NEED TO BE LOWER TO TRACK OF
SPORTS BUT WE WOULD CERTAINLY
WELCOME THAT AND SIMILARLY ON
THE GRANT PROGRAM YEAH IDEAS BE
BY DOWN THE AMOUNT OF THE DEBT
AS THE L. A. O. SAID IT'S
FAVORABLE TERMS IN THE SENSE
IT'S REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF THE
DEBT SERVICE IT NEEDS TO BE
CARRIED CITING BOTH. BOTH
PROGRAMS HAVE MERIT. OKAY THANK
YOU TO TAKE. AT SORRY JUST ADD
ON THAT ALSO. FOR WHERE THE
LOCAL MARKET IS ABLE TO HAVE
SUCH LOW RENTS COMPARED TO WHAT
THE UNIVERSITY HAS. THAT WOULD
BE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR US.
ESPECIALLY IF WE HAD EXISTING
CAPACITY- WHETHER IT'S- NOT
REAL CAPACITY BECAUSE FOR
SOCIAL DISTANCING. IF IT IF THE
USE OF STUDENT HOUSING IS DOWN
BECAUSE OF PRICING BECAUSE THEY
CAN FIND THINGS IN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY. THAN SOME OTHER
STRUCTURE COULD BE HELPFUL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANK.
JUST GOING BACK TO THE
ASSISTANT VICE CHANCELLOR
EATON'S COMMENTS SO ARE YOU
SAYING THAT- IF WE WERE ABLE TO
COMBINE THE GRANT PROGRAM WITH
THE- BOND PROGRAM THAT WE THE
PEOPLE TO GET MORE HOUSING
BUILT. I THINK THE POTENTIALLY
I THINK IT'D BE MORE FOCUSED ON
AFFORDABILITY AND THEN OF
COURSE AND THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY TRANSLATE INTO MORE
HOUSING- IF YOU IF YOU THINK
OF. JUST SAY OUT OF THE- LISESI
FIFTY MILLION SUPPLIED A GRANT
PROGRAM TO A PROJECT TO
CONSTRUCT THE FULL PROJECT. DO
YOU NEED THAT FULL FIFTY
MILLION IN OTHER WORDS A 100%
FINANCING IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE
AFFORDABILITY TARGET THAT MEET
YOUR GOALS. PERHAPS TEN OR
TWENTY MILLION. MIGHT MEET THAT
AFFORDABILITY TARGET WHICH CASE
YOU CAN FREE UP THE OTHER
THIRTY TO FORTY MILLION FOR
ANOTHER PROJECT RIGHT. SO AND
TO THE EXTENT THAT
AFFORDABILITY IS ONE OF THESE
CONSIDERATIONS WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT A PROJECT DOESN'T
PENCIL OUT AND WE'RE BALANCING
AT FINANCIAL VIABILITY OF THE
PROJECT WITH A FOUR BUILDING
FOR STUDENTS. ANY DOLLAR THEY
CAN GO TO HELP AFFORDABILITY
HELPS THE FINANCIAL VIABILITY
OF AFFORDABLE PROJECT AND
THEREFORE- POTENTIALLY COULD
RESULT IN MORE PROJECTS. SO
WHAT YOU'RE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
IS RATHER THAN HAVE- ALL THE
MONEY IS STILL FIFTY MILLION
BEFORE COSTS ON ONE PROJECT CA
CAL STATE LONG BEACH. SPREAD
THAT THROUGHOUT A NUMBER OF
PROJECTS WHICH WOULD PRODUCE.
THE COST AT ALL THOSE PROJECTS
NOT AS MUCH AS THE FIFTY
MILLION ONE PROJECT BUT
OBVIOUSLY YOU WOULD SPREAD THAT
AFFORDABILITY. A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT PROJECTS IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE SUGGESTING. YEAH EXACTLY
AND THE AMOUNT OF THAT WHICH
VARY BY PROJECT AND
CIRCUMSTANCE. WE LOOK AT
POTENTIAL IS THERE YES GOTTEN.
JUST QUESTION FOR SYSTEM CHANCE
ONCE YOU ADVANCE ON. THE
FLEXIBILITY TO INCLUDE-
RENOVATION PROJECTS I DID HAVE
A QUESTION WHICH IS. HOW
TRADITIONALLY RENOVATION
PROJECTS ARE PAID OUT OF. YOUR
MAIN INTEREST EARNERS WHICH YOU
JUST MENTIONED DESERVE REASON
WHY THERE AREN'T. ADEQUATE
RESERVES TO DO THE RENOVATION
THAT YOU'RE NEEDING AT THIS
HOUSING PROJECTS. FOR SOMEOF
THE PROJECTS THEY'RE QUITE
EXPENSIVE YES STILL EIGHTY TO A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS SO THE
RESERVES WERE HIT PRETTY HARD
WITH CODED EVEN WITH THE
FEDERAL FUNDING- THEY'VE BEEN
IT'S BEEN PROVED BUT- FOR ONE
PROJECT TO TAKE ON A EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PROJECTS
RECLINERS SERVICES DIFFICULT.
GONE AND THEN WE DO YEAH. WE DO
ENCOURAGE THEM TO USE RESERVES
TO HELP BUY DOWN THE DEBT IF
THERE IS A ISSUE WITH THAT WHAT
THEY CAN AFFORD. IN TERMS OF A
THE ADDITIONAL BED PER. PER
DOLLAR INVESTED- WOULD BE
CHEAPER TO DO RENOVATION
PROJECTS RATHER THAN TO DO NEW
CONSTRUCTION IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. BASED ON THE
PROJECT'S CAMPS IS SUBMITTED
THE RENOVATION PROJECTS PER
BETTER CHEAPER. CAN YOU GIVE US
A SENSE OF HOW MUCH CHEAPER
WITH WITH THE WITH THE ROUGH.
AT. THIRTY THIRTY TWO
RENOVATIONS THROUGH INNOVATIONS
THAT HAVE COME IN FROM A
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN THE
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO MILLION
COMPARED TO THE RANGE OF THE
TWO HUNDRED FIVE MILLION TO
THREE HUNDRED PLUS MILLION. FOR
NEW CONSTRUCTION. BUT WHAT'S
THE PROVIDE COST I GUESS. THAT
IS THE PERFECT COSTS SO BUT A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
VERSUS TWO ONE FIFTY NINE SO
I'M NOT A HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS PER BAD-
RENOVATION THAT'S THE- PROPOSED
COSTS FOR. THREE THE CAMP SINCE
THE RANGE ONE FOURTEEN TO ONE
HUNDRED TO PICK YOUR TOP OF THE
OVERALL COSTS I'M ASKING WHAT
WHAT THE PROJECT COST IS. THAT
STONE UP. HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND PER BED OKAY YOU
SUMMER RENOVATIONS AT A HUNDRED
TWENTY MILLION. SKEWS ME SEASON
WITH A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND PER BED VERSUS TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND PER ABOUT. TWO
FIFTY TO THREE HUNDRED PLUS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. PETERIK
INCREASE CAPACITY OKAY
QUESTIONS MR NEAR OKAY THANK
YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OFTEN BITING ME HERE TODAY MY
NAME IS AMY COSTA AND I
CURRENTLY SERVE AS THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS. WHAT I THINK THE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR PROVIDING
THIS FUNDING THIS YEAR- FOR
AFFORDABLE STUDENT HOUSING THIS
IS A HISTORIC INVESTMENT BY THE
STATE SPECIFICALLY FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHO
TRADITIONALLY I WITH A FEW
EXCEPTIONS DO NOT PROVIDE
STUDENT HOUSING- IN AS WAS
NOTED BY THE CHAIR IN HIS
OPENING REMARKS THE STATE IS IN
A HOUSING CRISIS THE DISTANCE A
PLEA IMPACTS OUR STUDENTS.
DISPROPORTIONATELY OUR COLLEGES
OUR MICROCOSM TO THE STATE AND
THEREFORE NOT IMMUNE TO THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS. OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS NOTED
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS
IN THE STATE. AS A POTENTIAL
RISKS TO THE OVERALL HEALTH OF
THE STATE'S ECONOMY.
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOTED.
FINALLY OTHER LONGER TERM
STRUCTURAL RESPECT PREDATED THE
PANDEMIC REMAINS AND SOME OF
THOSE RISKS HAVE BEEN
EXACERBATED BY THE PANDEMIC.
THESE RISKS INCLUDE
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING SHORTAGE.
WHICH CONTINUES TO PUT PRESSURE
ON INFLATION AND PRICES
LIMITING CALIFORNIANS ABILITY
TO AFFORD A HOME. INTERESTINGLY
THE JANUARY BUDGET NOTED EVEN
DURING RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT.
ONE IN FIVE HOUSEHOLDS SPENT AT
LEAST 50% OR MORE OF THEIR
INCOME ON HOUSINGCOSTS ONE
EIGHT HOMEOWNERS SPEND 50% OR
MORE OF THEIR INCOME ON HOUSING
COSTS. BUT MORE THAN ONE IN
FOUR VENTURE SPENT THAT MUCH.
AT TWENTY NINETEEN HOPES IN A
REPORT INDICATED THAT IN A
SURVEY OF OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS 60% OF RESPONDENTS
WERE HOUSING INSECURE IN THE
PREVIOUS YEAR. 19% OF
RESPONDENTS WERE HOMELESS IN
THE PREVIOUS YEAR. THESE
STATISTICS WERE PRE PANDEMIC SO
WE CAN ALL STAND THE HOUSING
AND SECURITY INCREASE FOR MANY
OF OUR STUDENTS AND THE LAST
TWO YEARS. GIVEN THAT HOUSING
CRISIS HOUSING HOUSING COSTS
CONTINUE TO INCREASE DURING THE
PANDEMIC. NONE OF US CAN EXPECT
THAT OUR STUDENTS CAN SUCCEED.
WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE A SAFE
PLACE TO SLEEP OR DON'T KNOW
WHERE THEY WILL BE LOOKING.
YEARS AGO I VISITED SIERRA
COLLEGE NOT FAR FROM YOU AND I
BECAME INTERESTED IN THE ISSUE
OF STUDENT HOUSING- BECAUSE THE
DATA WAS CLEAR AS MR BROWNSTONE
RECENTLY STATED THAT OUR
STUDENTS OUTCOMES OR BETTER
WHEN THEY ARE SECURELY HOUSE.
AS PART OF OUR VISION FOR
SUCCESS HOUSING CAN HELP US
ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS ARE
ABLE TO MEET THEIR EDUCATIONAL
GOALS. CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE CLOSE TO TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND ACRES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA PLANT. WE
HAVE THE LAND AND WE'D LIKE TO
HELP ASSIST THE STATE AND
ADDRESSING THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS. FURTHER OUR
INVESTMENT WILL IMPROVE OUR
STUDENTS OUTCOMES. THIS IS NOT
A FUNCTION THAT WE HAVE
TRADITIONALLY HAD A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION AND OUR
SISTER PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
SEGMENTS TO BUILD OUR INTERNAL
CAPACITY AND LOOK FOR AREAS TO
PARTNER ON SOME PROJECTS. AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR SUPPORTING OUR
STUDENTS WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
TURN IT OVER TO MISS NOT RAT
FROM THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE TO
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
STUDENT HOUSING. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHEN MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE. COMPANIES
WE COLLEGES STUDENT HOUSING
REPRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ADVANCE OUR AFFORDABILITY
AGENDA AS YOU EARLIER. BUT ALSO
TO MEET OUR STUDENTS NEEDS.
FURTHER YEAH IT'S ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO DANCE STUDENT
SUCCESS ON AVERAGE WE COLLEGE
STUDENTS SPEND. FOURTEEN
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED NINETY
TWO PER YEAR ON HOUSING. TEN
TIMES MORE THAN THEY PAY IN
TUITION AND FEES. CURRENTLY
ONLY TWELVE CALIFORNIA'S ME
COLLEGES OFFER STATE STUDENT
HOUSING. EIGHT OF THOSE HOUSING
COMPLEXES WERE CONSTRUCTED OVER
FORTY YEARS AGO. THE MOST
RECENT PROJECTS HAVE UTILIZED
SOME FORM OF PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS AS A MEANS TO
MAINTAIN AFFORDABILITY
PARTICULARLY IN HIGH COST
REGIONS. AS A SYSTEM OUR
COLLEGES CURRENTLY HAVE THE
CAPACITY. TO HOUSE ONLY TWO
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
STUDENTS THAT IS NO WHERE NEAR-
WHAT WE NEED CROSS ARE HUNDRED
SIXTEEN COLLEGES. ASSETS FOR
DECADES NOW SOME HOUSING HAS
BEEN A BASIC NEED THAT WE JUST
SIMPLY CAN'T FULFILL UNTIL NOW.
THIS INVESTMENT CALIFORNIA'S
MAHAJAN HOUSING CAN ENABLE
FOCUS ON AFFORDABILITY BUT ALSO
STUDENT SUCCESS. WE CAN SURE
THIS FINANCIAL- ENSURING THAT%
THIS IS NOT AN ISOLATED
IMPLEMENTATION BUT RATHER A
HOLISTIC VIEW. THAT OUR FOCUS
IS ON A FRAMEWORK. THAT
SUPPORTS FINANCIAL AID STUDENT
SERVICES MENTAL HEALTH ACADEMIC
SUPPORTS SO THE STUDENTS CAN
ACHIEVE THEIR- GOALS. WE HAVE
IMPORTANT WORK AT HAND THAT
WHERE THE LEGISLATURE WILL BE A
KEY PARTNER. AS A SYSTEM OFFICE
WITH SEVENTY THREE
INDEPENDENTLY GOVERNED
DISTRICTS OUR CAPACITY TO
SUPPORT THE COMPREHENSIVE
IMPLEMENTATION OF STERN HOUSING
IS STILL LIMITED. OVER THE NEXT
YEAR WITH YOUR HELP WE CAN
BUILD A COMPREHENSIVE STUDENT
HOUSING STRATEGY THAT INSURERS
WERE NOT ONLY IMPRINT
IMPLEMENTING THE BRICK AND
MORTAR COMPONENT. BUT ALSO
CONNECTING THEM TO REAL
SERVICES THAT. STUDENTS NEED.
THE SAFETY DAN THAT ARE CAN
SIX. AND THE ACCOUNT. THAT YOU
DESERVE. THE CHANTERS OFFICE
pKICKING OFF A STATE TASK FORCE
FOCUSED ON HOUSING THE
STANDARDS THE REGULATION THE
DATA THAT IS NEEDED AND THE
WRAPAROUND SUPPORTS THAT CAN
ACCOMPANY HOUSING. ALL TO
SUPPORT AND EFFECTIVE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
DOLLARS. OUR GOAL IS TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE TO ANY COLLEGE THAT IS
LOOKING TO INVEST AND EXPAND IN
THIS IMPORTANT AREA WE WANT TO
GET FROM STUDENTS TO FULLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY NEED. AND
LEARN MORE ABOUT HEIGHT AND
HIGHLIGHT EXACTLY PRACTICES
THAT EFFECTIVELY DELIVER
AFFORDABLE HOUSING A CROSS EYED
OUR DIVERSE AT REGIONS. FURTHER
ARE TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
SYSTEM BUDGET FOR REST INCLUDES
A PROPOSAL FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
OF STUDENT HOUSING- SO THAT WE
CAN DEVELOP A UNIT THAT LOOKS
AT THE LONG TERM IMPLEMENTATION
OF STUDENT HOUSING WE LOOK
FORWARD TO ENGAGING WITH YOU IN
THE COMING MONTHS TO HIGHLIGHT
WHY THIS IS A KEY COMPONENT. OF
AN EFFECTIVE STUDENT HOUSING
STRATEGY THANK YOU AND WE'RE
HAPPY. TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OKAY. THANK YOU AT MISTER CAN
YOU CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT THE
ISSUE THAT I ASKED THAT THE CSU
SO. AND I CAN I KNOW IT'S VERY
DIVERSE THERE'S A HUNDRED PLUS
COLLEGES AND- I FORGET HOW MANY
DISTRICTS- DOZENS. WHAT IS THE
REQUEST FOR. FOR MORE FOR ONE
TIME MONEY TO PROVIDE GAP
FINANCING. TO HELP THESE
PROJECTS BECOME VIABLE OR IS
IT. MONIES TO THE FUND MALL OR
THIS REVOLVING FUND NOTION WERE
AT THE POOL OF MONEY THAT YOU
CAN DRAW DOWN FROM. AND BORROW
MONEY FOR THE PROJECTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE QUESTION
THREE COLLEGES IN VERY EARLY
STAGES OF ENGAGING IN STUDENT
HOUSING. SO INVESTING IN
INITIAL CONSTRUCTION CAN ENSURE
THAT WE CAN MAINTAIN PROJECTS
THAT ARE AFFORDABLE THAT
ALTERNATELYHAVE AFFORDABLE
TRANSFER STUDENTS THIS
ADDRESSES SOME OF THE NEEDS
THAT STUDENTS HAVE. IN TERMS OF
WHAT YOU'LL RECEIVE IN-
FINANCING OR FINANCIAL AID.
LONG TERM A LOOKING AT PROJECTS
THAT DO NOT GET FUNDED THROUGH
THESE FIRST THREE ROUNDS OF
STATE INVESTMENTS CAN BE A WAY
TO LOOK AT HOW THE STATE CAN
SUPPORT FINANCING OF THOSE
THROUGH A MECHANISM. WE ALSO
HAVE A DECENTRALIZED SYSTEM AND
SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER
THAT- WHEN WE ARE LOOKING AT
FINANCING A STATE STRUCTURE IS
GOING TO BE NECESSARY BECAUSE
YOU'RE REALLY RELYING ON
INDEPENDENT DISTRICTS. AND
THEIR INDEPENDENT RATINGS AND
SO WE HAVE SOME STRUCTURE
BUILDING- AND STANDARDS THAT
NEED TO BE DEVELOPED FIRST FOR
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. YEAH MAYBE WE CAN
TALK MORE ABOUT THIS BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK THAT'S REALLY WHAT
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR WHAT I
WAS LOOKING FOR AND I KNOW IT'S
HARD BECAUSE LIKE YOU SEE HAS
NINE. UNDERGRAD CAMPUSES IT'S
EASY TO FORGET THAT COULD
RATTLE OFF NINE IN FIVE SECONDS
AND- YOU HAVE A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN. WITH DECENTRALIZED.
CAMPUSES AND SO. WE CAN'T PROP
FIND ALL OF THE PROJECTS
REQUESTED I MEAN THE POT FOR
THIS YEAR IS. THREE HOW MUCH
PARKING BECAUSE OF THREE THREE
THREE HUNDRED MILLION IN
SOMEBODY'S PROJECTS MAYBE A
HUNDRED MILLION A PIECE TO
FULLY FUND IT SO. IF YOU WANT
TO STRETCH IT OUT WITH MAYBE WE
DON'T WANT TO FIND 100% A
PROJECT MAYBE WENT TO DO. NOT
GAP FINANCING AND ALLOW THEM TO
BE MORE VIABLE WITH YOUR
EXISTING OPPORTUNITY TO BORROW
MONEY FOR IT I KNOW SOME CAMPUS
HAVE BONDING CAPACITY SO WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IS
IF WE WANT TO HELP YOU ACHIEVE
YOUR GOAL AND I WOULD TOTALLY
IN CONCURRENCE WITH WHAT YOU
AND- BOARD OF GOVERNORS. KOSTET
MENTION THIS TO YOU KNOW HELP
STUDENTS SIXTY EIGHT AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL WE HAVE
TWO MILLION STUDENTS AND-
AFFORDABILITY IS KEY AND YOU
SAID IT PERFECTLY THAT YOU KNOW
IT'S TEN TIMES MORE FOR HOUSING
THAT FOR TUITION AND- YOU KNOW
HAS WE'VE- BEEN CALIFORNIA MOST
TUITION IS FREE. FOR FEES IT IN
IN COMMUNITY COLLEGES UP SO
WHAT DO WE WHAT HELP US HELP
YOU DO WHAT DO WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON. THIS REVOLVING FUND OCEAN
OR- ONE TIME MONIES TO HELP
PROVIDE GAP FINANCING IF YOU
WANT THE STATE TO PAY. FOR IT.
HIJACKS I DON'T WE'RE GOING TO
BE VERY SUCCESSFUL MAYBE YOU'LL
GET ONE OR TWO PROJECTS ACROSS
THE ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE THEY'RE THEY'RE VERY
THEY'RE LIKE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PROJECTS PLUS OR MINUS
THE PROJECT AT. UC SANTA
BARBARA. GRANTED IT'S- IT'S
FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS IS ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS SO.
EIGHT I'M NOT SURE IF YOU HAVE
THE ANSWER TODAY. BUT THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR. ONE
THING I MIGHT OFFER TO THAT
CAME UP IN THE ANALYST- AND
THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS
DISCUSSED IS THE ABILITY FOR US
TO PARTNER WITH THEIR SISTER
SEGMENTS ON WE DO HAVE A NUMBER
OF. BUDGET ACTION WHICH WILL
BE- BRING THOSE FORWARD FOR
CONSIDERATION.
I WILL CERTAINLY
LOOK TO THOSE IN THE FUTURE.
ABOUT THE HIGH NUMBER OF
APPLICANTS WHO ASKED FOR A
PLANET GRAHAM'S- AVERAGING
ABOUT FORMED A LITTLE BIT OVER
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS OF GRANT
SO- WITH THAT REQUEST DO YOU
KNOW OUR FIRST YEAR ALLOTMENT
FOR THE COMMUNICABLE JUST COULD
BE TAKEN UP FOR JUST PLANNING
AND ACTUALLY NO CONSTRUCTION IF
WE HAVE STRUCTURED IT THAT WAY.
CAN YOU GIVE US A SENSE- WHY
THIS CAPACITY CAN'T BE ABSORBED
BY THE CAMPUSES OR IS THERE
SOME WAY TO ASSIST THE CAMPUSES-
IN A MORE EFFICIENT WAY IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF MONEY GOING
TOWARD PLANNING WITH NO.
CONSTRUCTION. YEAH I HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED THAT. AS I MENTIONED
OUR COLLEGES ARE CURRENTLY IN
EARLY STAGES OF ENGAGING IN
HOUSING IS A NEW VENTURE SO
MANY OF THEM HAVE TAKEN AN
pNEEDS HOW THEY CAN UTILIZE THE
LAND- AND HOW TO CONSTRUCT IN A
MANNER. THAT MAINTAINS
AFFORDABILITY SO THAT THEY CAN
CANCEL OUT THESE COSTS- THIS
WILL GIVE US. AND THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. GOOD LANDSCAPE OF WHAT
IS OUT THERE WHAT IT WILL TAKE
FOR A LONG TERM INVESTMENT THIS
SOAK YOU CAN STRUCTURE
STRUCTURE THIS IS FOCUS ON
FIRST FUNDING THOSE THAT ARE
SHOVEL READY. BUT THE
INFORMATION THAT COMES IN FROM
THOSE PLANNING RANTS REALLY CAN
HELP BUILD OUT THAT LONG TERM
PROGRAMS THAT THEN- A GIVES US
LEEWAY TO SEE HOW MUCH MORE THE
STATE COULD NOT EAT. IN SETTING
GOALS FOR AFFORDABILITY AND
LONG TERM CONSTRUCTION
INCLUDING BOTH MAINTAINING THE
COMMITMENT TO THE ONE BILLION-
INCLUDED IN SB ONE SIX NINE OR
ALSO- IN TANDEM BUILDING
POTENTIALLY. A REVOLVING LOAN
IN THE FUTURE. OKAY I DON'T
THINK I GOT AN ANSWER TO MY
QUESTION LET ME JUST RESTATE IT
SO ON. YOU HAVE SEVENTY ONE
APPLICANTS ASKING. FOR THREE
HUNDRED THIRTEEN. MILLION
DOLLARS IS THERE A CHEAPER MORE
EFFICIENT WAY TO HELP THE
SEVENTY ONE INSTITUTIONS. WITH
THEIR PLANNING WHAT DO YOU
REALLY EXPECT THE STATE TO KICK
IN THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO. HELP THESE CAMPUSES
PLAN WITH NOT A SINGLE UNIT
BEING BUILT. ONE APPROACH THAT
AT GREATER SYSTEM WIDE
STRUCTURE THAT CAN HELP
COLLEGES BUILD UP PLANS FOR
HOUSING AND THEY CAN PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THAT CAN-
BUILD THESE LONG TERM PLANS
INTEGRATED INTO THE FACILITIES
MASTER PLAN PART OF A SYSTEM.
AND SO THAT WORK AND THEN-
SUPPORT AND REDUCE THE COSTS
NEEDED FOR PLANNING GRANTS- AND
THEN FOCUS ON CONSTRUCTION FOR
THESE SYSTEMS. I THINK THAT'S A
GREAT IDEA I MEAN IT'S MY HOPE
IS THAT YOUR OFFICE COULD WORK
WITH THE SEVENTY ONE CAMPUSES
TO REALLY. FIND A WAY TO BE
MUCH MORE EFFICIENT REGARDING
THE- PLANNING BECAUSE WE WOULD
RATHER HAVE THIS MONEY GO TO
CONSTRUCTION RATHER THAN. THE
IDEA OF CONSTRUCTION WITH THE
PLANNING OF CONSTRUCTION WITH
NOT A SINGLE UNIT BEING BUILT.
ON WE DID SEE TWENTY ONE
CAMPUSES APPLY FOR THE FUNDS
WHICH IS VERY EXCITING COULD
YOU CAN YOU GIVE US A SENSE OF.
WITH THIS TWENTY ONE CAMPUSES
ARE LOCATED WAS IT FAIRLY WELL
DISTRIBUTED WAS IT. MORE URBAN
VERSUS RULE OR CAN YOU JUST
GIVE US AN IDEA OF WHAT THE-
WHO THIS TWENTY CAMPUSES ARE.
YEAH WE CURRENTLY HAVE A WIDE
DISPERSION COLLEGES THAT WERE
READY TO SUBMIT PLANS FOR
CONSTRUCTION. SOME OF THESE ARE
AND- REGIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY FIRES AND THEY HAVE
SEEN THEIR HOUSING STOCK
SEVERELY REDUCED LOSSES SEEN
OTHER PROJECTS IN URBAN AREAS
THAT ARE DEALING WITH DENSITY
ISSUES OR AFFORDABILITY ISSUES
AND- THAT LEVERAGING STATE
DOLLARS CAN KEEP THE COSTS
DOWN. BUT WE ALSO HAVE SOME
THAT ARE IN SUBURBAN AREAS-
THAT ARE UTILIZING SPACE AND
MORE INNOVATIVE APPROACHES AS
WELL AS A COMBINATION OF SOME
THAT. ARE LOOKING AT
PARTNERSHIPS SO AS YOU CAN SEE
THE DIVERSITY OF THE- PROJECT
BECAUSE MY COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE WIDE- AND- REALLY IS
REFLECTIVE OF THIS NEW VENTURE
AND PRIORITY FORESTS I'M- THANK
YOU COULD YOU COULD YOU. SAY
THE NAMES OF THE CAMPUSES AND
WHERE THEY'RE LOCATED. WE DON'T
HAVE A FULL LIST OF ALL OF
THEM- IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO BUILD AS THE
SYSTEM OFFICE HAS A GREATER
CAPACITY FOR DATA- IN THIS AREA
RIGHT NOW WHAT WE KNOW OR THOSE
THAT HAVE SENT US COPIES OF
THEIR PROPOSALS AS WELL. SOME
AS I MENTIONED- INCLUDE THOSE
THAT HAVE AN EFFECT FIRES COULD
COULD YOU SHARE THE NAMES OF
WHAT THE PERMISSION YOU DO HAVE.
SURE WE HAVE SOME IN THE LA
AREA- WE HAVE- CAMPUSES HAVE
NAMES AND LOCATIONS. YES SO
WHAT WE HAPPEN IS THAT A GROUP
WERE WOULD YOU MIND SHARING
THAT WITH THE COMMITTEE. DON'T
WE THESE PROPOSALS WERE SENT
DIRECTLY TO THE COMING OF
FINANCE SO I'LL TELL YOU THE
ONES THAT I DO NOW. SO WE HAVE
A PROJECT BY SANTA ROSA JUNIOR
COLLEGE. JUNIOR COLLEGE AGAIN
ONE OF THOSE THAT HAS BEEN
AFFECTED BY FIRES WE'VE A
PROPOSAL BY L. LADY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. ANOTHER BY-
PASADENA. THE WHOLE LIST OF ALL
THE TWENTY ONE THEY'VE BEEN
SUBMITTED STONES SINCE THOSE
WERE SENT DIRECTLY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND NOT
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE NO NO
UNDERSTOOD BUT THAT JUST GIVES
US. A SENSE OF WHAT. IS WHO'S
APPLYING AND FOR WHAT REASON SO
WE APPRECIATE THAT AND AGAIN-
WOULD REALLY URGE THE SYSTEM.
TO TRY TO COME UP WITH THE WAY
THAT THEY COULD PERHAPS ASSIST.
THE CAMPUSES AT LARGE I
UNDERSTAND THAT MANY OF MOST
CAMPUSES HAVE NEVER REALLY
CONSIDERED- HOUSING AND HAVE
ENOUGH TO REALLY THOUGHT ABOUT
IT BUT- IF THERE'S A WAY THAT
THE- THE SYSTEM COULD REALLY
HELP. A SISTER OUT TO BRING
THAT DOLLAR FIGURE DOWN I THINK
IT BE VERY VERY HELPFUL THANK
YOU. OKAY YEAH I KNOW WE'RE NOT
DELIBERATING. ON THIS TODAY HOW
WE'RE GONNA SPEND THE MONEY AND
AGAIN. YOU KNOW MISTER. CHANG
IS PART OF OUR PROCESS THROUGH
THE STATE BUDGET CHAIRMAN MR
MEDINA AND I AND THE OTHERS. WE
WILL DECIDE WHICH PROJECTS ARE
FUNDED THE THEIR
RECOMMENDATIONS GO. TO THE
GOVERNOR TO MYSTERIES IN THE
GIVEN TO US. BUT THIS NOTION OF
A PLANNING I THINK YOU BROUGHT
UP A GOOD POINT TELL ITS IT'S-
MISTER. PHIL TAKES. I KNOW
YOURSELF BUT THE GERMAN TANKS-
SEVENTY ONE PROJECTS AT THREE
HUNDRED MILLION THAT'S LIKE
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS PER
PLANNING. WHAT ARE THEY
PLANNING I GUESS THEIR VISIT
YEAH I THINK. IS THE
FEASIBILITY OF IT THAT SHOULD
COSTS YOU KNOW TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO HIRE A
CONSULTANT IT SEEMS LIKE A LOT
OF MONEY. TO HIRING PEOPLE ARE
GONNA COME BACK AND SAY WE NEED
STATE MONEY TO BUILD THIS
PROJECT. IF IT'S IF IT'S IF
IT'S PLANNING BY. CONSTRUCTION
DRAWINGS AND WORKING DRAWINGS
AND DESIGN AND THAT THAT'S THAT
THAT'S WHAT WE DO FOR PROJECTS
BUT THIS IS LIKE. FEASIBILITY
PLANNING AND I CAN CURRER WE
DON'T WANT TO WASTE ALL THIS
MONEY. ON HIRING A BUNCH OF
CONSULTANTS FOR PROJECTS. AND
NOT REALLY GETTING. MUCH OUT OF
BANG FOR THE BUCK IN CONTENT
ACTUAL PROJECTS. AND THEN
SECONDLY FOR THE CONSTRUCTION.
YOU KNOW DO YEAH WE WOULD LOVE
TO FIND AS MANY OF THESE
PRODUCTS AS WE CAN BUT AS WE
SEE HERE. THIS TWENTY ONE
PROJECTS AND REQUESTED IS- ONE
POINT TWO- BILLION I'M I'M NOT
SURE IF THAT'S FOR FULL FUNDING
FOR EACH PROJECT AND I GUESS.
THAT'S ROUGHLY BY MASS RIGHT
YOU KNOW ROUGHLY- FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS PER PROJECT WHICH
SOUNDS LIKE SMALLER TYPE
PROJECTS AS OPPOSED TO HUNDREDS
OF UNITS PROJECTS SO. WE'LL
HAVE TO FIGURE THAT OUT TO IS
DO WE WANT TO FIND SOME ALL THE
WAY- LOOK AT THAT GAP FINANCING
AND PROVIDE. SMALLER TYPE
AWARDS TO FIND A MORE. MORE
ACTUAL PROJECTS. SO WE WILL
SORT THAT OUT IN THE COMING
MONTHS BUT OVERALL I THINK. YOU
KNOW THE BIG PICTURE 100% WE
CONCUR WITH YOU AND- MISS COSTS
THAT THAT WE THINK THAT IT
WOULD BE GREAT FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO GET IN
THE BUSINESS OF- PROVIDING MORE
STUDENT HOUSING. FOR FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND YOU KNOW HELP
THEM NAVIGATE THAT THE SYSTEM
AND GRADUATING TRANSFER GET
THEIR CERTIFICATE AND MOVE ON
TO SUCCESS IN OUR TIMELY MATTER
AND- AND HAVE LESS- LESS DEBT
LESS STRESS ON THEMSELVES SO-
THIS IS A CERTAINLY A PRIORITY
THIS IS I KNOW YOU SAY IS NEW.
TO TO THEIR COMMUNICATIVE AND
AS YOU SAID EARLIER WE HAVE
LOTS OF DISTRICTS TO THEIR OWN
OPINION SO IT'S NOT ALWAYS
CENTRALIZED THROUGH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE SO WE
UNDERSTAND THAT AS WELL. SO I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
QUESTIONS NUMBER QUESTIONS FOR.
MR TAKE. THIS ONE JUST ONE
QUICK SIMILAR TO SAYING THAT-
WE WERE VERY EXCITED TO SEE
TWENTY ONE APPLICATIONS COME
IN. AND HAVE TWENTY ONE
CAMPUSES THAT ARE. INTERESTED
IN READY TO GO SO I THINK THAT
THAT IN ITSELF IS A CAUSE IS
GREAT IN. JUST- ECHO MISS- YOU
KNOW MISS KOSTAS STATEMENT.
REGARDING PARTNERING WITH
EITHER C. S. USER USES WE THINK
THAT'S A GREAT IDEA. AS WELL
AND WOULD BE HAPPY TO. FIGURE
OUT HOW WE. CAN ENCOURAGE THEM
TO THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
FOR. OUR NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
WE I KNOW WE HAVE A TIME
CONSTRAINT AND HE'S PERSONALLY
CHEN ANYWAY SO WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM. OUR CHANCELLOR AT UC
SAN DIEGO CHANCELLOR KHOSLA.
AND THEN WE HEAR FROM
CHANCELLOR LEVY. AND THEN FROM
OUR PRESIDENT FROM- CSU
FULLERTON VERGY. FURNITURE
MCCARTY AND GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT OF THE U. S.
OF CALIFORNIA AND THANK YOU FOR
WORKING SO DILIGENTLY TO FIND
WHAT I THINK IS MUCH NEEDED
STERN HOUSING IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. I'M VERY PLEASED TO
SHARE THAT THIS FOG UC SAN
DIEGO OPENED A BRAND NEW LIVING
LEARNING COMMUNITY. WELL THE
NORTH TORREY PINES LIVING AND
LEARNING NEIGHBORHOOD. THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD IS HOME TO OUR
SIXTH CALL OF THE TWO THOUSAND
STUDENT BEDS IN ARTS AND
HUMANITIES BUILDING A SOCIAL
SCIENCES PUBLIC. BUILDING
ABSENT THE PROVIDES CLASSES
WORKSHOP AND STUDIO SPACE FOR
STUDENTS EMPLOYEES AND THE
PUBLIC IN A VARIETY OF MEDIUMS
SUGGESTS AROUND X. WOODWORKING
THE SURFBOARD SHAPING. YOU ALSO
HAVE UNDER CONSTRUCTION THE
THEATER DISTRICT AND LEARNING
LEARNING NEIGHBORHOOD WHICH
WILL ADD ANOTHER TWO THOUSAND
UNDERGRADUATE BETS WHEN IT
OPENS IN FALL TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THREE. HOWEVER WE ARE
VERY ANXIOUS TO BUILD EVEN MORE
ALL THE UC SAN DIEGO'S GREATLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S WORK TO CREATE A
GRANT PROGRAM FOR SOME HOUSING.
WE BELIEVE A PERMANENT
REVOLVING LOAN FUND BUT 0%
INTEREST RATE WILL ALLOW THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO
BUILD MORE ON CAMPUS HOUSING.
MAKES LOTS MORE AFFORDABLE AND
HELP PRESERVE DEBT CAPACITY OR
OTHER CORE MISSION CAPITAL-PROJECTS. LET ME GIVE AN
EXAMPLE. BUT EVERY HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS UC SAN DIEGO
RECEIVES AT 0% INTEREST RATE AS
PART OF THIS PROPOSED REVOLVING
LOAN FUND. IT WOULD GENERATE AN
ANNUAL DEBT SAVINGS OF TWO
POINT ONE MILLION WHICH COULD
BE DISTRIBUTED LET'S SAY THE
PROXY TWO THOUSAND STUDENTS.
TWO THOUSAND OF OUR MEDIA
STUDENTS. THIS FUNDING WOULD
NOT DISCUSS WHAT BETS BUT IT
WOULD ALSO ALLOW US TO REINVEST
THE SAVINGS INTO AFFRONT TO
PROVIDE UPWARDS OF SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION. OR THIRTY FIVE YEAR
PERIOD IN HOUSING AID TO
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.
UC SAN DIEGO ALREADY OFFERS
FROM HOUSING AT 20% BELOW
MARKET. BUT IN THIS EXAMPLE
WOULD BE ABLE TO OFFER AN
ADDITIONAL 18% DISCOUNT TO OUR
NEEDIEST STUDENTS AT RATES
NEARLY 38% BELOW MARKET. OR IN
ADDITIONAL COST SAVINGS OF
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
AND FORTY THREE DOLLARS PER
STUDENT THREE. THIS SCENARIO
WOULD ALSO CREATE HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE CONSTRUCTION JOBS
OVER A THREE YEAR PERIOD AND
THIRTY NINE PERMANENCE WITH SO
THE CUSTODIAL OF RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAMMING JOBS. ADDITIONALLY
IN TE STATE ALLOWED THE UC
SYSTEM OUR CAMPUSES TO MANAGE
THE FUNDS COULD BE FURTHER
LEVERAGED TO BUILD ADDITIONAL
BEDS OR DIFFERENT NATIONALS ON
HOUSING. BECAUSE AT THE END OF
THIRTY FIVE YEARS YOU WOULD
AGAIN HAVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS RECOVERED WE COULD HAVE
YOU HAVE. A COLOR DAHLE
PRINCIPLE THAT WE COULD
INVESTIGATE. SO AS YOU KNOW AND
RICH CAMP ON CAMPUS WILL
EXPERIENCE IS VITAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF OUR STUDENTS.
STRESSFUL LIVE ON CAMPUS HAVE
MORE TIME TO STUDY. EXPLORE
INTERESTS AND CONNECT. IN
SPACES SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED
FOR LEARNING AND DISCOVERY.
THEY HAVE MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO
INTERACT WITH FACULTY
RESEARCHERS AND COLLEAGUES.
THEY'RE MORE FOCUSED AND
ACTIVELY ENGAGED WITH THEIR
EDUCATION. ENJOY STUDY GROUPS
SO LOCALIZATIONS. AND MORE
EDUCATIONAL EVENTS AND DEVELOP
STRONGERPEER NETWORKS THESE
NETWORKS KEEP THEM MOTIVATED IN
SCHOOL AND PROMOTE LONG TERM
CAREER SUCCESS AFTER GRADUATION.
TO IMPROVE THE SLICK BEAR TO
IMPROVE THIS ONE EXPERIENCE AND
SUCCESS. UC SAN DIEGO IS
INTERESTED IN BUILDING SOON
HOUSING BECAUSE WE KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT AND IMPACTFUL LIVING
ON CAMPUSES. WE ALSO KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF MAKING HOUSING
AFFORDABLE AND ACCESSIBLE. UC
SAN DIEGO IS LOCATED IN THE
BEACH COMMUNITY OF LOCAL AREA
AND PROXIMAL OFF CAMPUS RENTALS
CAN BE COST PROHIBITIVE OR
SINCE. HOUSING MORE CENTRAL
CAMPUS AS MANY BENEFICIAL
EFFECTS AS I'VE ALREADY
MENTIONED. AS SUCH A GOOD FOR
ON CAMPUS HOUSING IS TO OFFER
BEFORE YOUR HOUSING GUARANTEE
TO UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS AT A
PRICE THAT IS AT LEAST 20%
BELOW MARKET RATES. AND TO
ACHIEVE THIS HOUSING GUARANTEE
WE EXPECT WE HAVE EXPANDED OUR
INVENTORY FROM ABOUT TWELVE
THOUSAND BEDS IN 201-321-8000
THAT'S TODAY. WITH A NET
INCREASE OF SIX THOUSAND BATS
AND WE ANTICIPATE CONSTRUCTING
AN ADDITIONAL TEN THOUSAND BEDS
IN THE NEXT SEVEN TO TEN YEARS.
THIS ALSO ALIGNS WITH THE
STATE'S REQUEST DO YOU SEE DO
YOU AGREES AND WROTE AND THIS
I'M AT THIS UNPRECEDENTED
GROWTH REQUIRES SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN INFRASTRUCTURE
AND FACILITIES AND IN
PARTICULARLY IN SOME HOUSING.
SO IN ORDER TO FINANCE A PHONE
HOUSING EXPANSION UC SAN DIEGO
WHERE THEY SHOULD THIRTY FIVE
YEAR BONDS AND TYPICALLY TWO
THIRDS OF ASSUMES THAT GOES TO
OUR STATE SERVICE I'M SORRY
HOUSING PROJECTS. ISSUING A
LOAN BONDS INSTEAD OF ENTERING
INTO PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS AS ALLOWED UC SAN
DIEGO TO KEEP COSTS DOWN
BURSTYN'S WATER MIND YOU WE
OFFER 20% BELOW MARKET RATES
BLOSSOMS. AND HOWEVER WE ARE
CLOSE TO GETTING A BED CAPACITY
LIMIT WHICH MEANS CAPITAL IS
QUICKLY BECOMING THE BIGGEST
BARRIER. TO BUILDING MORE SOME
HOUSING. UC SAN DIEGO ALSO FOR
FUN FROM THE NEW STATE PROGRAM.
FOR SALUTE HOUSING NEW HOUSING
TO PROJECT CULPEPPER CANYON
WEST. THIS NEW DEVELOPMENT
HOUSE THIRTEEN HUNDRED TRANSFER
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS WITHIN
STEPS THE NEW ON CAMPUS CRAWLEY
WHICH COMES ALL THE WAY FROM
SENATE SEAT ROW TO OUR CAMPUS.
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE AND I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
CONSIDER THAT A REVOLVING FUND
WITH INTEREST RATES AT 0% WOULD
EXPONENTIALLY INCREASE THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT IN SOME
HOUSING. THIS APPROACH DOES NOT
HAVE TO BE APPLIED TO ALL THREE
HAVE EDUCATION SEGMENTS IF THE
OTHER TO DO NOT FAVORITE. BUT
UC CAMPUSES WOULD GREATLY
BENEFIT AND BE ABLE TO BUILD
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE HOUSING THAN
ONE TIME FUNDING KEPT AWAY.
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY AND I
APPRECIATE AND I APPRECIATE
JEFF MCCARTY'S. AND THIS OF
COMMITTEES EFFORTS TO FIND
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO THE
CHALLENGES OF BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND CREATING
AND AFFORDABLE EDUCATION FOR
HIGHLY DESERVING CALIFORNIA
SINCE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
EPICNESS ABORTIONS. THANK YOU
CHANCELLOR BECAUSE LACK I
WANTED TO FOCUS ON THE-
REVOLVING FUND ISSUE- YEAH OF
COURSE MISTER PRESTON BROUGHT
THIS UP AND WE BROUGHT THE
BROWN'S PROPOSAL LAST YEAR WHAT
WOULD IT MATTER IF THE FIND.
WAS UC REVOLVING FIND VERSES
EIGHT. LET'S SAY CALIFORNIA
REVOLVING FUND. THROUGH LIKE
THE TRAGEDY CATCHERS ON US WHAT
WHAT WHAT WOULD THAT DO WHAT'S
THE DIFFERENCE OR DISTINCTION
THERE AND HOW IT IS IT'S GOT.
SO THE DISTINCTION- JIM MCCARTY
FOR US WOULD BE THE FIRST OF
ALL IT WOULD NOT MATTER FOR THE
FIRST ROUND BUT THE DISTINCTION
WHAT BEAT THAT OF THE REVOLVING
FUND AFTER THE FIRST ROUND IF
IT WERE MANAGED BY YOU SEE.
THEN YOU SEE WILL HAVE AGAIN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
INVEST AFTER WE DON'T COVER
THE- PRINCIPAL AMOUNT. IF IT
WAS N THE STATE AND THE STATE
WOULD HAVE THE MONEY TO INVEST
AND THEY COULD DECIDE HOW TO
BOOK SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
EITHER WAY IT INVOLVING FUND IS
A RIGHT ANWER. VARONA YEAH I
THINK IT'S JUST SOME LOGISTICS
IF WE DID HAVE. THE YOU KNOW
THE WILL TO DO IT DO WE DO
THREE OR WOULD YOU WANT SO WHAT
WE'LL HAVE TO KIND OF SORT THAT
OUT BUT I STILL THINK IT'S- THE
APPROACH THAT- THAT THAT WE
NEED AND- WE HAVE OUR- OUR
BUDGET CHAIR HERE LISTENING
AND- YEAH I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE PLENTY OF.
OPPORTUNITIES WITH ONE TIME
MONEY AGAIN THE BUDGET TO LOOK
AT CALIFORNIA PRIORITIES AND-
AND THIS IS ONE- AND THEN. IT'S
MISTY BESIDE THE REVOLVING FUND
YOU'RE STILL SAYING TO THAT
THAT- ARE YOU KNOW ONE TIME
APPROPRIATIONS TO BUY DOWN THE
COST OF THE PROJECT IS DESIRED
TO YOU OR IS YOUR FOCUS 100%
RECALLING FRONT. SOON MIGHT BE
YOU THE TW ARE SIMILAR. BUYING
DOWN THE CLUSTER PROJECT ONE
TIME. DOES NOT- HER SERVICE IT
IS IT DOES NOT HAVE A LONG VERY
LONG TERM IMPACT IF YOU TAKE
THAT ONE TYPE BY DOWN AND JUST
GIVE IT TO ME AS A AND LET ME
USE IT AS A LOT OF FUN WE WILL
CREATE AN IMPACT OF HIS TO THE
THREE X. MORE THAN WHAT YOU
HAVE TO. ANTICIPATED. YEAH WELL
AGAIN ALL CAMPUSES ARE
DIFFERENT AND WE'RE WE HAVE
LOTS OF OPINIONS HERE TODAY-
BUT WE HAVE WE HAVE A FEW A FEW
OPTIONS DIFFERENT OPINIONS FROM
EACH SYSTEM AS WELL. I THOUGHT
WE HAVE QUESTIONS FOR MR
CLOSELY MR MEDINA. CHANCER
CONSULATE THANK YOU AGAIN YES-
FOR HOSTING ME- THIS WEEK- AT
UC SAN DIEGO AND THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE THERE IS CERTAINLY
IMPRESSIVE- ESPECIALLY AS IT
RELATES TO STUDENT HOUSING BOTH
FOR GRADUATE STUDENTS AND
UNDERGRADUATES- I DON'T
REMEMBER- THAT WHETHER IT'S THE
FIFTH OR SIXTH COLLEGE THAT I
VISITED AND HAD LUNCH. BUT SIX
COLLEGE ST COLLEGE- WHERE YOU
WERE WHERE YOU HAVE BOTH
STUDENT HOUSING AND CLASSROOMS.
I IF I UNDERSTOOD CORRECTLY ON
TOP OF EACH OTHER IS THAT
CORRECT IN THE IN IN THE SAME.
IN THE SAME BUILDING. YES IT'S
AN INTEGRATED LIVING AND
LEARNING NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE
I'M A STRONG BELIEVER THAT
SEGREGATING CLASSROOM SPACES
FROM LEARNING FROM- HOUSING
SPACES AND FACULTY OFFICE IS A
MISTAKE. WELL I WOULD SHARE
WITH MY COLLEAGUES THAT THAT
WAS CERTAINLY EXCITING AND
SOMETHING VERY DIFFERENT THAT
I'D EVER SEEN BEFORE ON A
COLLEGE CAMPUS SO. I APPLAUD
YOU FOR THAT VISION. HOW WERE
YOU ABLE HOW WERE YOU ABLE TO
FINANCE THAT WHERE YOU'RE ABLE
TO MIX OUR CLASSROOMS BASE WITH
STUDENT HOUSING. SO WHAT WE DO
IS- WE FINANCE THE WHOLE
PROJECT WHAT WE ALLOCATE THE
HOUSING COSTS TO HOUSING AND
DINING AND THE CLASSROOM SPACES
AND THE ACADEMIC BUILDINGS I
HAVE PAID FOR WITH INTERNAL
FUNDS- WOULD ONE TANKS- SAVINGS
THAT WE HAVE ON OUR CAMPUS- AND
DONE SOME LEVEL OF BORING BUT
ALL INTERNALS. AND ALSO SOME
FUNDRAISING. THANK YOU AND ALSO
JUST A TO- YOU KNOW SAYING- TO
YOUR STAFF HOW FAR THEY'VE COME
FROM MY DAYS OF- GOING DOWN THE
CAFETERIA LINE WITH MY LUNCH
TRAY BREAKFAST TRAY HOW THINGS
HAVE CHANGED. THANK YOU. WE
SHOULD HEAR POSITIVE COMMENTS.
THANK MISTER TANK. JUST ACROSS
THE BAY SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE-
CAN YOU GIVE US A SENSE OF WHY
YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO BUILD BY
YOU YOU FELT THE MOST HOUSING
OF ALL THE- DIFFERENT CAMPUSES
AND I DON'T KNOW MAYBE PERHAPS
YOU INHERITED THE MOST HOUSING.
CAN YOU GIVE US A SENSE OF HOW
YOU WERE ABLE TO DO THAT AS AN
EXAMPLE FOR PERHAPS SOME OF THE
OTHER CAMPUSES OR EVEN ANOTHER
SOME OF THE SEGMENTS TO. LEARN
AS AN EXAMPLE. HELLO THERE'S
NOTHING THERE'S NOTHING ROCKET
SCIENCE ABOUT THIS WHEN I GOT
HERE. IT WAS CLEAR TO ME THAT
WE HAVE THE LAND MASS- IN THAT
IF WE WERE GOING O BE
IMPACTFUL TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE TO GROW AND
NOT COULD NOT BE JUST IN A
LEAD- EXECUTION. UP AND AT THAT
POINT TO A STRATEGIC PLANNING
PROCESS BEFORE MULDER DIVISION
FOUR FOUR YEAR HOUSING
GUARANTEE. FOR UNDERGRADUATES
AND PHCS WAS UP 20% BELOW
MARKET. AND THE BELOW MARKET
WAS BECAUSE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE FEDS WERE
GENEROUS ENOUGH TO GIVE US LAND
FOR FREE. AND TYPICALLY HOUSING
PROJECTS THE COST OF THE AND
IT'S 2230% AND I WANTED TO GIVE
IT BACK. TO THE CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA. GREAT THANK YOU
IT'S BEEN DONE- SO THE BIGGEST
YOU MENTIONED YOU HAVE A LAND
MASS OF. SO ONE OF THE
CONSTRAINTS IS DEFINITELY
ACCESS TO LANCE OF OTHER.
CAMPUSES WERE SAY MORE LAND
CONSTRAINED THAT WOULD BE A
CHALLENGE BUT IF THEY DIDN'T.
HAVE THAT CONSTRUED TO SHOULD
BE ABLE TO. FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
CONSTRUCT ON MORE HOUSING. YEAH
THAT'S ANOTHER POSSIBLE AND FOR
US- THIS LIGHT RAIL. CREATES
ANOTHER AMPLIFICATION BECAUSE I
CAN IMAGINE- BUT ALONG THE
LIGHT RAIL. WE COULD START-
BUILDING SOON HOUSING. NOT ONLY
DEVELOPED COMMUNITIES ALONG THE
AROUND THE LIGHT RAIL STATIONS
BUT ALSO CREATE ACCESS TO OUR
CAMPUS AND PRESERVE THE LAND
MASS HERE FOR ACADEMIC
PROGRAMMING. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THAT MOST IMPORTANTLY CUTS
CANCER BECAUSE THAT I TELL YOU
THIS PRIOR BELIEVE I'LL TELL
YOU PUBLICLY I THINK YOU'RE
DOING A FABULOUS JOB DOWN THERE
THAT YOU SEE SAN DIEGO- IN
DOING AN AMAZING JOB TO EXPAND
STUDENT HOUSING THERE I KNOW
IT'S DIFFERENT THEY'RE NOT A
LOT OF. AVAILABLE HOUSING IN LA
HOYA THAT'S AFFORDABLE FOR
STUDENTS AND SO YOU REALLY NEED
TO BUILD IT ON CAMPUS IT IS AND
NOW HOUSING AT ALL AND AS MR
TANG SAID- NIGHT AND DAY
BETWEEN THE LAND YOU HAVE THERE
FOR EXAMPLE BURGHCLERE LA YOU
KNOW THE OTHER CAMPUSES THAT
THAT HAVE THAT ARE THE MOST
SELECTIVE AT THE UC SEGMENT
BUT- YOUR ENTREPRENEURIAL
SPIRIT THERE AND FINDING WAYS
TO BUILD STUDENT HOUSING IS
NOTED AND- I WOULD LIKE TO
REPLICATE WHAT YOU DO AT SOME
RATHER- CAMPUSES SO THANK YOU
FOR BEING A GREAT EXAMPLE.
THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY COULD
NOT DO THIS WITHOUT THE STUFF
ESTO SUPPORT OF THE STATE THANK
YOU ARE LIKELY TO SHIP. OKAY
THANK YOU WILL NOW GO TO OUR
CHANCELLOR AT UC SANTA CRUZ.
AND I I'M NOT SURE IF I
PRONOUNCE IT BECAUSE OF THE
REEF. IT'S LEAVES. ACTING
TEACHER MCCARTY YES GOOD TO SEE
HELLO I WAS JUST DOWN THERE A
FEW- MONTHS AGO TALKING ABOUT
HOUSING SO IT'S GOOD TO HAVE
YOU TODAY WITH- OUR COMMITTEE.
AND YOU KNOW YOU DO HAVE A
LAND- SHORTAGE THERE AS FAR AS
YOUR CAMPUS AND CAN SCAN
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSTRAINTS SO
HAVING YOUR PERSPECTIVE IS VERY
HELPFUL SO PLEASE PROCEED. WELL
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TODAY
WE DON'T HAVE. I'M A LAND
SHORTAGE AT UC SANTA CRUZ BUT
WE DO HAVE MENTAL CONSTRAINTS
THAT I'M PLEDGE IT. AND THAT'S
TOPIC IS JUST SO IMPORTANT TO
ME. AND IT'S ONE I'VE ACUTELY.
FAMILIAR WITH SINCE BECOMING
CHANCELLOR AT UC SANTA CRUZ AND
JULY TWENTY NINETEEN. ECHOED
THE SERIOUS CONCERNS THAT HAVE
ALREADY BEEN RAISED ABOUT THE
ISSUE TODAY AND ALSO REINFORCED
THAT STUDENT SUCCESS. IT'S
RESULT FROM PROVIDING CAMPUS
HOUSING FOR STUDENTS WE SEE
THAT IN MANY WAYS. I KNOW YOU
UNDERSTAND THE CRITICAL NEED
FOR MORE HOUSING AND THE HIGH
COST OF WHAT'S CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE ESPECIALLY IN COASTAL
AREAS WHERE HOUSING COSTS ARE
AN INCREDIBLE BURDEN FOR SO
MANY PEOPLE. OUR STUDENTS
FACULTY AND STAFF ARE AMONG. IN
A RECENT STUDY 70% OF SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY RENTERS REPORT
BEING SPENT BURDEN WHICH IS
DEFINED AS SOMEONE WHO PAYS
MORE THAN 30% OF THEIR INCOME
ON RENT. BUT IT IS NOT ONLY A
MATTER OF COST HERE THERE IS
VERY LIMITED HOUSING STOCK
AVAILABLE FOR RENT OR FOR SALE
IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AT ANY
PRICE. AND THIS PROBLEM HAS
BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE LOSS OF
NEARLY A THOUSAND HOMES IN OUR
COUNTY IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
SEIZE THE WILDFIRE. THE UC
SANTA CRUZ CURRENTLY HOUSES
MORE THAN 50% OF OUR STUDENTS
THAT'S ONE OF THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGES IN THE UC AND CSU
SYSTEMS AND- WE'RE MOVING DIRT
RIGHT NOW ON A PROJECT THAT
WILL ADD NEARLY TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED BETS. AT ONE OF OUR TEN
RESIDENTIAL COLLEGE. WE HAVE
APPLIED FOR A SATE GRANT FUNDS
THAT WOULD HELP WITH ADD
HUNDREDS MORE. RECENTLY THE
BOARD OF REGENTS APPROVED UC
SANTA CRUZ'S LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN L. R. D. P.
ITS OWN LAND USE DOCUMENT THAT
OUTLINES HOW AND WHERE ARE
CAMPUS MICRO AND ACCOMMODATE
STUDENTS OVER THE NEXT TWENTY
YEARS. SO AS YOU PREVIOUSLY
HEARD IS THE SENATE GROUPS
COMMITTED AS PART OF THAT PLAN
TO HOUSE A 100% OF OUR
ANTICIPATED GROWTH IN
RESIDENTIAL STUDENTS. AS WE
HAVE THE NECESSARY CAMPUS LAND
TO ALLOW THAT DEVELOP IN THERE
SO LITTLE HOUSING AVAILABLE IN
THE COMMUNITY. THIS DECISION IS
NOT MEANT IN ANY WAY TO CAP
ENROLLMENT GROW BUT TO
FACILITATE ENROLLMENT GROWTH UP
TO TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
STUDENTS. TO SUPPORT THE
STATE'S ENROLLMENT GOALS. IT'S
ALSO MEANT TO REDUCE THE
CONSTRAINTS THAT WOULD LIKELY
ARISE THROUGH SETTLEMENT OF
LAWSUITS AS OCCURRED IN THIS
MOMENT OF LITIGATION ASSOCIATED
WITH OUR TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
HELLO KITTY. ONE AREA THAT WE
ALSO NEED THE STATE'S HELP WITH
GETTING FINANCING AND I AGREE
WITH EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT
GROSS GRAMMOND CHANCELLOR
KHOSLA. THE PROVIDING ACCESS TO
MORE CAPITAL MY STAB US IN A
LOT REVOLVING LOAN FUND WOULD
BE HELPFUL HOUSING ON OUR
CAMPUS AND THAT THE UC SAYS
FINANCED LARGELY THROUGH
STUDENT RANSOM. WELL THIS MODEL
WAS SUFFICIENT IN THE PAST THE
CURRENT NEED OUT CASES OROVILLE
BIT MAIL ABILITY TO FINANCE
LARGE PROJECTS ON THE TIME
FRAME WE NEED THEM. ALLOWING
YOU SEE TO UTILIZE STATE
CAPITOL CREATIVELY WOULD SERVE
ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES AND
STUDENTS. EXTERNAL FORCES THAT
HINDER DEVELOPMENT ON OUR
CAMPUSES ARE ALSO OCCURRING AT
THAT IS THAT WE FACE AS WE
ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS THE NEED FOR
STUDENT HOUSING. UC SANTA CRUZ
SPENT NEARLY FIVE YEARS OF
PLANNING CONDUCTING
ENVIRONMENTAL ANALYSES WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND SEEKING
APPROVAL FOR I WOULD
APPROXIMATELY THREE THOUSAND
BED PROJECT CALLED STUDENT
HOUSING WEST. THIS PROJECT WILL
ALSO ADVANCE OUR LONG STANDING
COMMITMENT TO SUSTAINABILITY
INCLUDES SOLAR PHOTOVOLTAICS TO
GENERATE ELECTRICITY AND SOLAR
THERMAL TO PROVIDE HOT WATER AS
WELL AS A WATER RECYCLING
FACILITY THAT WILL ALLOW THE
CAMPUS TO RE USE WASTE WATER
FOR NON POTABLE USES LIKE
FLUSHING TOILETS TOILETS AND
IRRIGATION. SO THIS STUDENT
HOUSING WEST PROJECT WAS
APPROVED TWO AND A HALF YEARS
AGO BY OUR REGIONS. BUT
LAWSUITS HAVE FAULTED IT IN ITS
TRACKS THE ORIGINAL PLAN
PROJECTED THAT WE WOULD HAVE
ALREADY COMPLETED THE FAMILY
STUDENT HOUSING PORTION OF THE
PROJECT. AND AN ADJACENT CHILD
CARE CENTER BUT ONGOING
LITIGATION MEANS WE HAVE YET TO
PUT A SHOVEL IN THE GROUND.
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY JUDGE IN
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY APPELLE
SEES DETAILED ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW OF STUDENT HOUSING WEST.
THE PROJECT UNDERWENT A
THOROUGH ANALYSIS UNDER SCORING
THE CAMPUS IS COMMITMENT TO THE
ENVIRONMENT. THE JUDGE DIDN'T
FIND ANY ISSUES WITH THAT YEAH
I ARE. BUT DID IDENTIFY SOME
FOR FREE PROCEDURAL ISSUES WITH
THE RICH GENTLE APPROVAL. THIS
PROCEDURAL MATTER HAS SINCE
BEEN CORRECTED. BUT OPPONENTS
CONTINUE TO CHALLENGE THE
PROJECT IN COURT. DELAYS THAT
SIGNIFICANTLY ADD EXPENSES TO
THE PROJECT. UC SANTA CRUZ HAS
BEEN A CHAMPION FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP AND
JUSTICE CENTS ARE FOUND. AND I
BELIEVE THE ENVIRONMENTAL AT
THE CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT SEQUEL IS ESSENTIAL
FOR ENSURING THAT PROJECTS AND
DEVELOPMENTS ARE
ENVIRONMENTALLY SUSTAINABLE AND
DON'T POSE A THREAT TO THE
ENVIRONMENT. SIX HAS BEEN IN
THE FIFTY YEARS SINCE SAID THAT
ITS ENACTMENT A FORCE FOR GOOD
IN CALIFORNIA AND MAINTAINING
ITS INTEGRITY AND EFFECTIVENESS
IS IMPORTANT. THE PUBLIC'S
ABILITY TO CHALLENGE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW OF FORMED
BY A PUBLIC AGENCY IS ESSENTIAL
TO WAS EFFECTIVENESS. BUT THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT SEQUEL
COULDN'T BE IMPROVED. IN MY
EXPERIENCE SEEK BUT CAN BE USED
BY OPPONENTS TO SERIOUSLY DELAY
OTHERWISE GOOD NEEDED AND
IMPORTANTLY ENVIRONMENT LEASE
PROJECTS LIKE OUR STUDENT
HOUSING WEST PROJECT. THIS
ULTIMATELY RAISES PROJECT COSTS
AND INHIBITS OUR EFFORTS TO
PROVIDE MORE VITALLY NEEDED
STUDENT HOUSING. THE IMPACTS
OUR ABILITY TO HELP BOTH OUR
STUDENTS. AND THE COMMUNITIES
WITH WHOM WE PARTNER SANTA CRUZ
IT HAS A HOUSING PRICES NOT
JUST FOR OUR STUDENTS BUT FOR
ALL OF ITS RESIDENTS. SO WE
NEED A BETTER MORE TIMELY MORE
TRANSPARENT PROCESS THAT WILL
ENSURE BOTH ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AND IN PORTABLE
HOUSING FOR CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. THESE ARE NOT
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE GOALS WE CAN
HAVE BOTH IF WE ACT TOGETHER TO
CAREFULLY. AND THOUGHTFULLY
REFINED THE PROCESS. SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME CONSIDERATION
FOR YOUR INTEREST IN THIS
PROJECT IN SUPPORT OUT OF
EDUCATION CALIFORNIA SO I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU CHANCELLOR IT AND
HIDE I KNOW SEEK WAS THAT IT
TOUGH ISSUE TO ADDRESS AND OUR
FORMER GOVERNOR. GOVERNOR BROWN
I THINK CALLED IT GOD'S WORK OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BECAUSE-
IT'S VERY LUCIFER- IT'S THAT
THAT BEING SAID SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT I THINK ARE IN OUR
MORE OF OUR- YEAH IMMEDIATE
CONTROL HERE FOR THE SPECIALLY
WITH THIS. SUBCOMMITTEE IS THE
FINANCIAL PIECE SO YOU WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE- REVOLVING FUND
ISSUE. THAT CHANCE R. COSTA
TALKED ABOUT. AN INDOOR THE
ISSUE OF. NO ONE TYPE STATE
MONEY TO BUY DOWN THE PROJECTS
WHAT WHICH IS WHICH IS THE
ISSUE THAT WOULD BE MORE
HELPFUL. TO YOU TO PRODUCE MORE
STUDENT HOUSING. FROM IT. SO
YOU YES THANK YOU SO I CAN SEE
A PLACE FOR BOTH SO ABOUT THE
GAP FUNDING OUT WE HAVE ALSO
APPLIED FOR THE STATE GRANT
PROGRAM AND THAT WOULD BE A
HELP FOR US PROVIDING THOSE
BEDS AS PART OF OUR CRESPI
RENEWAL CHECK OUT OUT OF. THE
QUICKTIME L. ESTABLISHMENT
THOUGH ABOUT ABOUT REVOLVING
FUND THAT'S WRITTEN INTEREST
WOULD BE A REAL LONG TERM
NGUYEN I THANK FOR STUDENT
HOUSING IT WOULD ALLOW US NOT
ONLY TO HAVE READY ACCESS TO
THAT CAPITAL BUT ALSO TO PASS
ALONG THE COSTS TO STUDENTS.
LIKE CHANCELLOR KHOSLA
DESCRIBED WE PROVIDE HOUSING ON
OUR CAMPUS BELOW MARKET RATES
AND THE ABILITY TO REDUCE THE
**** S. N. COSTS WOULD ALLOW US
TO PASS ALONG THOSE. COSTS TO
OUR NEEDIEST STUDENTS. A THANK
YOU QUESTION FOR CHANCELLOR
MISTER TAKE. THANK YOU FOR
OUTLINING THE CHALLENGES YOU'RE
FACING GOING THROUGH ON THE
SPIRIT THE PARTICULAR STUDENT
HOUSING PROJECT ON YOUR CAMPUS
SANTA BARBARA BERKELEY FACE
SOME OF THE TOUGHEST. AND
COMMUNICATION- CONSISTED
COMMITTEE ON THIS ROAD HOUSING
OR DEVELOPMENT KID CAN YOU HELP
US UNDERSTAND OR WHAT WHAT WE
WHAT HOW WE COULD HELP YOUR JOB
TAKE YOUR CAMPUS IN PARTICULAR
ALSO OTHER CAMPUSES ARE IN.
VERY IMPACTED AREAS BUT ALSO IN
IN AREAS WHERE THE COMMUNITIES
GENERALLY ARE POSING ANY KIND
OF DEVELOPMENT. WELL SO I ONE
OF THE REASONS THAT THAT WE AS
PART OF OUR LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN OUT HAD
PROMISED A HOUSE A 100% OF OUR
NEW ENROLLMENT. IT'S TO HELP
MITIGATE THAT THE CONCERNS OF
OUR CITY AND COUNTY ABOUT THE
IMPACTS O STUDENTS. ARE
ALREADY TIGHT HOUSING MARKET.
AND SO I THINK THAT THAT IS
THAT YOU KNOW THAT IS OURS ONE
OF OUR STRATEGIES UP I I'M NOT.
A LAWYER AND SO I THINK THAT IF
WE WANTED TO TALK ABOUT SECRET
STRATEGIES IT BETTER TO HAVE
THE LEGISLATOR CHAIR AND THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT WORK
TOGETHER. TO DEVISE SOME POLICY
STRATEGY THAT COULD BALANCE THE
GOALS FOR. PROJECTIONS AND
STUDENT HOUSING. I THINK THAT
IN TERMS OF OUR CAMP. AND IN
OUR RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE CITY
AND THE COUNTY DOES DOES NOT
HAVE HAVE GREATLY IMPROVED I
THINK OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS. OF MANY OF OUR CITY AND
COUNTY ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF BUILDING MORE
CAMPUS HOUSING BECAUSE THAT
WILL REDUCE OF THE DEMANDS ON
THE COMMUNITY. BUT THERE WILL
BE THOSE WHO WILL FILE LEGAL
CHALLENGES ROUTE REALLY
REGARDLESS OF THE PROJECT I
THINK REGARDLESS OF THE
BENEFITS TO THE COMMUNITY SO.
THAT'S PART OF THE CHALLENGE
THAT THAT WE FACE IN SANTA CRUZ.
IN SUCH AS RESULT A COME
COLLEAGUE- MISTER DONALD-
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO ENTER INTO
AN AGREEMENT TO BUILD HOUSING
FOR. INCREASED ENROLLMENT
BECAUSE- BASICALLY YOU'VE BEEN
UNABLE TO BUILD HOUSING DOES
THAT IN ESSENCE A FORCE YOU TO
CAP YOUR ENROLLMENT BECAUSE OF
YOUR INABILITY TO BUILD.
HOUSING DUE TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ISSUE. H. NO I
DON'T THINK SO I THINK THAT-
IT'S DELAYS OUR ABILITY
PALESTINIANS SO WHAT WHAT WE
HAVE NOW IS IN OUR CREST
PROJECT WE'RE ADDING SEVERAL
HUNDRED BELTS AS PART OF THE-
REVISION. THIS BIG PROJECT OUT
STUDENT HOUSING WEST I'M I
THINK WE'RE EVENTUALLY GOING TO
GET TO BUILD IT AYE I DO WORRY
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO AFFORD IT. ONCE IT
FINALLY CLEARS THE LEGAL
HURDLES IT HIGHLIGHTS FOR ME
THE NEED FOR OUR USES ACTORS TO
ALWAYS HAVE HOUSING PROJECTS IN
DEVELOPMENT. IF WE ANTICIPATE
THAT THAT TIMELINE IS THE
LENGTH OF THE PIE I DELAYS DUE
TO LITIGATION. IT MEANS THAT WE
SHOULD ALWAYS HAVE US SOME
PROJECT IN DEVELOPMENT SO THAT
THAT THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
DELIVER BAD IN A TIMELY WAY.
WANT TO DIMINISH AT IN OUR TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN. WE DID
RECEIVE A NUMBER OF LEGAL
CHALLENGES TO THAT PLANT.
INCLUDING FROM OUR COMMUNITY
GOVERNMENT AND AS PART OF THE
THAT COMPREHENSIVE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT THAT RISK. THAT
LITIGATION THE CAMPUS HAD
SIMILAR- DEMANDS A DEBT THAT WE
MET. FOR A GROWING HOUSING AS
WE GREW ENROLLMENT BUT ALSO THE
ENROLLMENT OUT TARGET CAP FOR
THE LONG RANGE DEVELOPMENT PLAN
WAS REDUCED AS PART OF THE
APPLICATION. AND SO THAT'S ONE
THING THAT WE'RE HOPING TO
AVOID OUT THROUGH THIS HOUSING-
COMMITMENT. TO HOUSE A 100% OF
STUDENTS IS. A GROWING TO
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND STUDENTS
WOULD BE MEAN ADDING. NINE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS
MORE THAN NINETEEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED. AND TO OUR TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE LONG RANGE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN. BECAUSE WE-
ARE REALLY COMMITTED TO ACCESS
FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ON OUR
CAMPUS. THAT WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT WE'RE
ABLE TO. ACCOMMODATE. ON OUR
CAMPUSES RESIDENTIAL. THE OTHER
HALF OF I JUST HAVE BE ON IS I
CAN'T I DON'T I CAN REALLY GROW
ENROLLMENT WITHOUT HOUSING.
WHERE WOULD THOSE STUDENTS LIVE
WE CAN'T BRING STUDENTS TO
SANTA CRUZ. AND THEN AND THEN
NOT HAVE A PLACE FOR THEM TO
STAY. THANK YOU CHRISTIAN OKAY
THANK YOU MR MEHTA. OKAY NO NO
NO MORE QUESTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
OKAY LAST BUT NOT LEAST WE'LL
HEAR FROM A REPRESENTATIVE FROM
THE CSU SYSTEM ON THE GROUND
PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE PRESIDENT
FOR J. THANK YOU. SO MUCH FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. WELL SAY THE
BEST FOR LAST NIGHT YET AND I
RUIN YOUR LAST NAME SO TELL ME
HOW YOU PRONOUNCE IT AGAIN.
BURJI VERGY VIRGIN HOTELS CLUB
GET THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RESIDENTS YES. WELL THANK YOU
TERRY MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF-THE COMMITTEE FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF CAL STATE FULLERTON WHICH IS
BY THE WAY THE MOST POPULATED
UNIVERSITY IN THE LARGEST
SYSTEM OF HIGHER EDUCATION IN
THE COUNTRY AND THE LARGEST
UNDERGRADUATE PROGRAMS. IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WE ARE A
UNIQUELY SITUATED THAT WAY
ALLEN'S PRESIDENT OF THE
INSTITUTION THAT SERVES MORE
PELL ELIGIBLE STUDENTS THAN
THAN PRETTY MUCH THE ENTIRE
IDEALLY COMBINED AND MORE FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS THAN ANY
pAM ALWAYS EXCITED AND HONORED
TO SPEAK ABOUT CAPACITY ISSUES
AFFORDABILITY ISSUES ACCESS.
ISSUES AND ISSUES OF STUDENT
SUCCESS. ALL THE HIGHER
EDUCATION STUDENT HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IT'S A POTENTIAL GAME
CHANGER. AND MUCH A MUCH
OVERDUE INVESTMENTS SINCE THE
STATE HAS NEVER REALLY INVESTED
DIRECTLY IN STUDENT HOUSING
BEFORE. IN DEVELOPING OUR CAL
STATE FORTUNE PHYSICAL MASTER
PLAN- WHICH WAS UNANIMOUSLY
APPROVED BY THAT- CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES LAST SUMMER WE
RECOGNIZE THE DATA THAT
PROVIDES THAT A STUDENT
RETENTION AND SUCCESS IS
DIRECTLY CORRELATED TO HOW MUCH
TIME STUDENTS SPEND ON CAMPUS.
AT PARTICULARLY FIRST YEAR
STUDENTS YOU'RE A CAL STATE
FULLERTON WITH OVER FORTY ONE
THOUSAND STUDENTS MORE THAN
HALF OF WHOM ARE FIRST
GENERATION. AND ONLY ABOUT
NINETEEN HUNDRED EIGHTY BEDS-
THE. IS NOT JUST IN THE
ARCHITECTURAL BLUEPRINTS IT'S
ALSO IN THE PROGRAMMING. THE
COMMUNITY BUILDING THAT HAS TO
UNFOLD IN THE SPACE IN WHICH
THE DORMS ARE LOCATED. THAT YOU
REQUIRES RESOURCES AND LIKE THE
BRICK AND MORTAR THE DATA TELLS
US THAT IT IS MONEY EXTREMELY
WELL SPENT BECAUSE THE RETURN
IS ONCE AGAIN HIGHER
PERSISTENCE AND GRADUATION
RATES AND LOWER EQUITY GAPS AND
THAT IS OUR GOAL- WITH ALL THIS
IN MIND- A CENTRAL PART OF
CASTING FORTUNES MASTER PLAN.
IS TO BUILD WHAT I CALL A
TWENTY FOUR HOUR CAMPUS
COMMUNITY NO LONGER DO WE WANT
TO BE KNOWN AS A COMPUTER
COMMUTER CAMPUS BUT A CAMPUS
COMMUNITY. IN ORDER TO DO THAT
THOUGH WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
INVEST IN MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR STUDENTS AND THE
KEY WORD THERE IS AFFORDABLE
LET'S BE CLEAR HERE ORANGE
COUNTY IS NOT AND AFFORDABLE
AREA TO LIVE FOR OUR STUDENTS
WITH THE COST TO RENT A TYPICAL
TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT BEING
MORE THAN THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH NOT INCLUDING
UTILITIES. I'M AYE OUR STUDENTS
ARE FACING ONE OF THE HIGHEST
RENTAL RATE MARKETS OF ANY
SERVICE REGION IN THE SYSTEM.
AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE NUMBER
THREE IN THE NATION FOR
GRADUATING STUDENTS FROM POOR
HISTORICALLY UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES AND WE HAVE MORE
THAN A THOUSAND STUDENTS ON A
WAITING LIST TO GET INTO OUR
STUDENT HOUSING SO THE NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR OUR
STUDENTS IT'S REAL ON OUR
CAMPUS AND IT'S STARK. ABOUT
HIS HOUSE PROGRAM ALSO HAVE TO
BE ELF SUPPORTING AS HAS BEEN
TALKED ABOUT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN. HE COST OF BUILDING AND
OPERATING THEM HAS TO BE
COVERED WITH THE FUNDS THAT ARE
GENERATED WE DON'T HAVE A
SEPARATE ONGOING FUNDING
SOURCE. TO SUBSIDIZE OUR
HOUSING SO I CAL STATE
FULLERTON WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO
HOUSING PROJECTS IN PROGRESS.
ONE OF THOSE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS IS OUR
PHASE FOUR PROJECT WHICH IS
AMENDMENT MCCARTY YES MA'AM
MCCARTY HAS SEEN. AND IS
CURRENTLY IN THE CONSTRUCTION
STAGE OF YOU DRIVE BY THE FIFTY
SEVEN FREEWAY YOU SEE IT
RISING. I'M IS MORE THAN HALF
CONSTRUCTED IT'LL BE COMPLETED
IN- AN ONLINE READY FOR
STUDENTS IN JUST ABOUT TEN
MONTHS IN AUGUST TWENTY TWO.
AND IT'LL ADD SIX HUNDRED BEDS-
TO OUR CAMPUS. THAT'S THE GOOD
NEWS BUT ONCE THAT PROJECT IS
COMPLETED THE CAMPUS WHAT WILL
BEGIN TO PHASE FIVE PROJECT.
WHICH WILL INCLUDE DEMOLISHING
THREE OUTDATED HOUSING
BUILDINGS THAT WERE BUILT IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY AND WHICH
CURRENTLY HOW STUDENTS THAT
HAVE- IN IN INTO THE FACILITIES
THAT HAVE EXCEEDED THEIR USEFUL
LIFE AND- WILL SOON FRANKLY BE
UNINHABITABLE DUE TO FIRE LIFE
SAFETY CODES ADA ISSUES AND ALL
FAILING UTILITY LINES. BY A BY
THE WAY AS A SIDE NOTE THIS
UNDERSCORES WHAT WAS TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING THE FUNDS NOT ONLY TO
CONSTRUCT NEW HOUSING BUT A
DRESS DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
BEFORE IT BECOMES SORT OF BIRD.
WHICH IS WHAT WE HAVE NOW THAT
IT'S CHEAPER TO KNOCK THE
BUILDING DOWN AND START OVER-
THE ELIMINATION OF THESE
BUILDINGS WELL A RACE ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE BEDS
LEADING US. AFTER THE FIRST
PROJECT DONE WITH ONLY TO LEARN
FIVE BEDS UNTIL WE COMPLETE
PHASE FIVE. AS I SAID BECAUSE
HOUSING IS SELF SUPPORTING THAT
THAT MEANS THAT THEY HAVE TO
PAY FOR THEMSELVES IT'S
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT
ANYTIME A CAMPUS HAS TO
ELIMINATE BANDS SUCH AS THE
ACTION THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE. THAT IMPACTS REVENUE FOR
HOUSING FOR OUR SELF SUPPORT
AND THAT'S RATHER DO THAT.
ULTIMATELY GOES DIRECTLY
TOWARDS SUPPORTING FUTURE
HOUSING PROJECTS. SO WITHOUT
ANY HELP TO OFFSET THIS LOSS OF
REVENUE WE HAVE LESS RESOURCES
TO PUT TOWARD SUPPORTING FUTURE
HOUSING PROJECTS. THAT'S WHY
THE STUDENT HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM THAT YOU ARE ARE-
HAVING THIS HEARING ABOUT HERE
IS SO CRITICAL IN MEETING THE
HOUSING NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS
WITHOUT THIS PROGRAM. THE
IMPACT THAT OUR CURRENT AND
FUTURE DEBT SERVICE WILL BE
SIGNIFICANT AND IT WILL MAKE IT
VERY DIFFICULT TO PURSUE OUR
HOUSING GOALS AND STILL PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO OUR
STUDENTS. I'M AS YOU HEARD IN
THIS ISN'T AN ISSUE OF THAT
CAPACITY BUT AN ISSUE OF MAKING
THESE PROJECTS PENCIL OUT AT
THE ND OF THE TO HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION PHASES. WILL HAVE
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED BEDS ON
CAMPUS. VERSUS THE NINETEEN
HUNDRED BEDS WE HAVE CURRENTLY.
pPLAN IS TO INCREASE STUDENT
HOUSING TO APPROXIMATELY FIVE
THOUSAND BEDS. AND AT LEAST ONE
OF THEM IS FUNDED THROUGH THE
STUDENT HOUSING GRANT PROGRAM-
OR THROUGH A REVOLVING- CREDIT
PROGRAM OR SOMETHING. THAT READ
WE WILL ALLOW US TO REDUCE- THE
COST OF THESE BEDS THAT WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY IN IT INCREASE
THE AFFORDABILITY- BY ALLOWING
US TO NOT WE OFFER BELOW MARKET
HOUSING NOW BUT MAKE IT. EVEN
FARTHER BELOW MARKET MAY MAKE
IT MORE AVAILABLE TO OUR
STUDENTS FROM UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. CAL STATE
FULLERTON HAS SUBMITTED BOTH OF
THESE PROJECTS FOR FUNDING
CONSIDERATION TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND IT'S
OUR UNDERSTANDING TO PHASE FIVE
PROJECT WILL SOON BE SUBMITTED
TO THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE FOR
FURTHER CONSIDERATION- GRANT
FUNDS FOR THESE PROJECTS WILL
HELP US NOT ONLY EXPAND
CAPACITY WHICH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. WE NEED TO EXPAND
CAPACITY HOUSING BUT ALSO
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING. TO
UNDER REPRESENTED- STUDENTS
FROM OUR LOW INCOME. AS THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE WELL- WORK ON SOLVING
THESE ISSUES THERE'S ANOTHER
CONTEXT TO WHICH- THE
CONSIDERATIONS YOU HAVE TO BE
VIEWED AND THAT'S THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF EACH RESPECTIVE CAMPUS
THIS WAS TOUCHED ON AS WELL FOR
EXAMPLE FOR A SMALL CAMPUS WITH
THREE OR FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS
ARE SIX HUNDRED BAD ADDITION IS
GOING TO BE TRANSFORMATIONAL IT
WOULD AMOUNT TO ABOUT 20%
INCREASE IN IN- HOUSING BUT ON
OUR CAMPUS SIX HUNDRED THAT
INCREASES. FOR HOUSING
OPERATIONS THEY THAT ACCOUNTS
FOR ABOUT 2% OF OUR FORTY ONE
THOUSAND STUDENTS NEARLY HALF
OF THEM ARE LOW INCOME SO AS WE
WORK TO MEET INCREASING DEMANDS
TO ADMIT EVEN MORE HIGH
ACHIEVING LOW INCOME STUDENTS
THAT WILL BE THE FUTURE OF OUR
WORKFORCE OUR NEED FOR PROGRAMS
SUCH AS THIS THE HIGHER
EDUCATION STATE HOUSING GRANT
PROGRAM THEY'RE ONLY GONNA
GROW. AND SO I A LOT HAS BEEN
SAID YOU'VE BEEN SITTING TO A
LOT OF HEARING I THANK YOU ARE
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR PROVIDING ME
OPPORTUNITY GIVE A BROAD
OUTLINE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
HERE CAL STATE FULLERTON AND IN
THE CSU- I COULD TALK ABOUT
THIS AT LENGTH BUT I WANT TO BE
SURE TO BE RESPECTFUL OF YOUR
TIME AND ALSO. BE ABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE. YES THANK YOU I DO
HAVE- SOME QUESTIONS FOR YOU
AND WE HEAR YOU LOUD AND CLEAR
ON ON YOUR REQUESTS FOR
RESOURCES IT'S VERY- IN LINE
WITH WHAT WE HEARD FROM A PRIOR
SPEAKERS AS WELL AS THE- THAT
THE SEGMENTS AND SO WORK WE'RE
GONNA RECAP THAT DISCUSSION IN
TWENTY. TWENTY TWO I WANTED TO
ASK- YOU KNOW. THAT MISTER
MARTIN I SPOKE A FEW MONTHS AGO
TO ARE SICK TO YOUR COUNTERPART
HERE AT SAC STATE. AND THEIR
THEIRSYSTEM THEIR CAMPUSES
LET'S SAY IT'S THIRTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS RIGHT OR RIGHT AROUND
THERE. THEY SAID THEY HAVE I
THINK IN HERE IT SAYS THEY HAVE
LIKE. TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED OR
SOMETHING- THAT HOUSING BEDS ON
CAMPUS THREE THREE THOUSAND.
AND THEN THERE'S ABOUT SEVEN
THOUSAND THAT WERE BUILT.
ADJACENT TO THE CAMPUS BY THESE
PRIVATE DEVELOPERS- WHICH ARE
GOOD AND BAD THERE WAS A REPORT
THAT MR TANG GROUP JUST
RECENTLY. PASSED SIX SHARED
WITH SOME OF THESE OPERATORS
AND CAMPUSES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. ARE LIVING UP TO THEIR
YOU KNOW TO THEIR BEST TO SERVE
STUDENTS AND YOU KNOW THERE.
MANY TIMES THESE FOR PROFIT ALL
OTHER IF THEY ARE FOR PROP THE
MANY TIMES IN THEIR- OWN BY
THESE. MAJOR REITS WHO ARE
FOCUSED ON OUR Y. AND TAKING
CARE THEIR SHAREHOLDERS. SO
THOSE DO SERVE. A ROLE IN IN
STUDENT HOUSING IN SOMEBODY'S
AREAS. THAT THE CHARTS ARE
AFFORDABILITY. SOME OF THEIR
SON THEY'RE MORE EXPENSIVE MOST
LIKELY MORE EXPENSIVE ON CAMPUS
BUT ACTUALLY IN SOME OF THE
CAMPUS IT SAYS HERE. THAT ARE A
LITTLE BIT LESS EXPENSIVE. SO
TO QUESTIONS- ARE YOU SAYING
MANY OF. THAT MUCH OF THAT IN
AROUND. I KNOW OWES A LOT.
RIGHT AROUND HERE IT'S- YEAH
THERE A LOT OF THAT AROUND FOR
TEN AND IN YOUR PRIOR. AS THE
GENERAL COUNSEL FOR CSU. DO YOU
SEE IT YES IS THAT A TREND THAT
WE SEE AROUND CSU CAMPUS THREAT
CALIFORNIA FULLERTON AND
ELSEWHERE. I THINK YEAH-
INSULIN MCCARTY WE TALKED ABOUT
THIS A LITTLE BIT WHEN YOU WERE
HERE ON CAMPUS. THERE'S A
REASON WHY- THEY WERE
DEVELOPERS THAT ARE PRODUCING
HOUSING DEPARTMENT HOUSING
DEVELOPMENTS OFF- OFF OF THE-
CAMPUS. AND THAT IS BECAUSE
THEY THEY SEE THE DEMAND. FOR
THAT HOUSING AND THEY BELIEVE
THAT THEY CAN- MAKE IT A YOU
KNOW AS YOU SAID THESE ARE
PROFITABLE AND ENTERPRISES THIS
IS NOT A NON PROFIT SO THEY
BELIEVE THAT IT IS. NOT
FINANCIALLY VIABLE FOR THEM TO
DO THIS- THERE THERE ARE- OFF
CAMPUS AND PRIVATE DORMITORIES
AROUND CAL STATE FULLERTON AND
ACTUALLY THE CITY OF FULLERTON
IS IN THE PROCESS UP. RIGHT NOW
WELL CONSIDERING- I NEW
PROJECT- RIGHT OFF OFF OF
CAMPUS. THERE'S A BIG
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THOSE- THE-
AT AND THEY SERVE THEIR
PURPOSE- THERE IS WE HAVE. A
NEED FOR HOUSING IF WE DIDN'T
HAVE THOSE OFF CAMPUS PRIVATE
HOUSING FOR PROFIT HOUSING-
FACILITIES WE WOULDN'T BE ABLE
TO. HOUSE STUDENTS. BUT THEY
ARE TRADITIONALLY AND I'M I'M
MOST OF THE TIME MORE
EXPENSIVE. AND IN FACT THERE
ARE ONE OF OCT PARATROOPERS AND
THERE'S A PROGRAMMING
DIFFERENCE REMEMBER I SPOKE.
ABOUT THE- THE S. PERSISTED OF
STEW ON CAMPUS SIX AS ARE. IN
GRAD RATES AND LOWERING EQUITY
GAPS. THERE'S A LOT OF
PROGRAMMING THAT GOES ON IN
RESIDENTIAL LIFE ON CAMPUS AND
THAT DOES NOT GO ON. ANY
ANYWHERE THE TO THE SAME DEGREE
THE SAME QUALITY OFF CAMPUS.
AND SO WE ARE WE ARE FOCUSED ON
PROVIDING. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ON OUR CAMPUS BUT WITH GREAT-
PROGRAMMING THAT GOES WITH IT
THAT YIELDS THE DEMANDS THAT WE
NEED TO SEE AN ORDER TO-
JUSTIFY THAT HOUSE. YEAH AND
THEN I KNOW YOU UC'S ARE
DIFFERENT AND THEN SEE ISSUES
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE OVERALL
CAN'T HOUSING AT THE UC SYSTEM.
IT LOOKS LIKE THAT THEY'RE
PROVIDING ENOUGH HOUSING FOR
ABOUT HALF OF THEIR OVERALL
UNDERGRADUATE SAID. AND IN CSU-
I THINK WAS LIKE YOU KNOW A
QUARTER AND THEN COMMITTEE
CALLS ARE LIKE 1% IT YOU KNOW
THEY'RE VERY DIFFERENT SINCE
SEGMENTS. BUT WHICH WHEN WE
SPOKE TO THE PRESIDENT'S THEIR
LEADERSHIP AT SAC STATE THEY'RE
SAYING ROUGHLY AT THIS CAMPUS
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. AND AGAIN
IT'S NOT APPLES TO APPLES THEY
WERE SAYING THAT THERE IS A
FORMULA THAT THAT THE EXPERTS
SAID THAT YOU NEEDED TO HAVE
HOUSING FOR ROUGHLY. A THIRD OF
YOUR STUDENTS EITHER ON CAMPUS.
OR ADJACENT TO CAMPUS. AND SO
AT SAC STATE THERE'S TWO
THOUSAND- THERE'S ROUGHLY TWO
THOUSAND ON CAMPUS HOUSING
UNITS IN LIKE I SAT AROUND
CAMPUS WITHIN A MILE THERE'S
ABOUT EIGHT THOUSAND BETS AND
THE MAJORITY OF THEM HAVE BEEN
BUILT THE LAST TEN YEARS I
THINK. ALL OF THEM LAST- TEN
YEARS ME 90% LEASED. SO THAT'S
SET UP THE PHONE ON THERE AND
IT HERE AT IT SAYS FOR YOU AT
FULLER TEN. YOU HAVE ROUGHLY
TWO THOUSAND ON CAMPUS- THE
DADS AND YOUR FORTY THOUSAND
CAMPUS SO DO YOU HAVE IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU DON'T HAVE A LOT. OF
FOR PROFIT HOUSING. AROUND ARE
NOWHERE NEAR THAT NUMBER TO GET
TO THE A- THE FORM. THAT A
THIRD AT YOU KNOW HOW FOR A
YEARS TO. WITH AND LISTEN THEY
CAN AREA. I'M NOT I WILL AS
ACTUALLY BUT- I WOULD ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION WAY I'M I HAD
CURIOSITY WITH TO THIS AS WELL
BECAUSE CSU'S HAVE IN A REMOTE
OF THE C. ISSUES HEADQUARTERS
BEEN KNOWN AS COMMUTER CAMPUSES
WHERE STUDENTS COME AND GO TO
SCHOOL AND LEAVE AND THERE'S
BEEN A TRANSFORMATION OF MOST
OF OUR CAMPUSES TO BE MUCH MORE
COMMUNITY DRIVEN CAMPUSES WHERE
STUDENTS- EXPERIENCE THE%
UNIVERSITY CO CURRICULAR EARLY
AS WELL AS IN THE CLASSROOM
BECAUSE WE SEE THAT THE
BENEFITS OF THAT. SO I ASKED ON
THE TO DO TO DO A STUDY OF
WHERE OUR STUDENTS LIVE THAT
COMES MORE CAMPUS 50% OF OUR
STUDENTS WE HAVE FORTY ONE AND
A HALF THOUSAND STUDENTS 50% OF
OUR STUDENTS LIVE EITHER IN OUR
ZIP CODE WE ARE PRETTY MUCH OUR
OWN ZIP CODE OR IN ONE
EDUCATION ZIP CODE RIGHT NEXT
TO US. SO WE HAVE ONLY TWO
THOUSAND BEDS ON CAMPUS THERE'S
PROBABLY ANOTHER THREE OR FOUR
THOUSAND BEDS- ADJACENT TO THE
CAMPUS AND THEN STUDENTS LIVE
IN WHICH IS WHY WE NEED
STUDENTS HOW SOON HOUSING THEY
SHOT THEMSELVES INTO APARTMENTS
AND- HOUSES AND ANYTHING THEY
CAN GET. WITH TOO MANY PEOPLE
IN NOT GOOD CONDITIONS AND
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR STUDENTS
FROM UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
WHO CAN ONLY AFFORD TO THAT-
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE BY CORRECT CREATING
MORE HOUSING ON CAMPUS THE
DOUBLE EFFECT OF PRODUCING
QUALITY HOUSING FOR THEM THAT
THEY DESERVE AND NEED AND THE
PROGRAMMING AROUND IT SO THAT
THEY WILL PERSIST AND TO
GRADUATION I THINK THAT ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION. YEAH IT SO IT IS
THAT A OUGH FORMULA THOUGH THE
30% IT IS NOT A GOAL FOR
EXAMPLE FULLER TENDED DO YOU
WANT TO HAVE A GOAL THAT YOU
HAVE ENOUGH. ON CAMPUS HOUSING
OR RELATIVELY CLOSE THE WHAT
LET'S SAY WALKABLE HOUSE YOU
COULD WALK TO CAMPUS FROM THE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT FOR A THIRD
OF YOUR STUDENTS OR IS THAT
JUST SOMETHING THAT SACRAMENTO.
WAS DOING ON THE ROAD. I THINK
IT'S A GOOD ROUGH- THUMBNAIL
BUT I BUT IT ALSO IS TO DEPEND
ON THE- AND SOME TALKED. I I
THINK IT WAS- UC SAN DIEGO OR-
THAT AVAILABILITY OF LAND CAL
STATE FULLERTON DOESN'T HAVE
THE LAN- AND NOT ONLY DO WE NOT
HAVE THE LAND- THE- WE ARE
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF A VERY
DENSE URBAN AREA. SO IT WOULD
BE GREAT TO HAVE A FIFTY
PERCENT- IT RATHER THAN A THIRD
BUT IT'S PROBABLY NOT DOABLE
OUR GOAL IS TO GET TO FIVE
THOUSAND BEDS ON CAMPUS. WHICH
WILL CREATE A CRITICAL MASS ON
CAMPUS ALLOW US TO INCREASE
SUBSTANTIALLY THE NUMBER OF
FIRST TIME FRESHMEN. OR FIRST
TIME COMMITTEE COLLEGE TRANSFER
STUDENTS THAT COME TO CAMPUS
THAT ARE ON CAMPUS BECAUSE THAT
IS WHERE WE THINK WE CAN HAVE
THE GREATEST IMPACT. AND THEN
WELL WE ARE WE WOULD BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO SEE A MORE
PRIVATE DEVELOPMENT OFF CAMPUS-
BUT WE WILL. YOU KNOW WHAT WE
CAN CONTROL. IS WHAT'S GOING ON
ON CAMPUS. THANK YOU I
QUESTIONS MISTING MISTER TANK.
IF YOU HAD YOUR YOUR- IF YOU
HAVE THE FUNDS HOW MUCH CAN
CAMPUS HOW MUCH HOUSING CAMPUS
WOULD YOU WANT TO BUILD. I'M
SORRY I COULDN'T HEAR YOU IF
YOU HAVE THE FUNDS HOW MUCH ON
CAMPUS HOUSING WOULD YOU WANT
TO BUILD THIS IS A GOOD WOULD
BE FIVE THOUSAND WOULD BE MORE.
WELL OUR MASTER PLAN WHICH WE
JUST GOT APPROVED BY THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES CALLS FOR FIVE
THOUSAND. I MEAN THAT IS. WHEN
WE ONLY HAD TWO THOUSAND BEDS
ON CAMPUS THAT IS THE-
ASPIRATIONAL GOAL. I THINK WHAT
WE WOULD WANT TO DO IS GET TO
FIVE THOUSAND CREATE THAT
COMMUNITY- THAT SORT TWENTY
FOUR HOUR ON CAMPUS- A LIFE
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR AND
THEN- A SCALE UP FROM THERE. AS
AS WE GROW AS A CAMPUS. ARE
YOU. AS BEING THE LARGEST CSU.
I THINK THERE'S GOING TO BE A-
A CHANGE AS WE COME BACK FROM-
VIRTUAL LEARNING- TO A- BOTH A
HYBRID KIND OF. RELATIONSHIP
WHERE WE HAVE STUDENTS ON
CAMPUS AT DIFFERENT TIMES
DURING THE DAY. SO I THINK FIVE
THOUSANDS WHERE WE'RE HEADED
RIGHT NOW. GREAT HE YOU'D
MENTIONED YOU'RE HAVING TO TEAR
DOWN BUILDINGS THAT WERE BUILT
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY. CAN YOU
GIVE US A- UNDERSTANDING OF
WHY. THEDEFERRED MAINTENANCE
WASN'T TAKEN CARE OF OUT OF
RESERVES. BECAUSE TRADITIONALLY
IF YOU. IF YOU'RE BRINGING IN
INCOME YOU'D SET ASIDE PART OF
THEIR INCOME. FOR RESERVE SO.
YOU COULD DO YOUR MAINTENANCE
ANNUAL. SELL I WILL A QUESTION
A COUPLE OF WAYS FIRST OF ALL
WE DO SET ASIDE SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT FOR MAINTENANCE OF OUR
FACILITIES AND- WE HAVE A LOT-
THAT'S THOSE ARE THE BUILDING
TO BE HAVE TO TEAR DOWN IS
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED THREE HUNDRED
BEDS- AND WE HAVE. AS I SAID
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND AS THE REST
OF THEM ARE MUCH NEWER AND-
HAVE BEEN KEPT UP QUITE WELL-
THE- WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WITH THIS BUILDING THAT WOULD
BE THAT THAT'S THAT WERE BUILT
IN THE NIGHT. IN EARLY NINETEEN
EIGHTIES IT'S LIKE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES EIGHTY FIVE OR EIGHTY
FOUR I'M IS THE USEFUL LIFE OF
THOSE BUILDINGS HAS JUST THEY
JUST WORN OUT. THERE
SEISMICALLY UNSAFE THE BONES OF
THE BUILDINGS THE HVAC AND THE-
AND THE PLUMBING AND THEIR
MULTI STORY- HAS ROTTED AND
DECAYED TO THE POINT WHERE THE
USEFUL LIFE OF THE BUILDINGS IS
OVER AND NO AMOUNT OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE- WOULD HAVE. TAKING
CARE OF THAT ISSUE THEY THEY'VE
JUST. THE USEFUL LIFE OF THE
BUILDINGS AS OVER AND THEIR
SEISMICALLY UNSAFE SO WE NEED
TO TAKE THEM DOWN- BUT- WE
DEFINITELY PAY GREAT ATTENTION
TO THE ISSUE- EXTENDING THE
LIFE OF OUR- ALL OUR BUILDINGS
ARMENIA MOST OF THE BUILDINGS
ON THE CAMPUS THE ACADEMIC
BUILDINGS THEY HAVE. BUILT IN
THE NINETEEN FIFTIES NINETEEN
SIXTIES NINETEEN SEVENTIES SO
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IS
CONSTANTLY AN ISSUE. THAT WE'RE
PAYING GOOD ATTENTION TO. RIGHT
THE- BUT THE APARTMENT BUILDING
OF THIRTY FIVE YEARS THAT IS
NOT A USEFUL LIFE SO WAS IT
BECAUSE THE ORIGINAL PROJECT
WAS JUST POORLY CONSTRUCTED WAS.
NOT MAINTAINED OVER ITS THIRTY
FIVE YEARS TO MEAN THE BUILDING
SHOULD LAST MUCH LONGER THAN
THIRTY FIVE YEARS IF IT'S
PROPERLY BUILT AND- PROPERLY
MAINTAINED. YEAH I THINK IT'S A
COMBINATION OF THINGS- YOU KNOW
YOU CAN THAT BUILDING CODES
WERE VERY DIFFERENT BACK THEN
FOR- SEISMIC REQUIREMENTS AND-
THE- YOU KNOW I WAS NOT THERE
WHEN THAT BUILDING WAS BUILT SO
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE- SPECS
WERE BUT I IMAGINE. THEY WOULD
BE COMPLETE COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT TODAY BUT AS WE'VE
GONE AS WE'VE GONE IN TO. DO
THE REPAIRS FOR THAT THE THAT
BUILDING AND WE COULD WE'D WE'D
LOOK AT DOING THE REPAIRS
COMPLETELY REPLACING ALL OF THE
PLUMBING AND HVAC AND
RETROFITTING IT FOR SEISMIC THE
COST OF DOING THAT EXCEEDS THE
COST OF TEARING IT DOWN TO
BUILDING A NEW BUILDING. THAT'S
THE REAL ROUTE THERE WE COULD
FIX THE BUILDING. AND WE COULD
HAVE THESE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
BEDS IN THE OLD BUILDING THAT
IS SAFE AND WE CAN MODERNIZE
THE BUILDING BUT IT WOULD COST
MORE TO DO THAT THAN TO TEAR
DOWN AND BUILD A NEW BUILDING
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BILL. NOW
UNDERSTAND I JUST I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE- LEARNING
THOSE TYPES OF LESSONS I
REPRESENT A CITY. WE HAVE
PLENTY OF BUILDINGS IN OUR CITY
THERE OVER A HUNDRED YEARS OR-
SO AGAIN- HERE WE'RE WE'RE
GIVING OUT THIS GRANT MONEY.
WHAT I WOULD HOPE. I SAID IT
SOUNDS LIKE BOTH WHAT HAPPENED
WAS POOR CONSTRUCTION AND POOR
MINUTES SOUNDS SOUNDS LIKE.
BOTH OF THOSE THINGS. HAPPENED-
SO. IF YOU DON'T THE BLACK OF
PREVIOUS BEEN A- BUT THERE'S NO
THAT A- SHOULD NOT LST MORE
THAN. THIRTY FIVE YEARS I DON'T
CARE- YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
BUILDING GO TO TALK ABOUT
NINETEEN EIGHTY BUILDING CODE
SO. I HAVE TO BUILDING HAS
BUILDING PROTECT EVOLVED.
THEY'RE PLENTY OF BUILDINGS IN
THERE PLENTY OF APARTMENT
BUILDINGS BUILT IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE THAT. ARE FINE.
TOTALLY FINE. I AND MANY
MEANINGFUL TO SO SOUNDS LIKE
AND IT WAS. YOU KNOW SOME
PEOPLE FELL ASLEEP AT THE WHEEL
AND DIDN'T TAKE CARE OF THIS.
THE LAST THING WE WANT IS MONEY
IN THE GRANT PROGRAM TO GO TO.
APARTMENT THAT AREN'T BILL WELL
AND AREN'T TAKING CARE OF. SURE
ABSOLUTELY YEAH I. AND I HAD
SORRY TO INTERRUPT PRESENT
VIRGIN MEMBER CHIANG IF I COULD
I WOULD HAVE TO CONFIRM OF THE
FOUR FULLER TEN IF THIS IS THE
CASE BUT IN THE EIGHTIES
RELATED TO THE EIGHTY FOUR
OLYMPICS BOTH CAL STATE LA CAL
STATE DOMINGUEZ SENATE MAY BE
THE SAME AT FULLERTON. THERE
WAS HOUSING BUILT FOR THE
OLYMPICS AND IT WAS WOOD FRAME
AND NOT THE BEST CONSTRUCTION
WENT UP PRETTY QUICKLY AND BOTH
CAL STATE LA AND TO MAKE A
CELLS WOULD LIKE TO REPLACE
THEIR HOUSING THAT CAME IN WITH
THE OLYMPICS AND IT MAY BE
THAT- THE FULLER TEN HOUSING
PRESIDENT VIRTUES MENTIONING IS
THE SAME SO WOOD FRAME NOT
GREAT CONSTRUCTION SO WE WOULD
AGREE ON A PERCENT ON A BETTER
CONSTRUCTION COMMONSENSE THAT
SOUNDS LIKE THOSE ARE THREE.
BUILDINGS BUILT PERHAPS FOR
TEMPORARY GAVE THANKS FOR WHAT
YOU WERE BILLED WITH. A
TEMPORARY HOUSING IN MIND NOT.
LONG TERM HOUSING- I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT ANY MONEY.
THAT'S BEING USED AT THIS FROM
THE STATE FROM THE GRANT
PROGRAM. IS NOT GOING TO BE
BUILT FOR HOUSING THAT'S ONLY
GOING TO LAST FOR. THIRTY FIVE
YEARS. AT MIDNIGHT IT IS A
CHALLENGE FOR US ESPECIALLY
THOSE CAMPUSES THAT. MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO- CHARGE THE RENTAL
RATES TO FORWARD STAY A STEEL
FRAME BUILDINGS SO WE HAVE
ENDED UP WITH SOME WOOD FRAME
BUILDINGS FOR STEEL. AND
CERTAINLY THE LONGER TERM WOULD
BE A PRE CAST FACILITY WHICH IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO FORT SO I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT AND
THAT'S KIND OF REFLECTS THE
ECONOMICS BELT CAMPUSES TRY TO
BALANCE WITH THE- THE RATES AND
THE LOCAL MARKET. AND THE OTHER
THE OTHER PIECE THAT I WOULD
SAY SOME WOMEN AT CHIANG IS
THAT THEY THE GOOD NEWS IS-
WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF OUR
CONSTRUCTION OF OUR FACE FOR AS
I SAID WHICH S A BUILDING THAT
IS- STATE OF THE ART AND- WELL
HAD AND WHAT WE'RE LOOKING TO
DO IS REPLACE THIS OLD-
BUILDING THAT. AS I SAID IS
UNSAFE WITH EXACTLY THE SAME-
TYPE OF BUILDING SO THE QUALITY
OF THE CONSTRUCTION AND THEY
DEL USEFUL LIFE WILL BE MUCH
LONGER. YOU SHOULD I JUST I
JUST WANTED TO NOTE THIS POINT
JUST BECAUSE- ON. HOW WANT TO
BE SURE THAT WERE. YOU KNOW
INVESTING IN THE FUTURE WE'RE
NOT JUST YOU KNOW PORN DOWN.
POUR MONEY DOWN THE DRAIN.
EXACTLY RIGHT THAT'S WHY WE
THAT WE KNOW WE LOOK AT
RENOVATING THIS THIS BUILDING
AND IT JUST DIDN'T MAKE SENSE
TO DO IT. FOR THAT EXACT
REASON. KNOWN UNDERSTOOD BUT I
THINK THE- THE QUESTION IS WHY
DID IT MAKE SENSE TO BUILD IT
THAT WAY IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE. THAT'S THE QUESTION. SURE
THANK YOU. WELL AS THEY BUILD
HOUSING FOR THE NEXT LA
OLYMPICS MAKES FOR THE BILL
THAT FOR THE- FOR THE FIFTY
HUNDRED YEAR WELL. THANK YOU I
THINK OF NO IT'S NOT A TWO YEAR-
WE APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS THAT CERTAINLY HELPS
US WITH OUR DELIBERATION ON
THIS ISSUE. IN THE COMING YEAR
SO THANK THANKS TO ALL THE
PARTICIPANTS FROM THE UC CSU
INCOMMUNICADO SYSTEMATICALLY
NOTED HERE BY THE LARGE
PARTICIPATION IN A FROM OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- HOUSING AND
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY COLLEGE
ACCESS IS THAT. TOP TOP
PRIORITY FOR CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
OF US YOU KNOW THESE THINGS GO
HAND IN HAND. I THINK THAT'S
WHY YOU SAW US TO TAKE- A KIND
OF A RARE STEP IN IN IN DELVING
INTO THE STUDENT HOUSING-
FINANCIAL ISSUE FROM FROM THE
STATE BUDGET PERSPECTIVE AND SO
WE THINK IT'S AN APPROPRIATE
PLACE TO BE AND WILL BE BACK AT
IT AGAIN. NEXT YEAR AND- FIVE
SPECIALLY FINE TUNING THESE
THESE THREE YEARS OF ONE TIME
FUNDS TO MAKE SURE WE GET OUR
BIGGEST BANG FOR THE BUCK AND
WE WILL COME BACK TO THE PUZZLE
NEXT YOU'RE LOOKING AT THAT
REVOLVING FUND ISSUE- SO WITH
THAT WE WILL NOW. GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IF ANYBODY IS IN THE
AUDIENCE TO SEE WE HAVE ONE
INDIVIDUAL HERE. I'M IN THE
AUDIENCE AND THEN ANYBODY WHO
WANTS TO PARTICIPATE. VIA THEM.
VIA THAT TELEPHONE- PUBLIC
COMING OPPORTUNITY CAN DO SO BY
CALLING ONE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. 977-692-8957 THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
TWO ZERO TWO. ACCESS CODE. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL. WE'RE GLAD YOU'VE
CONVENE THIS HEARING STUDENT
HOUSING IS CRITICAL FOR THE
SUCCESS OF STUDENTS ENROLLED AT
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
HOWEVER. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
EDUCATIONAL NON COLLEGE BOUND
APPRENTICES IN OUR STATE
APPROVED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS IS ALSO CRITICAL.
THEIR EDUCATIONAL CAREERS NOT
IN CLASSROOMS HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS BUT ON JOB SITES
WITH THEIR HANDS. AND ALL TYPES
OF WEATHER AND THEY ARE PAID A
LIVING WAGE WHEN THEY'RE
LEARNING. THE PROJECT
ENVISIONED TODAY SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED CALIFORNIA BASED
CONSTRUCTION WORKER LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS PROVIDING THESE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS TO
CONSTRUCTION WORKER FINANCES
WHO ARE BUILDING PROJECTS TO
HELP COLLEGE BOUND STUDENTS TO
LEARN. AS A POLICY WE SHOULD
ALL EMBRACE. TO MAKE THESE
PROJECTS WORK FOR THE WORKERS
AND APPRENTICES BUILDING THEM.
WE ASK THAT YOU ENSURE THESE
PRODUCTS ARE COVERED BY THE
PREVAILING WAGE. AND A SKILLED
AND TRAINED WORKFORCE IS
REQUIRED TO BUILD THESE
PROJECTS. DOING THIS WILL
ENSURE THESE BROTHERS ARE BUILT
RIGHT THE FIRST TIME SAVING
MONEY. AND IT WILL INSURE THE
JOB SITES ARE PROVIDED FOR
APPRENTICES CURRENTLY IN THE
SYSTEM HELPING THEM JOURNEY
THROUGH THEIR FINISH OF
QUICKER. OPENING UP A PRESS
LOTS FOR FUTURE PURPOSES. THESE
REQUIREMENTS FINALLY WILL.
PROTECT NOT ONLY THE JOURNEY
MANY WOMEN ON THESE PROJECTS.
BUT CREATE A LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT FOR CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY STUDENTS. THE
APPRENTICES. ARE PROJECTS BEING
BUILT FOR YOU SEE CSU AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY
MODERATE DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON
THE LINE. AND LADEN JUDGMENT
COULD LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. AT THIS
TIME WE DO HAVE ABOUT SIX IN
OUR QUEUE OKAY THANK YOU. AND
WE'LL START WITHLINE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE LINE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT ON MUTE.
MOVED TO LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT YES HELLO YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU. YES HELLO MY
NAME IS KIANA AFTER HE AND I'M
A STUDENT AT UCSD I'M CALLING
TO CONVEY MY CONCERNS ABOUT THE
MUNGER PROJECTS CURRENT DESIGN
ULTIMATELY I HOPE TO SEE A
REDESIGN BECAUSE I'M WORRIED
THAT SINGLE WINDOWLESS ROOMS%
WOULD BE A RISK TO STUDENTS
WELL BEING AND A THREAT TO
SOCIABILITY AND COMMUNITY. I
HOPE TO SEE YOU SEE IS THE
ADDRESS CONCERNS AND ENSURE
THAT THIS PROJECT IS GOOD FOR
STUDENTS OVERALL. THANK YOU
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. NEXT WE'RE
GONNA LINE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE YES HELLO WE CANARIA.
HELLO MY NAME IS NADIA AND I'M
THE UCSB STUDENTS CO CHAIR OF
THE COMMISSION ON DISABILITY
EQUALITY I'M CALLING TO EXPRESS
MY CONCERN THE CURRENT DIVIDED
AMONG THE DORM PROJECT HOPE IF
YOU'LL BE DESIGN UNIFORMITY A
SINGLE PAYER HOUSING UNITS
CONCERNED BECAUSE OUR CURRENT
COUNT IS HOUSING FACILITIES
ALREADY POST LIMITED OPTIONS TO
DISABLE THE FIND ACCESSIBLE
HOUSING THE CIVIC NEED A
CURRENT DESIGN IS DOCTOR A
VARIETY OF. THE OF DIFFERENT
CAN TYPES WITHIN A SYSTEM OF
MOVING THIS CALL WILL TALKED
ABOUT THE FOR MORE AND BUILDING
STUDENT HE'S AKC EACH BE PAID.
ONE KNOW HOW TO GET IT FOR THE
FIRST FLOOR AT THE BLUEPRINTS
IN THE- ERA BACK YOU WERE JOHN
WHAT THE PROBABILITY NEEDS TO
AT HE THAT THE SHOULD BE TO USE
THE UP ELEVEN FLOOR EVENTUAL
PRESIDENT AT THE TWO MAY
ENTRANCE NOT A GOOD CHOI ENTRY.
THE ONLY OF THE EIGHT AWKWARD
SIX P. OF THE I WOULD THE
PROPER IF REGARD THE PARKING
EVEN THOUGH THE EIGHT EIGHT AND
WITH SECTION EIGHT ZERO ABOUT
ONE GUIDELINE THE RECORD BUT
BLOWING. THE BLUEPRINT DOORS
WITH NO MENTION AT THE END OF
OUR UNIT DOORS OR BASED LARGE
TABLE IN THE KITCHEN AND STUDY
SPECIES PROVIDE USER FLEXIBLE
THE COMMUNITY OF STAGE AREN'T
AS SOMEONE WHO'S ALWAYS GOT TO
GO I THIS BOATS THANK FOR YOU
IF THAT MAKES SENSE OF. COULD
ISOLATE SPEEDING I HOPE YOU SEE
JUST. NO POLICIES THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE SIXTEEN HOPE THESE GUYS.
HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. I
THANK YOU- HI MY NAME IS ALEX
NILES I CURRENTLY SERVE AS THE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS CHAIR FOR
THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION I AM
ALSO SENDING YOU SEE SANTA
BARBARA- I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR MAKING THIS TIME
AND FOR PRIORITIZING HEARING
SOON HOUSING- YOU KNOW I A
RESIDENT LISTA. MYSELF AND MY
NEIGHBORS WE KNOW BETTER AS
WELL AS ANYONE- HOW URGENTLY WE
DO NEED ADDITIONAL HOUSING
HERE- WHAT THE COSTS AND JUST
THE LACK OF CAPACITY AND WE
WANT TO SEE SOMETHING BILL
WHERE THE MUNGER PROJECT IS
PLANNED BE WHAT THIS BILL
WITHOUT DELAY- BUT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS. AND OUR GOAL OF
STUDENTS IS TO ENGAGE IN THIS
PROCESS TO KEEP THOSE TOP THOSE
CONCERNS. IN THE CONVERSATION-
SHE WORKED WITH THE ACTUAL
DESIGNERS TO KNOW THAT THE
BASS- SOLUTION TO THESE
CONCERNS AND UP IN THE FINAL
DESIGN BALANCING ALL OTHER. YOU
KNOW- ANY OTHER CONSIDERATIONS
THAT NEED TO BE MADE. AND DON'T
WANT TO SEE THIS PROJECT
DELAYED WE DON'T WANT TO STOP
THIS PROJECT. BUT AS YOU KNOW
HOW YOU KNOW WE HAVE WE'RE NOT
CERTAIN THAT THIS IS THE BEST
BALANCE THE BEST OUTCOME FOR
STUDENTS AND FOR THE UNIVERSITY
AS A WHOLE. SO WE HAVE TO KEEP
THE SAME PERSPECTIVE SENATE'S
CONVERSATIONS AND- WE HOPE-
YEAH I GET THE BEST. HOUSING
RESULTS FOR YOU SEE S. B. AND
EVERYONE INVOLVED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT BIGGER PLEASE.
NEXT NEXT IS NUMBER EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS DR TRACY LOVE AND I
SERVICE THE DEAN OF THE COLLEGE
OF GRADUATE STUDIES AT SAN
DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY. THE
PROGRAM THAT YOU'RE CONSIDERING
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO POSITIVELY
IMPACT ONE OF SDSU'S
POPULATIONS THAT'S OFTEN
OVERLOOKED DURING DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT CRITICAL NEEDS ARE
GRADUATE STUDENTS WHO LIKE OUR
UNDERGRADUATE POPULATION NEARER
REGIONAL DEMOGRAPHICS. ARE
GRADUATE STUDENTS HAVE A
CRITICAL ROLE IN OUR
UNDERGRADUATE EDUCATIONAL
MISSION AND THEY STRONGLY
SUPPORT OUR UNIVERSITIES
RESEARCH MISSION. ONE MONTH AGO
SB ISSUES ECONOMIC CRISIS
RESPONSE TEAM WAS CONTACTED BY
A GRADUATE STUDENT WHO WAS
INVOLVED IN A VOLATILE DOMESTIC
ABUSE SITUATION. POLICE TOLD
HER TO LEAVE HER HOME BEFORE
HER HUSBAND WAS RELEASED FROM
CUSTODY. THIS FIRST GENERATION
STUDENT HAD NOWHERE TO GO AND
DIDN'T HAVE THE FUNDS TO RENT
AN APARTMENT IN TRANSIENT CAL.
OUR GRADUATE STUDENTS HAVE
DIFFERENT NEEDS THAN THOSE OF
OUR UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS AND
WE SHOULD BE PROVIDING AT THE
VERY LEAST AFFORDABLE HOUSING
OPTIONS TO HELP MEET THOSE
NEEDS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK. THANK YOU NEXT BIGGER
PLEASE. NEXUS NUMBER ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS JAY
STREET ART- MY COLLEAGUE SPOKE
EARLIER MARK VIA ARE FIFTY
STUDENT AND I'M THE GENDER AND
SEXUALITY EQUITY OUTREACH
COORDINATOR FOR THE ASSOCIATED
STUDENTS COMMISSION ON
DISABILITY EQUALITY I WOULD
LIKE TO ECHO MIGHT- COMMENT ON
LONGER HAUL- AND CONTRAFECT MY
CONCERNS WITH THE CURRENT
DESIGN OF THE LONGER TERM
PROJECTS AND HOPE TO SEE A
REDESIGN- YEAH. I WANT TO AND
THE THAT CRITICAL AT THE STANDS
NOT PROVIDE I'LL FOR THE OF
DIFFERENT FAMILY COULD. OF
INEFFECTIVE AND LIVING
STRUCTURE. ALSO DISABLED. AND I
CAN THINK INFRASTRUCTURE LAST
WEEK ACCOMMODATION AND MARKETS
WILL EXACT THE LACK OF SLEEP.
RATHER THAN THAT AT THERE ARE
NO HOUSING UNITS ON THE FIRST
AGAIN AND ONLY EIGHTY RAMPS THE
END. BILL AND THE BLUEPRINT DO
NOT THE PRESS OF THEIR VACUUM
JERRY TO LAST. MOBILITY TO MAKE
THE AND FRANKLY FROM BUILDING
SO THEY CHOOSE UTILIZE THE
MINUTE THE AMENITIES ON THERE
ARE FLOOR- THE ONLY MENTION OF
THE EIGHTY AND ALL FORTY THREE
PAGES OF THE NOTICE PEPPER. I
READ THROUGH THE ENTIRE THING
MY- WERE IN THE TO. AND THE TO
READ PLAN FOR DISABLED HE- THAT
I FIND- FOR NEED PARA QUE A
COUNTRY. ABOUT LIVING. HOUSING
AND EVERY HOPE SEE A REDESIGN.
I'M ACUTELY ILL OF THE LACK OF
HOUSING HERE- MANY OF MY
FRIENDS OF COURSE MAKES- YEAH.
HAVING QUITE AND ARE LIVING A
HOTEL- AND I BELIEVE THE NEED-
AND IS HOUSING. HOWEVER IT'S ON
A- TO ME THAT THE- OF MUNGER
HALL AND DOES NOT PRIOR TO THE
PEOPLE. AT LEAST. EIGHTY THREE.
A NEXT GO TO LINE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO- MY NAME'S CALLED
MURDOCH CAMPUS SURE OF THE
UNITS. AND YOU DAVIS WHO IS
EXPRESSED MY APPS. OPPOSITE TO
MY HOW USES BARBARA- I WOULD
LIKE YOU TO FILL YOUR YOU NEED
TO DEFEND AND EVERY WHICH-
ESPECIALLY EUROPE YEAR WHEN YOU
SYSTEM MOVES FURTHER AWAY FROM
STUDENT PRIORITY AND TOWARDS
THEIR OWN PRIORITIES. WITH
REGARD TO PREFIX THAT TO THIS
BILL THE AFTER PRO IN HORROR.
AND IT'S ABSOLUTELY. THAT THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS ON THE
COMMITTEE. DID NOT VOCALLY.
OPPOSED THE BUILDING PLANS WHEN
THE UC REPRESENTATIVES WERE IN
FRONT OF THEM. THE FACT THAT
YOU TEAR MCCARTY DID NOT USE
YOUR PLATFORM TO FORCE THE
ISSUE REPRESENTATIVES HAND
TODAY DANCER THE HORRID
CONDITIONS IN PLANS OF MUNGER
HALL. WHEN STUDENTS ARE GOING
TO BE FORCED INTO ROOMS WITH SO
CALLED VIRTUAL WINDOWS AND THE
RESPONSE TO THE WINDOW RESPONSE
QUESTIONS FROM ELECTED
OFFICIALS WHAT ABOUT THERE
WOULD BE LARGE BEAUTIFUL
WINDOWS AND COMMON AREAS. YOU
DISAPPOINTED IN YOURSELF AND
KNOW THAT STUDENTS ARE
LISTENING TO YOUR RESPONSES TO
BE ELECTED OFFICIALS. AND TO
THE UC SYSTEM. SO SPECIFICALLY
AND YOU SANTA BARBARA IT'S GOOD
FOR PLAN. THANK FOR THE
PRIORITIZE OF HOUSING. NEEDED
DESPERATELY NEEDED BY STUDENTS
ACROSS ALL UC CAMPUSES. COVERED
IS NOT CONSIDERED HOUSING WHEN
STUDENTS ARE FORCED INTO THESE
RANGE WITH TERRIBLE CONDITIONS.
OF THE LEGISLATURE EXPRESSING
THEIR CONCERNS OVER THE
CONSTRUCTION PLANT THAT THEIR
NEW PLAN PUT FORTH. SEPARATE
TOP RIGHT FOR PRIORITIZE THE
STUDENT HOUSING BUT ALSO PUT
STUDENTS MENTAL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING. AT THE FOREFRONT OF
THESE PLANTS. I THANK YOU FOR
THAT YOUR THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME AND I HOPE YOU TAKE THIS
INTO CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
NEXT BAKER PLAY. AT THE TIME WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE
OKAY I THINK YOU THIS THEY'LL
CONCLUDE A PUBLIC COMMENT I'LL
JUST NOTE THAT- THIS UC SANTA
BARBARA STUDENT HOUSING ISSUE
IS NOT ON OUR AGENDA IS NOT IN
OUR PURVIEW- YOU KNOW FRANKLY
HAD THIS HEARING BEEN TWO WEEKS
AGO WE WOULD NEED TO BE
BRINGING THIS UP. IT IS
CERTAINLY AN INTRIGUING HOT
ISSUE THAT WE ALL READ ABOUT I
THINK WE HAVE SOME IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS BUT THIS IS 1100% TO
BE ADDRESSED- APPROPRIATELY AND
FRANKLY BY LAW BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
REGENTS AS IT HAS ZERO
OVERSIGHT WITH THE- CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE- A REPRESENTATIVES DOWN
THERE- PROBABLY HAVE OPINIONS
AND THEY'LL I'M SURE. VOICE
THEM TO THE- TO THE UC REGENTS
WHEN THEY DISCUSSED THIS AT
THEIR PUBLIC MEETING COURAGE
YOU AS AS YOU KNOW TO VOICE
YOUR- COMMENTS QUESTIONS AND
SUGGESTIONS AND IDEAS THERE AND
I THINK MY OPINION AS I SAID
EARLIER IS I THINK THAT WE NEED
MORE STUDENT HOUSING AT OUR UC
CAMPUS ESPECIALLY SANTA BARBARA
IN FULL SUPPORT. OF HAVING FOUR
THOUSAND PLUS NEW BEDS THEY'RE
BUILT AT THIS SITE AND-
ENCOURAGE- THE- UC SYSTEM IN
THE AND THE CAMPUS TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE SURE IT'S
A WIN WIN FOR EVERYBODY SO. IT
THIS IS A PROCESS ENCOURAGE
EVERYBODY TO KEEP PARTICIPATING
IN THAT PROCESS AND ENGAGE YOUR
LOCAL. REPRESENTATIVES EARLY
<c.magenta>OUNT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER- MEMBER.</c>
HAS OUR SENSE MEMBER DOWN THERE
HAS NAME OF SAID. A PLAN THAT I
MICROBIT BRAIN FOG- BUT- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
TODAY EVERYBODY THANK YOU.